foreign
foreign
welcome everybody it is an incredible
day this is day 10 of the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial the defense has rested
the prosecution made its case first and
today we are going to see arguably some
of the most interesting elements of this
case starting number one with the jury
instructions given to the jury by the
judge as to the legal basis on which
they are to decide you have to compare
the actions of the defendant to some
legal standard if I say to you was
something self-defense the first
question should be what is self-defense
defined as in the law jurors I served
with on a jury on a self-defense case
didn't seem to understand that
um uh but that is what is go so we're
and there was much disagreement on
Friday about what the instructions
should be they have over the weekend
finalized that and we're gonna hear the
instructions from the judge uh today
that's number one
um number two oh wait a second I put
some of these elements on the wrong spot
let me see if I can fix this
give me a moment here I have some new uh
judge elements as well
audio stuff uh let's see where's my
soundboard judge here we go ah okay here
we go I'm gonna play these for you in a
little bit
um so so we're gonna hear from that and
then we are going to get right into
closing statements I believe the order
is going to be closing statement from
the prosecution closing statement then
from the defense and then a rebuttal
from the prosecution the judge is
allotting two and a half hours to each
side total for the defense it would just
be up to two and a half hours for their
closing statement for the prosecution
that two and a half hours has to contain
the closing statement and the rebuttal
okay so that's the plan today
um a bunch of different things to go
over Steve Bannon has just surrendered
to the FBI he is being arrested Steve
Bannon has been um indicted for contempt
because he ignored two subpoenas from
the Trump Riot committee here's video
from 15 minutes ago breaking news into
CNN Steve Bannon the former president
Trump senior advisor has now appeared at
the FBI field office here in the
District of Columbia to turn himself in
this following his indictment on two
counts of contempt of congress look at
this this is just moments ago and there
you see him arriving at the FBI field
office
I really would like to see that smirk
wiped off of bannon's face and I don't
mean somebody hitting him I mean it
would be great if that stupid smirk was
wiped off by actually having some legal
consequences to the things he's done
this indictment let's watch these
pictures as it happens
[Music]
I like the coup plotter sign in the
background what are your plans now
all right
[Music]
okay so it seems like he says something
we couldn't hear it let's see if there's
a close-up of that
uh
do we have any close-up of that
maybe not yet here's a second video
of attention just seconds ago Steve
Bannon arrived at the courthouse on his
way to surrender to the FBI after being
indicted for defying a subpoena from
Congress he is set to appear in A
District Court later today you can't see
him right here you can just see that
gray hair behind those cameras look at
him he's not rushing past them to walk
inside what is he like this media
attention martyring himself from Maga a
smile on his face as he said to
surrender so I think that Stephanie
Rule's voice she also noticing that
stupid smirk
um so there it is let's see if we have
anything any other closer in video
thank you
all right nothing there
okay
we're taking down every day the focus
we've got Rahim to Sam today you got Dr
Peter Navarro Captain Bannon you're
going to have uh Boris Epstein the whole
show is he promoting his show when as
just as he's getting arrested intense we
got pulling out economic data out
everything I want you guys to stay
focused in your message remember signal
not noise this is all noise wow uh can
you imagine can you imagine this is he's
promoting his show as he's getting
arrested so there's that
um and we're standing by for all of it
very very strongly and uh that's all I
mean it's crazy what's going on all
right I have a few new memetic elements
for you guys and okay so first of all
the judge as many of you know oh yeah
why do people think I'm not going to do
super chats I'll get to Super chats
there's just no super chats right now
everybody relax so I have a bunch of
different soundboard elements that small
fuzzy Moss sent me now from the judge in
The Written House case last week we had
the following whatever you do think
right by the way how are the calzones
the food is here let's take a break
lunch is here uncharged piccolos pizza
is here in fact we have Subway tomorrow
okay I have a few others now I have four
additional elements all right enjoy your
lunch
all right how was the KFC very good huh
KFC yeah warm food
warm food that's the best one maybe
around
warm food around noon noon is actually a
Hebrew letter that could be a that could
be a he might be referring to the letter
nun
um that is let me hear that one one more
time
around
noon that is something else huh
that is something else
um Okay so we've got that now a couple
of other things that I have here is an
Obama related thing that one of our
viewers made Let's see if people like
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pretty good
uh okay and then we also have an
historic new song from Jethro Bradley I
was worried Jethro Bradley had retired
but Jethro is back with an Obama song
this is an original song guys okay
[Music]
God bless
[Music]
Obama
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yeah the flute in the background is
maybe the best comedic element
[Music]
okay so that's really strong and then
lastly we're just standing by for the
start of the trial guys everybody relax
I do have a mango remix for you guys as
well check this out
[Music]
I love mangoes too
say okay
okay now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it this is good
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango ES
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow what an incredible
I don't even know what to call it
composition
um
you know in most jobs you might have
like TPS reports dot XLS here this is a
work file this is Lulu featuring diamond
and silk and Deepak bag of mangoes.mp4
that is a little bit of insight into
what I have going on so we're going to
get back to those because people are
just starting to connect to the stream
it's very very early we're going to
review those a little bit later and
there is a lot a lot a lot coming
forward people saying super chats aren't
working they are it's just that the
first few are are up so they don't show
up but I'll read it anyway David sends a
super chat from Britain
or the UK or England not sure which one
sir do you think the judge will still
try to play both defense and judge today
or will he pickle Lane also have you
seen my wife I actually know where your
wife is Sir your wife is up in the air
exactly
um no the judge the judge is completely
um uh cartoonish in many different ways
by the way the new thing now is that the
Stephen Kenneth Destiny Bonnell the
second Community is attacking me for my
view of the judge
go away guys come on it's it's getting
so boring
um
okay
so that's that Charlotte says Dave I
work for a politician have been watching
your stream in the background had to log
off from laughing so hard at the remix
as many confused faces thanks for all
you do well I apologize Charlotte uh
Charlotte also uh in the UK or Britain
or England
hard to know exactly which one oh so I I
made an agreement with everybody that I
was going to darken the mustache over
the weekend which I attempted to do
it didn't like it's a little darker I
got some of the beard Coman Just For Men
stuff it's only marginally darker I'm
kind of disappointed with the quality of
it so if I have time today in order to
stick to the promise I made I'll keep
trying to darken it I'll get other
things but
I'm just not it's just it's not a great
product I guess oh and I shouldn't even
say it wasn't necessarily Just For Men
it's it's I got a product I got a
product I don't want to disparage
anything in particular but I got a
product to darken the mustache
um
and uh yeah so um just so everybody
remembers let's go Brandon does get you
banned this is the seventh person I'm
Banning for that just this morning
um
there we go okay Have you listened to
opening arguments take on the trial no I
haven't I haven't listened to anything
guys I'm just I'm just too busy
producing my show Dave uh David I agree
Kyle is likely to get off on the
homicide is there a realistic chance he
serves jail time for the lower level
charges I think there's about a 15
chance that he does any jail time
um and in fact let me ask you people in
the chat
do you think that there will be any
guilty verdicts that's question one and
do you think Rittenhouse will serve even
a day of jail or prison time let me know
in the chat I want to hear from people
okay let me know in the chat
um and if you want to send a Super Chat
by all means but I'm not requiring that
I'm not requiring that just let me know
in the chat
um let's see here another let's go
Brandon ban that person's band
um
let's see what oh there's just a lot of
people to ban it's I can barely even
keep up with the band hammers it's it's
kind of sad
okay good all right we've got that very
good so again if you're just joining us
today is in a sense it is the absolute
last day of the trial we are about to
hear jury instructions from Judge
Schroeder uncharged piccolos then we
will hear the closing argument from the
prosecution closing argument from the
defense and then a rebuttal from the
prosecution and then they will be off
and running into
um uh deliberating now I'm gonna make a
request of you guys right now as soon as
it is announced that there is a verdict
please let me know
info davidpackman.com or however
I'm going to be doing my best to keep up
the verdict could be today they might
deliberate an hour they might deliberate
three to four and come back with a
verdict it could take a week we don't
know I want to carry the verdict live
we're this far in we're on day 10 in a
row really 11 if you include jury
selection
um oh sorry I gotta keep Banning people
here man I can I can barely even keep up
um
hold on a second
another band that's number 12.
and hold on 13
um
okay
there we go
uh another let's go Brandon ban
it's it's we've never had to ban people
at the rate at which we're Banning them
today it's crazy
it's really crazy
uh okay so the point is let me when
there's a verdict announced usually they
give us at least an hour they give media
an hour
and um
and hopefully they will do that today
all right good uh I really want to just
very briefly mention before I continue
with super chats and also voicemails are
pouring in and they're starting any
second here uh please get memberships on
my website we are still banned from
twitch last Monday I received a 30-day
ban from twitch for showing a portion of
the trial that was graphic
um we are banned for 30 days I've
appealed it the the appeal hasn't even
been adjudicated yet I'm told it's in a
queue so I have no idea uh when that's
gonna happen I'm hoping it'll be reduced
to a week which would get us back on
today they haven't even adjudicated it
yet so
um we lost a thousand paid subscribers
on Twitch we're seven days in 23 days to
go
please sign up on my website
joinpakman.com we do have a very special
coupon code that will only go as long as
the trial and the the code is uncharged
pickles uncharged piccolos and you can
use that code at joinpakman.com also
anyone who signs up today via patreon
it'll count double okay first person to
sign up today is Kevin gouldy using the
code uncharged piccolos and Kevin is new
member number whoa oh my god get help
with notepad that's not what I want
uh new member number one today there it
is number one at joinpakman.com
and we are about to start this is the
final day the final day of the trial we
will have closing statements today Mike
says guilty on a gun charge
and uh
I have accept
proposal or draft number three of the uh
instructions to the attorneys uh this
morning
and we'll make a record now on
my pictures well have they not even
agreed on the instructions yet
wow
um other super chats
David wackman who hates me but continues
contributing says Lawless gangs are
running wild instilling fear and a
terrified child to the Liberals I say be
quiet your bleeding hearts cause many a
riot Lawless gangs running wild okay who
cares pokolova says show me your dog
all right
um
everybody received
and state objections
requests we need a real objection I know
the defense has asked that the
self-defense instruction be read with
every account which is applicable
um if they're asking for that out of a
abundance of caution we would agree with
that request
all right what about that
we've had um
you know we've all talked about things
uh off the Record in terms of our jury
conference I I was under the impression
that that was
um a requirement I understand we're
trying to streamline it we're trying to
not uh bore the jury with the
instructions
um I think that is and if I'm wrong I'm
wrong but I think that is what the law
requires
um I I inquired on the on the message
last night
is anybody familiar with authority on
this subject that requires that that
makes I guess I'll argue with you and
then I'll hear the rest of what you have
to say
you know attention span as you know
you're you speak to juries all the time
and
um when you start repeating yourself you
lose your audience Mighty fast they've
got a lot to hear today from me and from
you lawyers
and
um
I uh
if I am reading the self instruction
self-defense instructions five times
uh I would expect to lose the audience
rather rapidly by the way how are the
calzones uh this is just this is so
typical of lawyers to wear highbanked uh
that's well we've always done it this
way and
um uh I I will tell you that for years I
have
um
I have taken out common elements of
things elements and put them in separate
areas of the instructions
and once they learn what the term intent
to kill means I don't have to Define it
every single time it comes up
um and I've never gotten even to my
knowledge either he hasn't even been an
appeal on it
my job here is to communicate with a
jury
um
so that they understand what their what
the law provides and I think that can be
done
um
better
briefly and concisely than by repeating
the same old stuff over and over again
um but given the position of the parties
if it's if that's your position
uh we'll do it but it to me it's a
Monumental waste of time and um
me and end up having a negative effect
but you know how was the KFC very good
magnitude
over two days or two weeks to try
so if you think that that risks
everything to
proceed as I've suggested then we'll go
with the long long forms every time it's
you're gonna I'm gonna have to count on
you to make timely objections
um if you feel that I'm leaving
something out on a particular count
because I've prepared it in the
36 pages of instructions oh my God
using a brief form uh
without there's already plenty of
um going to be a long day
repeat repeating going on but if I have
to do a longer you're going to have to
object if I if you think I'm missing
something or it's going to be a waiver
just so you're forewarned
um
you have to make a contemporaneous
objection
36 pages and our only one that um you
don't have it in that we had talked
about a little bit was
um count five
you had there's a lesser included
offense of um recklessly endangering
safety oh yeah I'm sorry on that one I
do think that uh well no I didn't put it
in there although it does I didn't think
they were supposed to refer to the judge
as you satisfied Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt of the uh
the defendant was not acting
lovely in self-defense but um
I'll try to squeeze the content in there
as well
and I I guess I'm not sure that I agree
with your statement that um I'll only
take a look at it
um
so if you're just joining us they're
still arguing about jury instructions
which will be read today to the jury
and of course the state wants me if I
read the self-defense portions in then
they want me to repeat every time
retreat in provocation which you have
opposed so they're going to hear that
again what they don't want that anymore
they don't want it anymore I'm going to
throw that request uh simply because of
time
okay
hmm I think I think I'll go back to bed
okay uh whatever you do make sure you go
to the bathroom
I gave special instruction only
with respect to
Mr McGinnis
because the law is here with respect to
him and look after that
um but I didn't reread it with respect
to the account involving Mr
jumpsuit man
jumpsuit man what do you think is where
so you've done attempted first degree
with self-defense attempted second
degree with self-defense
but the way that I read and if I'm
reading it wrong I know the court will
correct me
um on page
27 of the final instructions
it simply says
here are the elements I didn't see
elements of medical self-defense
mentioned right in there
you're right
um
because as I did no let me see
on counts
the attempt murder and the murder
of those I that's the pattern of
instruction
in my if I had my way I think that's
overly verbose and
um they're both I like that I used to do
it that way and then they came up with
this and I followed I follow it but but
uh I think it could be better stated but
I
it's wacky I agree
but
um
and then on count
free I gave a special instruction
because of the situation with Mr
McGinnis
but I didn't on count two or count five
because I relied upon the general
principles of self-defense on which I
instructed them so if you want me to do
it on five I need to do that too too
and they've just that's that's uh two
also
um and that's right after they've just
heard it
so um all right well my only concern is
that
the instruction makes it clear that
self-defense is an issue for first
degree attempt and second degree attempt
I don't know if ever right so that's
because
that's from the pattern instruction I
understand you're thinking well because
I didn't discuss it
in the parchment on and reckless
endangerment that they're going to think
it's not part of it but the last
sentence tells them and if you are
satisfied Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
uh that the defendant's conduct was not
privileged under the law of self-defense
you should find the defendant guilt
did you see that under the recklessly
endangering safety one year
is that we I'm just making is that what
you're saying that's that's on the yeah
that's on
excuse me I'm reading the fourth count
here let's see let's have a look at what
I said on five
see if I even set this up I would have
put a
I'm not going to say whatever
you know you're right
um
well maybe I misunderstood what you
wanted did you want the whole
self-defense instruction discussed again
or just the cause
and the
if you are not satisfied Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant
or that I should say it is all
three elements of the crime have been
dangering safety
of the first degree
have been proved and that the defendant
is not privileged under the law of
self-defense
you must find the defendant that guilt I
think that's fine as long as the self
you don't need as long as they're aware
that the whole instruction is an option
yeah well you're right
all right I was misunderstanding what
what your email said so
if you are not satisfied Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt
well there's more missing there than
that you know that
there's not a the clause about
if you are satisfied
big thanks to Mitch Reed for signing up
on my website joinpakman.com Mitch
you're the man thank you also thanks to
Shamari Vazquez who just upgraded her
subscription I'm gonna call it a new one
that's number three okay the page 27 for
the fourth line will be if you are
satisfied that all three elements of the
crime of reckless endangerment
have been proved and that the pro the
conduct of the defendant was not
privileged under the law of self-defense
then you should find the defendant
guilty of Reckless and dejuven
of the first piece
is submitted
if you are not So Satisfied then you
must find the defender not guilty
okay is that satisfactory
okay
uh what's next patreon is double today
yes
nothing else on the instructions
uh defense
um
so judge you and I'm just this is more
for the record you've already made I
think preliminarily uh you had talked a
little bit about the Richie McGinnis
instruction right
um which is on page eight and nine
right the the position that I had taken
was
one of the lines says but the defendant
does not have a privilege of
self-defense as to Richard McGinnis
uh after that
there's discussion about self-defense
and what that means
on page nine there's a sentence that
says if the defendant was acting lawful
lawfully in self-defense his conduct did
not create an unreasonable risk to
another
I had told you in an email that all the
parties were involved in that I thought
that that
was some incongruence in that in terms
of how that reads
I know the court disagrees but just for
the record I wanted to make sure that
that was on there
um
because I do think it's confusing
however I know it's the pattern
instruction I know you took it from the
panther yeah I'm not even going to argue
with you it is the pattern and I I'm not
going to argue with you that it is
confusing but
um
what it's it's an accurate statement of
the law Mr McGinnis does not have a
self-defense status because he's
um he's uh
he's the defendant has no right of
self-defense
as to any harm you could cause to Mr
engines
and that's what the instruction is
telling the jury but
if he was acting lawfully in
self-defense with respect to
Mr Rosenbaum
then it kills one of the elements
I think I'm reading that right yes
it gives them an absolution
with respect to the element of
the what is the precise a lot of
elements huh
um
unreasonable substantial risk of death
says then that the jury can't find that
well if they can't find out they can't
find the one of the elements so they
have to find the defender not guilty
judge do you think it's appropriate then
on page nine to say if the defendant was
acting lawfully in self-defense as it
relates to Joseph Rosenbaum
um
I just think that makes it clearer I
mean what do you want to put in where
did you say yeah on page nine
it would be the red so there's a
subheading determining whether the
beliefs were reasonable
I think it's the third or fourth the
last sentence says if the defendant was
acting lawfully in self-defense comma
okay with respect to the to Joseph
Rosenbaum with respect to Joseph
Rosenbaum
his conduct did not create an
unreasonable risk to
Richard McGinnis yeah I'll do that any
objection
no okay
okay what's next
rather that on page these are small but
on page 34 uh two of the witnesses you
said one of the witnesses had been
convicted of of a crime Mr gross kreutz
had been convicted of a crime and Mr
Smith had been convicted of a crime
that's for a juvenile adjudication so I
think if you just say
multiple Witnesses have been something
like that okay
um what number what page is that on I'm
sorry 34.
a lot of Demands here from the defense
they're doing their job they're doing
their job and we are um
asking for the cost you want the word
some instead of one or multiple yeah how
many was it
two that I recall
uh there actually were
well I don't think you asked me this
sword about hers there was another
witness with convictions but I don't
believe the question was asked so too
what was the answer
uh all right I'll put down two of them
um and then there was some conversations
regarding a cautionary instruction
regarding Mr Armstrong yeah and I really
struggled with it and we had proposed
the uh the instruction to the court
which I think we took off of 245 or
something like that yeah so
um we are asking based on his testimony
um that the court instruct with that
modified 245 instruction as it relates
to Mr I'm sure
uh did you want to be heard
well
I would stand by what I indicated over
the weekend in my email but I I believe
that
I I I'm looking up these specific
instruction
my instinct is that Richards and Binger
are not participating in this because
they're the ones delivering the closing
statements and they're just sort of you
know staying in the zone as far as that
goes I had planned on using if I had
drafted it myself
the evidence was received the points
that the defense wanted to get into were
made on cross-examination
giving any kind of
instruction on this would essentially be
telling the fact finders how to weigh
the evidence
um I proposed a different or some
different wording
um the
you should not base a vertical guilty
upon it alone unless after consideration
of all the evidence you were satisfied
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt of the
defendant is guilty is completely
inappropriate I can understand where
it's appropriate if you're talking about
accomplices but certainly not we're
talking about a one picture out of a
hundred and some odd exhibits
so
I don't believe it's appropriate I don't
believe it's necessary
I again I believe that these arguments
about
pixels and zooming are specious that
they're expert to use the very similar
software program with zooming was was
cropping there was no objection then you
see it I understand right there's no
basis for an objection and they know
that I don't know I don't know that
maybe they do I don't know I can't read
their minds
yeah this is a forensically sound
program used by a forensic analyst who's
trained this image was peer reviewed if
they want to discuss the proprietary
algorithms and how here we go would not
know a proprietary uncharged contained
in the software that they are using that
is an industry standard they can go
ahead and argue it but to give an
instruction that tells the jury
essentially to ignore this evidence
unless everything else
proves it is
is way too far well this whole business
about well I don't want to say the whole
business but
the daughter rule is the product
of the abuse of
so-called scientific evidence
by attorneys
there were there were
companies Pension funds individuals were
bankrupted because of legal decisions
that were made on the basis of so-called
science which was later shown to be
garbage
so when you come in here you tell me
well this is what they rely on
I think that's fine except when my
Common Sense tells me well wait a minute
what's happening here when you get a an
image that is
I'll say it again let's say 2500 pixels
and you blow it up to 25
000. or 250
000 unchanged you don't really know what
fills the vacant space
um that's a little struggle for me and
this is not being used
to decide which camera I'm going to buy
or which phone I'm going to buy when I'm
at the store this is being used to
decide about whether someone's innocent
or guilty of a crime
so that's why I was I was uh here we go
when the witness answered he didn't know
and the only reason I
um
in the end I decided Well
wait a minute we allowed this kind of
thing to happen in DWI cases where the
officers
asked well how does the machine work
I don't know I just am trained how to
operate it
um but there is a difference there that
has already passed judicial scrutiny and
this method has been judicially
determined to be accurate
has that been done in this I don't know
so that was so that was when I was
thinking well maybe I should give a
cautionary instruction
I ultimately
Who convinced me
uh in our exchanges that
um
I don't want to be meddling and
commenting on the evidence
I will tell you this
assuming that
there's a conviction one or more
assuming that other motions don't
contaminate the whatever outcome there
is
if it comes out at some time that the
method used
produces unreliable results
this is going to fall like a house of
cards
is your facing
uh this extremely important
segment of the evidence
on something that I'm really queasy
about but as I said when I left Friday
this is the jury's case it's not mine
and I'm going to let them decide they
have he's going to let him decide but
he's going to warn them
video and they've got the testimony of
the
person who is was worked with it who
knows a lot more about this stuff than I
do so I've decided to leave it alone so
I'm not going to give an instruction on
it but I've made my record on
the high risk that I think it presents
for the case
okay what's next
you the court had modified a little bit
um count six which was the I didn't Dean
okay so uh the third element that you
have listed there is the dangerous
weapon was a rifle that had a barrel
length of less than 16 inches or or an
overall length of less than 26 inches
um we have pulled a transcript uh taught
and looked at it uh detective antaremine
was asked
if this was a short barreled rifle he
had answered no he did not believe that
it was that's the only information
regarding it was the gun offered as an
exhibit yes yes that is evidence correct
enough in itself
the jury you can measure it okay
is that fair enough I just didn't the
way that I looked at it there was no
other information that would that a
reasonable juror could believe that
count three has been met
what are you telling me that I'm asking
that you take it from them
they're asking me to
to dismiss the case
for failure to prove discount Six
there have been
many discussions about this couch I'm
not going to rehash everything the state
disagrees with the interpretation of the
Court
the court has established we do not
believe this jury instruction is
appropriate we do not believe that the
exception or forward defense or whatever
you want to call it was properly raised
we argued about all that on Friday I'm
not going to rehash it
um I believe it should go to the jury if
the jury
believes that
it was proven not from Beyond reasonable
doubt they can return a verdict on that
but
state
[Music]
the state has objected all along or has
given its version all along We Stand by
that version I believe that this jury
instruction essentially swallows the
entire statute you've gone over that
before so I I believe that if if they
raise an exception then it should go to
the jury
uh we would like standard instruction
clearly the Court's not going to do that
well
up to now the the emotions were motions
to dismiss the complaint
and you filed a very nice brief which
well explained what the law is and of
course we were dealing with what the
complaints needed and whether the
complaints stated
sufficient facts
uh to bring the case to court
and the court is confined on that kind
of emotion to the
to what's in the complaint and whether
it meets the law and as you pointed out
these offensive matters are affirmative
defenses and the D.A doesn't have to
Plate them
so that's why I ultimately denied the
motion to dismiss although I think it
ought to have been mighty clear that I
had big problems with this statute I've
made to oppose about that that from the
beginning
and
um
there always was access to the court of
appeals all along here
well I guess I that's not fair for me to
say because if I was sitting on it but
but [ __ ] shame on me but
um
um
I I
ultimately read the statute and have
even when I rolled on the motion to
dismiss
um I was of the opinion that the statute
was as interpreted by the defense
and
but there was not sufficient grounds to
Grant the motion to dismiss
is the firearm here no
yes
we can either measure it
or
you can stipulate that it is it does not
meet what I've
so we started a poll 16 minutes ago
about whether they would do at least 30
more minutes of the debate the poll is
still running it's looking more and more
like the answer is yes
there's less than 16 infinite inches
or an overall length less than 26 inches
then
I'll deny the motion if it does not meet
those specifications then this
defense motion will be granted
we are not disputing
that the barrel
is appropriate isn't legal
it is not a shortved shotgun or a short
barrels rifle yes either
oh my God the audio correct all right
and then count uh six is dismissed wow
uh they've dismissed another count
what's next I had filed
on November 8th 8th we had uh addressed
a motion to uh
a motion for mistrial with prejudice the
court had taken that under advisement uh
what I had informed the court uh was the
mistrial so I have filed
um
something in writing on that I know the
court likely hasn't had an opportunity
to review it
I don't know
okay I'm assuming that we're going to go
through obviously through uh closing
arguments today but I I did want to make
sure the court was aware that it it had
been filed and at some point have the
court make a final ruling on it just for
the record I will okay uh if it's
necessary
um the um
so that means there's not going to be a
mistrial it sounds like came in this
morning okay
okay anything else
the defend his interview link that we
sent to play
The Washington Post uh story I didn't I
did receive that I I did receive that
it really relates to the motion that's
the only reason I asked
this motion it relates to that
um
but I'm not going to take up the motion
now I didn't know I just know there are
typical problems I just wanted to make
sure they were ironed out
I did I did receive it okay
okay uh anything else right now
I have pretty sure yeah the only thing
judge uh in our uh arguments uh we would
like to
indicate that pointing a loaded AR-15 at
someone without reasonable justification
would be a criminal act without citing
you know the statute about that pointing
under 941.20 is a crime we would like to
point that out and we just wanted to
preview that so if there's objection we
can handle it now
okay um do you want to respond
we would object this is once again
relying on the exhibit that is so far
out of focus and there's been nothing in
the record when I specifically asked the
detective Detective Howard regarding the
strong arm of robbery I asked about
strong armed robbery while Mass I asked
about it it's in the record
uh you know the struggle I'm having with
that is and and I will
well I'll leave that
um
how do you how do we know it was pointed
at or toward Mr zaminsky or Mr zaminsky
or whomever
you have a theory that is pointed in
that direction I agree with that but the
statute's prohibition is pretty explicit
and I'm not sure that
the evidence that you have especially
because it's just the
well not just especially but in part
because it's
um just a regular
photograph it's not multi-dimensional
it doesn't show the exact area at which
the firearm will land George even if you
see the firearm
again the photograph is
perhaps the
fifth or sixth
most relevant piece of evidence on this
topic uh what fifth or sixth most
relevant piece of evidence on this topic
we have testimony we have videos on not
going all over that again the defense
submitted their own exhibit of the FBI
video with the zaminski is denoted as
being the only two that were on that
side of the Duramax Mr zaminski is
starts out by the
one of the windows of the Duramax I
guess would be the rear
passenger side window
and
so there's no real dispute that they are
in that area and that is where
you that he is pointing the weapon it's
for the jury to decide if he's pointing
at zabinski's or not so it's for the
jury to decide it is not for the jury to
speculate
I let's let's look at the Statue that's
that's a good place to start
I want to say thanks to Kelly fultz and
Miles Cornish as well as Eric Lair Eric
Fair Layman for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com
really appreciate that yeah
yeah well also thanks to Tariq Thomas
for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com
issue I suppose
that what is the role of Mr Rosenbaum
assuming the defendant violated that
statute that's the very theory that the
state has proceeded on in the first
place is that the defendant was a
vigilante who is getting himself
involved in something that was not as
concerned and now you're telling me that
would justify Mr rosenbaum's actions I I
I'm kind of struggling with that too
patreon is double today guys I see
people in the chat what does the jury do
with that
thank you
because I don't I don't feel like you're
saying the first question I would also
know is
pardon me he also pointed the weapon of
Mr Rosenbaum
before the shooting well the while he's
being pursued he turns and points into
Mr Rosie but there's no question about
that correct
pardon me I said he's being chase fire
well they made it much more complicated
it used to be a points and names points
or aims of firearm at another
I'm not seeing that exact language
anymore but
um
not seeing it here on the statute that
there would be a broad enough sweep to
uh
capture
so 24 minutes ago we started a poll
asking are they going to do another 30
minutes of this uh arguing over the jury
instructions we're only six minutes from
that becoming a reality we'll end the
poll at that point typically
add or toward another
in the meantime let me know in the chat
if you think there will be any guilty
verdicts at all on any count
sure 1A is in dangers another safety by
the negligent operation or handling of a
dangerous weapon uh we would argue that
that it is if the court feels otherwise
we just simply will talk about it and
not call it where was the fire Army you
say at the zabinski's
I hadn't I didn't hear the zabinsky's
come in here and say that who said it
except for looking at the video there's
and that's who's over there that would
be pardon looking at videos and
indicating that that those are the ones
who are over there that would be the
only I can't say I'm not
I'm saying I don't think I can give an
instruction to the jury telling them you
know something when I don't see this the
statutory uh WordPress for instruction
in our arguments we just wanted to say
I think it would be okay for you to say
hey by the way great to see flossie
Carter in the chat on the stream flossy
uh even significantly bigger YouTube
channel than ours
um uh check out flossie Carter
congratulations for finding our stream I
appreciate it
kind of want to try to you know rule in
advance it's I've refrained from doing
that I always tried to
because I can't read your mind but um
um
so I'm not going to say here they can't
mention that at all
that it's unlawful to point a gun at
somebody
the jurors probably have a sense of that
anyway but uh they have a sense of it I
like that but as to
the jurors generally have a sense that
murder is wrong
okay what's next
oh we have
okay
ready for the jury wow I'll probably
take a break after these the lengthy
instructions so they actually stopped
just four minutes short of going an
extra half hour it really looked like it
was going to go long but it didn't we
don't yet know what's for lunch today
that's we we just don't know arm forward
around noon yeah I do want to say thanks
to Al The Alchemist
and a person and Edward Lopez they just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
appreciate you guys put this at 10.
remember today patreon pledges count
double
that means one counts as two two count
is four sixteen count is 32 a thousand
count as
1100 what's what's a thousand times two
it's Eleven Hundred right I can't
remember
um they have not had to my knowledge
Indian food now when the judge referred
to the Asian food last week
India is part of Asia but traditionally
when we say Indian when we mean Indian
food we say Indian food
so we are looking into that very
strongly juries coming in they're
starting 36 pages of jury instructions
and then we will have closing statements
closing statement from the prosecution
closing statement from the defense
rebuttal from the prosecution two and a
half hours allocated to each so if this
takes an hour that puts a set close to
noon then they will take a break
probably until one
and then we could potentially have five
hours which would already get us to six
so it they may not even be done today
the judge was talking about we'll be
we'll hand the jury the case by 3 P.M
their time which is 4 P.M on the East
Coast uh I don't I think that's very
optimistic because there's going to be a
break there's presumably going to be
lunch by the way how calzones yeah
um and oh actually and today maybe even
be something else in fact we have Subway
tomorrow yeah we just don't know what
they're going to be bringing in today
so that'll all be happening a few quick
super chats here
how many think the Judge has sent
elements of his misconduct seen elements
of misconduct in his trial judge seems
different today oh now he's on his phone
many people have been convicted based on
junk arson science bite mark science
blood type science
probably some of the judge was referring
to this is painful anybody need Medico
here we go
we are just getting started it's going
to be a long day
um it's getting really trashy in the
chat so we may go subscribers only we've
had to ban about 30 people just in the
how long have we been streaming hour 45
minutes we've been streaming so we may
um we may do it honestly watching this
trial just makes me hungry let's take a
break lunch is here all right how was
the KFC very good huh
oh something about the pretty good huh
have you heard of KFC pretty good huh
um is extra funny
shout out to Durango's Pizza in Kenosha
David thank you for doing this every day
pleasure it's been it's been good to be
here
um yeah
the food is here yeah still my favorite
moment is the judge telling people not
the jury not to use the not to go to the
bathroom in the middle of the courtroom
whatever you do make sure you go to the
bathroom somewhere other than the
cartoon yeah
oh man I wonder how far is it from
the courthouse to the nearest KFC
Kenosha Courthouse
to KFC like how far did they bring that
in
uh it's about a seven minute it is 2.3
miles I guess in the in the midwest 2.3
miles isn't a lot
you know in a lot of cities it's like
2.3 miles it could take you an hour to
do that
any interesting restaurants
Infusino's Italian Restaurant and
Pizzeria that's an interesting spot
I wonder if the Asian food was from
Chen's Bistro very close to the
courthouse just looking at a map here
a lot of interesting little spots I
don't know if Kenosha is considered a
culinary destination but
remains to be seen
this weekend and uh
we'll uh begin our
final phase of our case which is my
instructions and I'm going to instruct
you on the principles of law
what you are to follow in considering
the evidence and in reaching your
verdicts here we go it is your duty to
follow all of these instructions
regardless of any opinion that you may
have about what the law is or what the
law ought to be you must base your
verdict on the law as I give it to you
in these instructions
apply that law to the facts in the case
which have been properly approved by the
evidence
consider only the evidence received
during the trial and the law is given to
you in these instructions and from these
things alone Guided by your soundest
reason and best judgment reach your
verdict if any of you has any impression
of my opinion as to the Innocence or
guilt of the defendant you must
disregard that impression entirely and
decide this case solely as you view the
evidence you are the sole judges of the
facts and I am the judge of the law only
keep in mind that the information is
nothing more than a written formal
accusation against the defendant
accusing him of the commission of crimes
you are not to consider it as evidence
against the defendant in any way and it
does not raise any inference of guilt
the information contains six counts of
charged unlawful Behavior against the
defendant and to each of these he has
entered a plea of not guilty which is a
demand that the state proved every
element of each crime Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt
self-defense is an issue in this case as
25 and I might interject here uh count
six is no longer part of your
consideration that was the firearm
charge
so that will not be something that you
will need to address you'll need to
address you'll need to address only the
first five counts
count uh well self-defense is an issue
in this case as to each of counts one
through five the state must prove by
evidence which satisfies you beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant did
not act lawfully in self-defense
the law of self-defense allows the
defendant to threaten or intentionally
use Force against another only if
he believed that there was an actual or
imminent unlawful interference with his
own person
and he believed that the amount of force
which he used or threatened to use was
necessary to prevent or terminate the
interference and his beliefs were
reasonable
the defendant May intentionally use
Force which is intended or likely to
cause death or grit bodily harm only if
he reasonably believed that the force
used was necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to his own
person
a belief may be reasonable even though
it is mistaken in determining whether
the defendant's beliefs were reasonable
the standard is what a person of
ordinary intelligence and Prudence would
have believed in the defendant's
position ordinary intelligence is a
tough one existed at the time of the
alleged offenses
the reasonableness of the defendant's
beliefs must be determined from the
standpoint of the defendant at the time
of the defendant's acts and not from the
standpoint of the jury now
there is no duty to retreat however in
determining whether the defendant
reasonably believed the amount of force
used was necessary to prevent or
terminate the interference you may
consider whether the defendant had the
opportunity to retreat with safety
whether such retreat was feasible and
whether the defendant knew of the
opportunity to retreat
you should also consider whether the
defendant provoked the attack
a person who engages in unlawful conduct
of a type likely to provoke others to
attack and who does provoke an attack is
not allowed to use or threaten force in
self-defense against than a tank
however if the attack which follows
causes the person reasonably reasonably
to believe
that
he is in imminent danger of death or
great bodily harm he may lawfully act in
self-defense but the person may not use
or threaten Force intended or are likely
to cause death unless he reasonably
believes that he has exhausted every
other reasonable means to escape from or
otherwise avoid greatly harm
counts four and five require intent to
kill as part of the elements intent to
kill means that the defendant had the
mental purpose to take the life of
another human being or was aware that
his conduct was practically certain to
cause the death of another human being
while the law requires that the
defendant have acted with the intent to
kill it does not require that the intent
to kill have existed for any particular
length of time before the Act was
committed
the the ACT need not have been rooted
over considered or reflected upon for a
week a day an hour or even for a minute
there need not have been any appreciable
time between the formation of the intent
and the act the intent to kill may be
formed at any time before the ACT
including the instant before the act and
must continue to have existed at the
time of the ACT
you cannot look into a person's mind to
determine intent intent to kill must be
found if found it all from the
defendant's X words and statements if
any and from all the facts and
circumstances in this case which bear
upon intent
intent should not be confused with
motive proof of motive is necessary
Excuse me while proof of motive is
necessary to a conviction proof of
motive is not motive refers to a
person's reason for doing something
while motive may be shown as a
circumstance to Aid in establishing the
guilt of the defendant the state is not
required to prove motive on the part of
the defendant in order to convict
evidence of motive does not by itself
establish guilt
you should give it the weight you
believe it deserves under all the
circumstances I didn't want to interrupt
but that was a very did the judge say
both that motive is and is not a
requirement that motive that was a very
strange thing there give Kenosha in this
County
the defendant recklessly caused the
death of another human being Joseph D
Rosenbaum under circumstances would show
utter disregard for human life
first degree Reckless homicide as
defined in the criminal code is
committed by one who recklessly causes
the death of another human being under
circumstances which show utter disregard
for human life
before you may find the defendant guilty
of Reckless homicide of the first degree
the state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond A Reasonable Doubt
that the following three elements were
present first that the defendant caused
the death of another
cause means that the defendants Act was
a substantial factor in producing the
death
second that the defendant caused the
death by criminally Reckless conduct
criminally Reckless conduct means the
conduct created a risk of death or great
bodily harm to another person
and that the risk of death of great
bodily harm was unreasonable and
substantial
and that the defendant was aware that
his conduct created the unreasonable and
substantial risk of death or great
bodily harm
the circumstances uh and the
circumstances of the defendant's conduct
showed utter disregard for human life in
determining whether the
circumstances of the conduct showed
utter disregard for human life you
should consider these factors what the
defendant was doing why he was engaged
in that conduct how dangerous the
conduct was how obvious was the danger
whether the conduct showed any regard
for human life and all their facts I
mean without even attacking the people
on the jury as incompetent because we
don't know anything about him other than
some of the things that were said which
raised real questions
can the average person who doesn't work
within the law even keep all these
things in mind in making such
complicated decisions I'm just asking I
don't know as I have instructed you on
the law of self-defense
then you should find the defendant
guilty of Reckless homicide of the first
degree as charged in the information
if you are not So Satisfied then you
must find the defendant not guilty on
this gunk
counts two and three of the information
accuse the defendant of the crimes of
recklessly endangering safety although
the elements of each of these charges
are identical elements of self-defense
which apply to them are not
oh boy
the second count of the information
charges that at the same time and place
the defendant
recklessly in danger of the safety of
Richard McGinnis under circumstances
which show utter disregard for human
life
the third count of the information
charges that at the same time and place
the defendant recklessly endangered the
safety of an unknown male
under circumstances which show utterness
life
first degree reckless endangerment as
defined in the criminal code is
committed by one who recklessly
endangers the safety of another human
being under circumstances which show
utter disregard for human life
before you may find the defendant guilty
of reckless endangerment of the first
degree
the state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond a reasonable doubt
that the following three elements were
present first that the defendant
recklessly excuse me first that the
defendant endangered the safety of
another human being
and the risk of death or great bodily
harm was on reasonable and substantial
and the defendant was aware that his
conduct created the unreasonable and
substantial risk of death or great
bodily harm
great bodily harm means
injury which creates a substantial risk
of death or which causes serious
permanent disfigurement or which causes
a permanent or protracted loss or import
impairment of the function of any bodily
member or organ or other serious bodily
injury
the third element is that the
circumstances of the defendant's conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
again inter determining the circum
whether the circumstances of the
economic should utter disregard for
human life
you should consider these factors what
the defendant was doing why the
defendant was engaged in that conduct
how dangerous was the conduct how
obvious was the danger whether the
conduct showed any regard for human life
and all other facts and circumstances
the circumstances related to the conduct
judge seems confused
uncharged piccolos
warm food around noon
this is this is a mess I agree with you
guys
but I guess so far he hasn't made any
jokes that's something
look at this
my God
please proceed governor
I do want to say thank you to um
oh nobody even signed up that's sad uh
okay
David who eats more fast food Donald
Trump or this judge and the jury but we
have Subway tomorrow right
all right how was the KFC very good huh
I don't know the answer I don't know I
love calzones though I really do calzone
is
every once in a while
my girlfriend would be like let's order
a pizza and I'll go yeah man I go oh
wait a second
the pizza place has calzones pizza is
here right and then I'll go let's do it
let's do it
ricotta mozzarella you need you really
need both
you really need both
when was the last time I ateeded a KFC
um I think 15 years ago one opened near
where I was living at the time after
there being no KFC for a while and I
went and got a crispy strip meal
I remember that KFC coleslaw quite
compelling I don't even know if it has
mayo in it or real Mayo
um that was the last time yeah about 15
years ago
the judge actually just pulled out
an Asian food menu
he's actually worried that what is being
advertised as Wasabi is just horseradish
and green food coloring and he is not
pleased one bit the food is here
will I open phones today so I am open to
opening phones today yes
but
I actually have a very interesting live
stream on my Instagram happening later
today with a celebrity which I will
announce once it's confirmed so here's
the deal
if we were to get to a hundred and I
don't have time we'll do it tomorrow
okay when I was instructing a moment ago
on Reckless homicide I indicated there
were two elements there are actually
three I did read all of the ingredients
but I'm just going to reread a portion
of that instruction so it's clear that
there are three elements to that crime
and I also use the word both of the
elements and it's actually three so
um
I apologize for that mistake and uh
it's getting pretty dicey
let's just we'll stop with the reckless
endangerment
for a moment in return to the Reckless
homicide uh in the elements of Reckless
homicides are
that the defendant caused the death of
another all right I'll be back I did so
by criminally Reckless conduct and the
third element which I read as part of
the second is that the circumstances of
the defendant's conduct utter disregard
for human life
and what tipped me off is uh other than
causing death the reckless endangerment
which I've been reading now has those
same three elements so uh utter
disregard for human life is one of the
elements of the
of the of both crimes
and in order to convict on the
first count you must find the presence
of all three of the elements
of first-degree Reckless homicide and
also find Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
the defendant was not privileged under
the law of self-defense
is that clear
thanks thank you very much
getting back to the reckless
endangerment charged with respect to Mr
McGinnis
there is evidence in this case that the
defendant was acting in self-defense as
to Joseph Rosenbaum
the fact that the law may have allowed
may have allowed the defendant to use
force in self-defense as to Joseph
Rosenbaum does not necessarily mean that
recklessly endangering the safety of
Richard McGinnis was lawful
you must consider the law of
self-defense in deciding whether the
defendant's conduct as to Richard
McGinnis was criminally Reckless conduct
which showed utter disregard for human
life but the defendant does not have a
privilege of self-defense with respect
to Mr McGinnis so the defendant would
enjoy a privilege of self-defense with
respect to Mr Rosenbaum if you find the
factual
ingredients of that but that doesn't
mean that what he the fact that he if he
endangered the safety of Mr
um
beginners
was privileged under the law of
self-defense because Mr McGinnis was not
attacking him
however
um
you must consider the law of
self-defense and deciding whether the
defendant's conduct as to Richard
McGinnis was criminally Reckless conduct
which showed utter disregard for human
life
but he does not have a privilege of
self-defense as to Richard McGinnis the
law of self-defense allows the defendant
to threaten or intentionally use Force
against another
only if the defendant believed that
there was an actual or imminent
interference with the defendant's person
that he believed that the amount of
force he used or threatened was to use
was necessary to prevent or terminate
the interference and that his beliefs
were reasonable
the defendant May intentionally use
Force which is intended to or likely to
cause death or great bodily harm only if
the defendant reasonably believed that
the force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily injury to
himself
may be reasonable even though mistaken
in determining whether the defendant's
beliefs were reasonable the standard is
what a person of ordinary intelligence
and Prudence would have believed in the
defendant's position under the
circumstances existing at the time of
the alleged offense the reason illness
reasonableness of the defendant's
beliefs must be determined from
the standpoint of the defendant at the
time of his acts and not from the
Viewpoint of the jury now
you should consider the evidence
relating to self-defense along with all
the other evidence in the case in
deciding whether the defendant's conduct
created an unreasonable risk of death or
great bodily harm to Richard McGinnis if
the defendant was acting lawfully in
self-defense with respect to Joseph
Rosenbaum his conduct did not create an
unreasonable risk to another
the burden is on the state to prove by
uh beyond the it should be this the
burden is on the state to prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant did
not act lawfully in self-defense and you
must be satisfied Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt from all of the evidence in this
case that the risk was unreasonable
you should consider the evidence
relating to self-defense in deciding
whether the circumstances of the
defendant's conduct showed utter
disregard for human life the burden is
on the state to prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant did
not act lawfully in self-defense and you
must be satisfied Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt from all of the evidence in this
case that the circumstances of the
defendant's conduct showed utter
disregard for human life
if as to each of these counts you are
satisfied Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the elements have been proved
and that the defendant was not acting
lawfully in self-defense you should find
the defendant guilty of Reckless
homicide of the first degree if
So Satisfied then you must find the
defendant not guilty
the fourth counter the information
charges that at the same time in place
the defendant caused the death of
another human being Anthony M Huber with
intent to kill that person
this is a charge of intentional homicide
of the first degree and you must
consider first whether the defendant is
guilty of that offense
if you are not satisfied the defendant
is guilty of first degree intentional
homicide
you may consider whether or not the
defendant is guilty of second-degree
intentional homicide or first degree
Reckless homicide which are less serious
degrees of criminal homicide
the crime is referred to as first and
second degree intentional homicide and
first-degree Reckless homicide are
different degrees of homicide
homicide is the taking of the life of
another human being the degree of
homicide by defined by law depends on
the facts and circumstances of each
particular case
while the law separates homicides into
different types and degrees there are
certain Elements which are common to
each crime both intentional and Reckless
homicide require that the defendant have
caused the death of another first and
second degree intentional homicide
require the state to prove the
additional fact that the defendant have
acted with the intent to kill
first degree Reckless homicide requires
that the defendant acted recklessly and
that the circumstances of his conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
it will also be important important for
you to consider the privilege of
self-defense in deciding which crime if
any the defendant has committed
self-defense excuse me the criminal
court of Wisconsin provides that a
person is privileged to intentionally
use Force against another for the
purpose of preventing or terminating
what he reasonably believes to be an
unlawful interference with his own
person by the other person however he
may intentionally use only such Morse as
he reasonably believes is necessary to
prevent or terminate the interference he
may not intentionally use Force which is
intended or likely to cause death unless
he reasonably believes that such force
is necessary to prevent imminent death
or great bodily harm to himself
as applied to this case the effect of
the law of self-defense is
the defendant is not guilty of any
homicide offense if the defendant
reasonably believed that he was
preventing or terminating an unlawful
interference with his own person or
reasonably believe the force used by him
excuse me and reasonably believed that
the force used by him was necessary to
prevent imminent death or great bodily
harm to himself
the defendant is guilty of second-degree
intentional homicide if he caused the
death of another human being with intent
to kill and actually believe the force
used was necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself
but the belief or the amount of force
used was unreasonable
the defendant is guilty of first-degree
intentional homicide if he intended to
cause the death of another with the
intent to kill and did not actually
believe that the force used was
necessary to prevent imminent death or
great bodily harm to himself
the defendant is guilty of first-degree
Reckless homicide if the defendant
caused the death of another by
criminally Reckless conduct and the
circumstances of the conduct showed
utter disregard for human life
you will be asked to consider the
privilege of self-defense of deciding
whether the elements of first degree
Reckless homicide are present
because the law provides that it is the
state's burden to prove all facts facts
necessary to constitute a crime Beyond a
reasonable doubt you will not be asked
to make a separate finding on whether
the defendant acted in self-defense
instead you will be asked to determine
whether the state is established the
necessary facts to justify a finding of
guilty for first or second degree
intentional homicide or for first degree
Reckless homicide if the state does not
satisfy you that those facts are
established by the evidence you will be
instructed to find the defendant not
guilty
the facts necessary to constitute each
crime will now be defined for you in
Greater detail
first degree intentional homicide is
defined in the criminal code is
committed by one who causes the death of
another human being with the intent to
kill that person or another
in this case first degree intentional
homicide also requires that the that the
defendant did not actually believe the
force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself
before you may find the defendant guilty
of first-degree intentional homicide the
state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond a reasonable doubt
that the following three elements were
present
first that the defendant caused the
death of another cause means that his
act was a substantial Factor
reducing the death second that the
defendant acted with the intent to kill
the other
third that the defendant did not
actually believe that the force used was
necessary to prevent imminent death or
great bodily harm to himself
the third element of the first degree
section of intentional homicide requires
that the
defendant did not actually believe the
force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself
this requires the state to prove either
that the defendant did not actually
believed he was in imminent danger of
death or great bodily harm or that the
defendant did not actually believe that
the force used was necessary to prevent
imminent danger of death or great bodily
harm to himself
when first-degree intentional homicide
is considered the reasonableness of the
defendant's conduct excuse me
when first degree intentional homicide
is considered the reasonableness of the
defendant's belief is not an issue you
are to be concerned only with what the
defendant actually believed whether
those beliefs are reasonable is
important only if you just if you later
consider whether the defendant is guilty
of second-degree intentional homicide
if asked to the fourth count you are
satisfied Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the defendant caused the death of
another
with the intent to kill that this is Mr
Huber uh with the intent to kill and
that the defendant did not actually
believe that the force used was
necessary to prevent imminent death or
great bodily harm to himself
if you are not So Satisfied then you
must not find the defendant guilty of
first degree intentional homicide and
must consider whether the defendant is
guilty of second-degree attentional
homicide
as defined in the kernel code which is a
lesser encoded offense of the first
degree intentional homicide
there are hierarchies of cases in the
law
typically first degree is the is the
highest defense
then lesser included are crimes that are
of the same nature with many common
elements but some differences so there's
a sequence of verdicts that are going to
be submitted to you with respect to the
discount
and that's what we're going through at
this time so we'll take on now the um
but let me advise you you should make
every reasonable effort
to agree unanimously on the charge of
intentional homicide of the first degree
before considering the offense of
second-degree intentional homicide
however if after a full and complete
consideration of the evidence you
conclude that further deliberation would
not result in unanimous agreement on the
charge of first degree intentional
homicide you should consider whether the
defendant is guilty of second-degree
intentional homicide
before you may find the defendant guilty
of intentional homicide of the second
degree the state must prove by evidence
which satisfies you beyond A Reasonable
Doubt
that the following three elements of
this crime were present
first that the defendant caused the
death of another
second that he acted with intent to kill
another human being
and third that he did not reasonably
believe that he
are terminating an unlawful interference
with his own person or did not
reasonably reasonably believe that the
force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself
you have already been already been
instructed on the definitions of causing
death and with intent to kill these same
definitions apply to your consideration
of second degree intentional homicide
the third element of second-degree and
tangential homicide requires that the
defendant did not reasonably believe
that he was preventing or terminating an
unlawful Affair interference with his
own person or did not reasonably believe
that the force which was used was
necessary to prevent imminent death or
great bodily harm to himself
this requires that the state
have proved one of the following first
that a reasonable person in the
circumstances of the defendant would not
have believed that he was preventing or
terminating an unlawful interference
with his own person or
that a reasonable person in the
circumstances of the defendant would not
have believed he was in danger of
imminent death or great bodily harm
or that the reasonable person in the
circumstances of the defendant would not
have believed that the amount of force
used was necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself
the reasonableness of the defendant's
beliefs must be
determined from the standpoint of the
defendant at the time of his acts and
not from the standpoint of the Viewpoint
of the jury now
standard is what a person of ordinary
intelligence and Prudence would have
believed in the position of the
defendant under the circumstances
existing at the time of the alleged
offense
CFS to the fourth count you are
satisfied Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the defendant caused the death of
another another human being with intent
to kill and did not reasonably believe
that he was preventing or terminating an
unlawful interference with his own
person or did not reasonably believe
that the force used was necessary to
prevent imminent death or great bodily
harm to himself you should find the
defendant guilty of second-degree
intentional homicide
If You're Not So Satisfied then you must
not find the defendant guilty of
second-degree intentional homicide and
you should consider whether the
defendant is guilty of first degree
Reckless homicide as defined in the
criminal code which is also a lesser
included offense of first degree
intentional homicide
again you should make every reasonable
ever effort to agree unanimously on the
charge of second-degree intentional
homicide before considering the offense
of first degree Reckless homicide
however if after a full and complete
consideration of the evidence you
conclude that further deliberation would
not result in unanimous agreement on the
charge of second-degree intentional
homicide you should consider whether the
defendant is guilty of first-degree
Reckless homicide which is a crime
committed by one who recklessly causes
the death of another human being under
circumstances would show utter disregard
for human life
before the demand the defendant may be
found guilty of Reckless homicide of the
first degree
the state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond a reasonable doubt
that the following three elements were
present first that the defendant caused
the death of another human being
cause means that the defendant's Act was
a substantial factor in producing the
death
second that the defendant caused the
death by criminally Reckless conduct
which means the conduct creative risk of
death or great bodily harm to another
person and the risk of death or great
bodily harm was unreasonable and
substantial and the defendant was aware
that his conduct created the
unreasonable and substantial risk of
death or great bodily harm
you should also you should consider the
evidence relating to self-defense in
deciding whether the defendants
conduct created the unreasonable risk to
another
if the defendant was acting lawfully in
self-defense
his conduct did not create an
unreasonable risk to another the burden
is on the state to establish
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
that the defendant did not act lawfully
in self-defense and you must be
satisfied Beyond A Reasonable Doubt from
all of the evidence in this case that
the risk was unreasonable
the third element is that the
circumstances of the defendant's conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
again into determining whether the
circumstances of the conduct showed
utter disregard for human life you
should consider these factors what the
defendant was doing why he was doing it
how dangerous the conduct was
the obviousness of the danger whether
the conduct showed any regard for life
and all other facts and circumstances
relating to the conduct you should
consider the evidence relating to
self-defense and deciding whether the
circumstances of the defendant's conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
the burden is on the state to prove by
evidence which satisfies you beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant did
not act lawfully in self-defense
and you must be satisfied Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt from all of the
evidence in the case but the
circumstances of the defendant's conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
consider also the defendant's conduct
after the death so as excuse me consider
also the defendant's conduct after the
death to the extent that it helps you
decide whether or not the circumstances
showed utter disregard for human life at
the time that the death occurred
if as to the fourth count you were
satisfied Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the defendant caused the death of
another human being by criminally
Reckless conduct and that the
circumstances of the conduct showed
utter disregard for human life and that
the defendant's conduct was not
privileged under the law of self-defense
then you should find the defendant
guilty of Reckless homicide of the first
degree
as submitted if you are not So Satisfied
then you must find the defendant not
guilty on the fourth count
the fifth count of the information
charges that at the same time in place
the attempt the defendant attempted to
cause the death of Gage gross kreitz
with intent to kill that person
a crime of attempted first degree
intentional homicide
with respect to this charge the judge
got a text during the instructions is
that true defense if you are not
satisfied that the defendant is guilty
of attempted first degree intentional
homicide
you must consider whether or not he is
guilty of attempted second-degree
attentional homicide or first degree
reckless endangerment which which are
less serious degrees of criminal
homicide
the crimes referred to as attempted
first and second degree intentional
homicide are different degrees of
homicide again that is the taking of the
life of a human being
the degree of attempted homicide is
defined by law
depending on the facts and circumstances
of each particular case
while the law separates intentional
homicides into two degrees there are
certain elements that are common to each
both attempted and second degree intent
both attempted first and second degree
intentional homicide require that the
defendant have intended to kill another
that he act did acts towards the
commission of that crime which indicate
unequivocally under all the
circumstances that he had formed that
intent and would have caused the death
of the other
except for the intervention of another
person or some extraneous Factor it will
also be important for you to consider
the privilege of self-defense in
deciding which crime if any the
defendant has committed
the criminal court of Wisconsin provides
that a person is intent is privileged to
intentionally use Force against another
under the following circumstances
forces used for the purpose of
preventing or inter or terminating what
the person reasonably believes to be an
unlawful interference with his own
person
or by the other and he uses only that
amount of force which he reasonably
believes is necessary to prevent or
terminate the interference and the
person may not love I mean excuse me and
the person may not intentionally use
Force which is intended or likely to
cause death unless he reasonably
believes that such force is necessary to
prevent imminent death or great bodily
harm to himself
if you find that the elements of
attempted first or second degree
intentional homicide have been proved in
this case the effect of the law of
self-defense is as follows
the defendant is not guilty of either
attempted first or second-degree
intentional homicide if
he reasonably believed that he was
preventing or terminating an unlawful
interference with his own person
and he reasonably reasonably believed
the force used was necessary to prevent
death or great bodily harm to himself
he is guilty of attempted second-degree
uh intentional homicide if he actually
believe the force used was necessary to
prevent imminent death or great bodily
harm to himself but the belief or the
amount of force used was unreasonable
the defendant is guilty of attempted
first degree intentional homicide if the
defendant did not actually believe the
force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
him
because the law provides that it is the
state's burden to prove all the facts
necessary to constitute a guilty on a
reasonable doubt you will not be asked
to make a separate finding as to whether
the defendant acted in self-defense
instead you will be asked to determine
whether the state has proved the
necessary facts to justify a finding of
guilty for attempted first or second
degree intentional homicide if the state
does not satisfy you that those facts
are established by the evidence
you will be instructed to find the
defendant not guilty
the elements of each crime will now be
defined for you in Greater detail whoa
before you may find the defendant guilty
of attempted first degree intentional
homicide the state must prove by
evidence which satisfies you beyond a
reasonable doubt that the following
three elements were pressed
first that the defendant had intended to
kill another
second that he did ask which demonstrate
unequivocally under all of the
circumstances that he had formed the
intent and would have caused the death
of another except for the intervention
of another person or some other
extraneous Factor unequivocally means
that no other inference or conclusion
can reasonably and fairly be drawn from
the defendant's acts under the
circumstances
another person means anyone other than
the defendant
include the intended victim
an extraneous factor is something
outside the knowledge of the defendant
or outside of his control
the Third
element is that the defendant did not
actually be believed that the force used
was necessary to prevent imminent death
or great bodily harm to himself
the third element of attempted first
degree intentional homicide requires
that that the defendant did not actually
believe the amount of force was
necessary
to prevent imminent death or great
bodily harm to himself
this requires the state to prove either
that the defendant did not actually
believe that he was in imminent danger
of death or good badly harm
or that the defendant did not actually
believe that the amount of force used
was necessary to prevent to prevent
imminent danger of death or great bodily
harm to himself
when attempted first degree intentional
homicide is considered the
reasonableness of the defendant's belief
is not an issue you are to be concerned
only with what the defendant actually
believed whether these beliefs are
reasonable is important only if you
later consider whether the defendant is
guilty of attempted second-degree
intentional homicide
if as to the fifth count you were
satisfied Beyond a reasonable doubt that
the defendant intended to kill another
human being and that his acts
demonstrate unequivocally that the
defendant intended to kill and would
have killed the other except for the
intervention of another person or some
other extraneous factor and that he did
not actually believe that the force used
was necessary to prevent imminent death
or great bodily harm to himself you
should find the defendant guilty of
attempted first degree intentional
homicide
if you are not So Satisfied then you
must find the defendant not guilty of
attempted first degree intentional
homicide and must consider whether the
defendant is guilty of attempting
second-degree homicide intentional
which is a lesser included offense of
intentional
homicide of the first degree
again you should make every reasonable
effort to agree unanimously on the
charge of attempted first degree
intentional homicide before considering
the offense of attempted second-degree
intentional homicide however after f
after a full and complete consideration
of the evidence you conclude that
further deliberation would not result in
a unanimous agreement on the charge of
attempted first degree intentional
homicide you should consider whether the
defendant is guilty of attempted second
degree intentional homicide
before you may find the defendant guilty
of second-degree intentional homicide
the state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond a reasonable doubt
that the following three elements were
present
first that the defendant intended to
kill another second that he did acts
which demonstrate unequivocally under
all of the circumstances that he had
formed that intent and would have caused
the death of another human being
except for the intervention of another
person or some other extraneous Factor
the third element is that the defendant
did not reasonably believe that he was
preventing or terminating an unlawful
interference with his own person and or
did not reasonably believe that the
force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily heart I
know that the jurors will have this on
paper but how much do you think
anybody's really retaining when it's
being read to them like this
position equivocally another person and
extraneous Factor the same definitions
apply to your consideration of attempted
second degree intentional homicide
the third element of attempt at second
degree intentional homicide requires
that the defendant could not reasonably
believe that he was
preventing or terminating an unlawful
interference with his own person or did
not reasonably believe that the force
used was necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself
this requires that the state have proved
any one of the following first that the
reasonable person and the circumstances
of the defendant would not have believed
that he was preventing or terminating an
unlawful interference with his own
person or that a reasonable person in
the circumstances of the defendant would
not have believed that he was in danger
of imminent death of great bodily harm
or that the uh that a reasonable person
in the circumstances of the defendant
would not have believed that the amount
of force used was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself
the reason illness of the defendant's
belief must be determined from the
standpoint of the defendant at the time
of his acts and not from the Viewpoint
of the jury now the standard is when a
person of ordinary intelligence and
Prudence would have believed in the
position of the defendant under the
circumstances existing at the time of
the alleged conduct
if after the fifth County were satisfied
Beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant intended to kill and that the
defendant's acts demonstrated
unequivocally that the defendant
intended to kill and would have killed
another except for the intervention of
another person or some other extraneous
factor and that the defendant did not
reasonably believe that his that he was
preventing or terminating an unlawful
interference with his own person or did
not reasonably believe that the force
used was necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself
you should find the defendant guilty of
attempted second-degree intentional
homicide
if you are not So Satisfied beyond the
reasonable doubt that the defendant is
guilty of attempted first or second
degree intentional homicide you must
determine whether the defendant is
guilty of the Lesser included offense a
first degree Reckless endangering
safeties recklessly endangering safety
as defined in the criminal code which is
a lesser included offense of attempted
first and second degree
attention
first degree recklessly endangering
safety is defined in the criminal quote
is committed by one who recklessly
endangers the safety of another human
being under circumstances which show
utter disregard for human life
before you may find the defendant guilty
of first degree reckless endangerment
the state must prove by evidence which
satisfies you beyond a reasonable doubt
that the following three elements were
present
first they had the defendant in danger
of the safety of another human being
second that he did so by criminally
Reckless conduct which means that his
conduct created a risk of death or great
bodily harm to another and that the risk
of death or great bodily harm was on
reasonable and substantial and that he
was aware that his conduct created the
unreasonable and substantial risk just a
reminder guys free Kyle in all caps gets
you banned and let's go Brandon gets you
banned just as a reminder I think we've
banned 50 people already today was this
permanent serious serious permanent
disfigurement or which causes a
permanent or protracted loss or
impairment of the function of any badly
member or organ or other serious bodily
injury
third that the circumstances of the
defendant's conduct showed utter
disregard for human life in determining
whether the circumstances of the conduct
showed utter disregard for human life
you should consider these factors what
the defendant was doing why he was doing
it
how dangerous was the conduct how
obvious was the danger whether the
conduct showed any regard for life and
all the facts and circumstances relating
to the conduct
if you are satisfied they had all three
elements of this offense have been
proved Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
and that the state has proved Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt that the defendant was
not acting lawfully in self-defense then
you should find the defendant guilty of
reckless endangerment of the first
degree as Char has submitted
if you are not So Satisfied then you
must find the defendant not guilty
you are not in any event to find the
defendant guilty of more than one
of
any sequence of offenses so you can
return only one verdict per come you
should consider the charged offense
first
if you find unanimously that the
defendant is guilty of the highest
degree of crime
you need not consider lesser included
offenses if you decide unanimously the
defendant
did not commit the greater crime and was
acting lawfully in self-defense
it was a juror asking a question I got
myself into a mid-sentence and I don't
like it
no
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
warm food around noon
foreign
I do want to say a big thank you to Adam
Janna's and Anthony Blackman who just
signed up at joinpakman.com and our new
members 11 and 12. today you can use the
code uncharged pickles uncharged
piccolos also want to say thank you to
Kate Davis Kate made a pledge on patreon
patreon.com davidpackman show patreon
counts double today meaning that puts us
at 14 already really appreciate that and
appreciate everybody who's been
supporting the streams throughout the
trial this is the 11th weekday in a row
with a written house stream
um and uh we don't know whether the jury
will get the case today the way it's
going I mean listen guys the judge was
talking about the jury will have the
case by 4 pm our time
that's only four hours and 15 minutes
from now they still have a half hour
lunch the completion of these
instructions and up to five hours of
closing statements I don't see this
going to the jury today but we will see
the defense was saying we're actually
going to be kind of short in our in our
closing statement so I don't know
um I'm guessing that everybody's
standing because the jury is now being
excused there there's I guess something
they want to discuss further
um
yeah
so we're going to stand by and look into
all of that
we don't know what lunch is scheduled to
be today we just we just don't know by
the way how are the calzones the food is
here let's take a break lunch is here
pizza is here in fact we have Subway
tomorrow
all right enjoy your lunch all right how
was the KFC very good um food warm food
around noon yeah
all right so now they continue
the concern that I have and I you know
I've worked with the instructions uh
all weekend and we discussed them by
email and then I'm reading them
and little things are striking me as I
read them
um but the jurors are never told to
actually discuss self-defense except
except in the context of charged
offenses and what I was about to say to
the jury and decided I better talk to
you people beforehand is if the jury
gets into a discussion of
of uh first of a charge defense any
charge defense but let's use this one as
an example
um
and they decide that he's the elements
are there and he wasn't acting lawfully
in self-defense they're done
they never they never discussed the
lessers what was or was not acting
lawfully and so what well let's see if
they decide the elements are there but
he was this is going to be all day
was uh
not acting lawfully in self-defense
they're done
then they find him guilty of the charged
crime
what if they if they discuss come on or
count five I should say and decide that
the elements are there
but they all decide it was privileged
under the law of self-defense
they're not is there anywhere that
they're being told are they being told
you're done
see under the Old Law we did do that is
that in here where is it saying that
yeah that's what I used to construct
these from scratch
and we were I would tell the jury what
which I was just doing now
that you know once you have exhausted
this you're done
uh as opposed to having them needlessly
go through these lessers if they've
already concluded
that uh and and this is a case where
this could happen I'm missing it short
or wood
saying it could that they would decide
well look yeah the elements are there
and then they make a decision
[Music]
of uh
then they have really should not be
considering
lesser included
am I right wrong about that
so if they find
perfect self-defense
on the charged count yeah
they should be told
you see what this is yeah I'm sorry I
mean I understand where the Court's
coming from I guess they could consider
the other ones in 30 seconds and just
find go down to be not guilty but
they're so complicated as it is no I
understand I feel I just I I feel
terrible about giving this kind of stuff
it's it's it's just so well anyway
um you don't see what the what the com
what what the instruction is telling
them that kind of cryptically
um
it says if after it tells them if after
a full discussion
this is one of the most poorly managed
cases it's the most poorly managed case
I've ever covered let me just speak to
that
hey thanks to Hannah lorber for the
patreon pledge patreon counts double
today putting us at 16. also the coupon
code uncharged pickles remains available
for your privileged use at
joinpakman.com uncharged piccolos
all right we're gonna end this poll
and we're gonna do a new poll
uh it says however if after a full and
complete consideration of the evidence
you conclude that further deliberation
would not result in unanimous agreement
on the charge of second-degree
intentional Amazon I'm going back to a
different account a few more bands
guilty so it is telling them
it is telling them
yeah I I just think it's kind of unclear
I think it's very unclear what you're
saying is the law
they all agree that the elements are met
and there's a privilege you don't go any
further
pardon me
pattern instruction makes that clear
enough if they unanimously agree which
includes the privilege they're done
they don't have to go forward they going
where does it use
it says you should make every reasonable
effort to agree unanimously on the
charge of second-degree intentional
homicide before considering the offense
of first-degree regular's homicide
however if after a full and complete
consideration of the evidence
you conclude that further deliberation
would not result in unanimous agreement
on the charge of second-degree homicide
consider whether the defendant is guilty
of first-degree Reckless homicide so
they're um I I don't think it's
but it's not the way
a person would speak if he wanted to
make things clear and I'm not saying
anyone didn't know it's trying to make
things unclear but anyone could say that
about all 30 some pages
that's not a joke don't do that people
will find out our lawyer's secret
um I think it's clear in the
instructions if the court did wish to
say just explain if you're unanimous
either way on
first count there's no need to go to the
lessons yeah I think that's a good way
to do it I think I'll tell them that in
any sequence if there are lessers
submitted to them
once they've discussed the highest count
if they are unanimous either way
uh
then they're done
that make sense
no Mr Binger is having a problem with
that and let's see where he is or what
he's
Mr Binger I actually I don't like the
way I said that either
up uh
aside from any one aspect this all feels
like it's a bogus trial with a
conclusion that's foregone which is
going to be not guilty on all the major
accounts like it all of this is crazy
but it's details I think there was never
really a shot at guilty on those
yeah please proceed governor
how about this in any count where in any
count where there are
lesser charges oh
if at any point in your deliberations
you are unanimous either as to both the
elements the presence or absence of the
elements
of the crime
and the presence or absence of the right
of self-defense
you need go no further
the reason the reason I was shaking my
head honor is because let's take
um Anthony Huber's counts for example
yeah if the jury is unanimous that he is
guilty a first reintentional homicide
they go no further right if they are
unanimous that he's not guilty a first
degree intentional homicide then they
are instructed to consider secondary
intentional homicide only if they're not
satisfied that it was done in
self-defense
if they for example if they if in your
example if they discussed it and said
well sure the elements of of attempt
murder are there
and then they go around the table and
they say well we all think it's it's not
self-defense then guilty if they all say
we don't think is well actually if they
all say we don't think of self-defense
then it's not guilty and what the jury
is being told is if you can't agree
unanimously
then consider these lessers but I don't
think it's so clear as it should be the
problem is the rubric he's setting out
means there's no time at which they
would really consider the Lesser charges
before it was originally proposing is
telling the jury
unanimous
um the charge count one way or the other
then you go no further I like that
that's not that's not the law
if you're a unanimous on
so for example you know if you're
unanimous on the legal question
intentional
well you're right because it could be an
element's issue
the jury maybe the constructions
committee is right this jury only goes
to lesser included if they are either
unable to agree on the charge count or
if they're unanimous not guilty on the
charge count then they go to the Lesser
included
so there is no requirement after all
this the judge is lining it up for there
to be no way to consider lesser included
but we'll see
if they're unanimous then they're done
that's what I'm trying to tell them but
I don't know how to say it but that's
not true because if they're unanimous on
first degree intentional homicide what
they're concluding at that point is that
the defendant either the elements aren't
met or the defendant actually believed
that deadly force was necessary
they would still then have to consider
the secondary intentional because it
changes the self-defense into the
objective reasonable one so
they can be unanimous on count one let's
take Huber for example they can be
unanimous on uh the first degree
intentional homicide
they can be an atoms on that
and in the defendant's favor
but they still have to then move to the
second element or to this the Lesser
included
okay
no you might be right
so pardon me if they if it's perfect
self-defense it's perfect self-defense
for everything but they're not totally
consider perfect self-defense
um first degree intentional homicide
they're specifically told
well yeah they're you're right he's
right he's right they're not told
consider that until second degree
intentional homicide the instructions
you're on are the pattern instructions I
understand your point that they if we
had to redraft them today from scratch
maybe we could do better but I we I'm
sure we could but we need to follow them
and I don't know right
I think you're right it um and they're
certainly correct in what they say I
just think that they're not
clear but maybe maybe they are I don't
know
now let's see how much damage I've done
already by my last paragraph so can you
walk to what the last thing I said to
the jury
dear God remind me
by the way how are the calzones
big thank you to Kyle Dowdy and Patricia
Rowan who just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com our new member 17 and 18
great people great people we love you
here at the show and really appreciate
your support of our work
you can use the coupon code uncharged
pickles today to get a 69 discount
uncharged piccolos
if you're just joining us there was an
interruption to the 36 pages of jury
instructions they're just rereading what
he said there was an interruption to the
36 pages of jury instructions after 30
minutes of debate about them
uh as to how to explain to the jury what
are the circumstances of considering the
Lesser included charges we still then
will have up to five hours of closing so
it this is almost certainly going to go
into tomorrow unless they go long today
man was acting lawfully in self-defense
you know
if he was acting lawfully in
self-defense that the ball game's over
oh my God yeah
I I think that's correct even
your your suggestion is seductive Mr
Binger but
[Music]
um
but if they if but see they're not asked
to consider that that's that's where I'm
having the problem
there you know they may even make
reference to it the funny thing is as if
these jurors will even have a
sensitivity to these nuances
we don't have like some states too they
have a question right off the bat was
the defendant acting lawfully in
self-defense if they answer that yes
we're all done
we've got to Inner interlaced in all
these cumbersome instructions and uh
no does anyone have any objection to
what I've already told the jury
and tell them what
just what we said
if you find perfect self-defense you
don't go on to the next count it's over
I understand what the term perfect
self-defense means but we haven't told
the jury what that means we're we're
deviating from the standard instructions
here and the words perfect self-defense
don't have a meaning to Ordinary People
would require further definition from
the court and now we're going much
further afield I also have a problem
with
um
the wording of you know do we do you
find if you find the defendant um is
Justified in his self-defense because
we've instructed them on
um his own uh yeah can you imagine is it
self-defense yes was the self-defense
Justified no what and then we've given
instruction on what the law considers to
be objective self-defense is what a
reasonable person would think when we
when the wording that was just read by
The Madam court reporter
doesn't delineate between those two
things and I I think as I said and I've
repeated here several times I think the
more we deviate from these standard
instructions the more confusion it
causes Council has asked you to read the
self-defense individually on each count
so they're already being told on each
count that you are to consider the
objective the final thing is the
objective self-defense and that is a
you know if you find that then he's not
guilty and to say across the board that
you find self-defense is a defense to
everything is not technically true
because there are different self-defense
claims as to the different counts so for
example he may be justified the
self-defense as to Rosenbaum but not as
to humor so from a blanket statement
that says anytime you find Justified
self-defense he's not guilty is not
technically true well it is if you're
talking just about an individual account
but I was saying blankets and I think I
think what I'm going to tell
in addition to what I've already said
is if they
are discussing an account
that has multiple possible verdicts I
think the standard instruction already
spells that out your honor it I agree if
we had to do it from scratch we could do
it better but I don't think we should
deviate any further because I think it's
causing confusion what Madam court
reporter just read back for example
could be construed as saying anytime
with regard to any count you find
Justified self-defense he walks on all
five counts and that is that is
absolutely when I intend to tell them at
all I know I know you don't tend to tell
that but what's already been said
gives that implication and again I just
worry that the more we deviate from
these standard instructions the more we
get into these issues I think we should
stick with what you drafted which has
been sent to the parties we've all
agreed on them and I am leery of any
additional language that hasn't been
cleared by the parties and could cause
further confusion well I I uh and and
I could say that whenever I've dealt
with lesser included I do give a little
talk about
um
how they you know how they should
address them
and this is this is a more complicated
case than most
than any frankly that I can remember
um
I don't think I've said anything
incorrect so far
I don't want to step into something that
I haven't already
done
um
I am inclined though because I've made a
statement about
if everything's present they're done
because they found their defended guilty
and I do think I probably should give
the alternative which is and I'm not
going to use terms like perfect
self-defense like he did I'm going to
use the term acted lawfully in
self-defense and they're instructed on
that so I think the correct statement is
if as to any of the cases with multiple
submissions
if
on any individual account
they find
in their consideration of the charge
defense
that the defendant acted lawfully in
self-defense
they're done
the gears of Justice are turning any
objection
okay and while we're talking about the
jury instructions uh it was noticed as
you read them on page 10 which is Count
three it should be first degree reckless
endangerment and you it's written and
you read homicide uh which is not a
homicide count so page 10
page 10 on count still at the end of
count three it says you should find the
defendant guilty of first yeah you're
right you're right it is in there as
homicide uh we didn't catch that last
night when we talked about him I sent
you three drafts uh it's your fault not
his but I you know what should I just
leave that alone they'll know that I'll
change it in the printed copy
okay okay thanks wow
exposing before lunch now it's after 11.
uh
how long are you gonna talk origin in
your first sequence
I'm trying to limit myself in two hours
[Laughter]
are
you
uh
uh troubled by taking a break in the
middle of your presentation well let's
just kind of plan on around noon because
the lunch is already been ordered so
um and I'm not going to comment on the
lunch lunch is here
he's not gonna comment on the lunch
uh
break it
well around noon
uh just asked for the breakup
yeah well when he's the commander of the
I don't want to interrupt him at a time
he doesn't want to be
I want to say thank you to John Franco
saracino who just made a pledge via
patreon and those count double today
which puts us at 20. I have five
incredible people to thank as well for
getting memberships on my website Nadine
Perkins thank you Nadine Patrick Dylan
and Rodney hammock Rodney and Patrick
have signed up on my website Corey
resner is a new member and also thanks
to Larry Burns who have signed up on my
website joinpakman.com we are at 25 for
the day and we are going to be here
through the end of proceedings today I
also have an exciting live stream on my
Instagram today at 6 P East 3p West with
a celebrity I will be announcing it as
soon as it's confirmed I'm standing by
because they're on the west coast they
may uh you know a little slow on the
trigger there maybe uh what I was
talking about with the cases that you
have
multiple possible verdicts submitted to
you for consideration if in when you
address the charged crime
uh if in your discussions
you conclude that the elements are
present and the defendant was not acting
lawfully
then you didn't go any further
you can return your verdict
of guilt based upon that conclusion if
in your discussions
as to any individual
count
of those with multiple possible verdicts
in your initial discussion if you decide
that the defendant acted lawfully in
self-defense
you're done
returning that guilty verdict without
considering the Lesser offenses
any question about that oh God
it hopefully will become clear I'm going
to give you written instructions
because I know this is arduous going
through this any confusion helps the
defense because they're like we're not
sure we're not guilty instructions for
your reference in
in considering these things
and we resume
counts one through five that's all the
counts now uh each contain a uh the
guilty verdicts of any
submitted offense contain a question
based upon the allegation of the
information that the defendant committed
the crimes while using a dangerous
weapon
if you find the defendant guilty of
on any of the counts you must answer the
following question did the defendant
commit the crime while using a dangerous
weapon dangerous weapon means any
firearm whether loaded or unloaded a
firearm is a weapon which acts by the
force of gunpowder
before you may find the answer the
question before you may answer the
question yes you must be satisfied
Beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant committed the crime while
using a dangerous weapon if you are not
So Satisfied then the question must be
answered no
in reaching your evidence examine the
evidence again you're reaching your
verdict to examine the evidence for the
utmost care in question react with
judgment reason and Prudence the
defendant is not required to prove his
innocence the law presumes every person
charged with a commission of a crime to
be innocent and this presumption
requires a finding of not guilty unless
in your deliberations you find that it
is overcome by evidence which satisfies
you beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant is guilty the burden of
establishing every fact necessary to
constitute guilt is upon the state
before you may return a verdictive
guilty the evidence must satisfy you
beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant is guilty
you can reconcile the evidence
upon any reasonable hypothesis
consistent with the innocence of the
defendant then you must do so and find
him not guilty
the term Reasonable Doubt means a doubt
based upon reason and Common Sense it is
a doubt for which a reason can be given
arising from a fair and rational
consideration of the evidence or want of
evidence it means such a doubt as would
cause a person of ordinary produce to
pause or hesitate when called upon to
act and the most important Affairs of
Life A Reasonable Doubt is not a doubt
which is based upon mere gospel or
speculation I doubt which arises merely
from sympathy or from Fear to return to
verdict of guilt is not a reasonable
doubt A Reasonable Doubt is not a doubt
such as may be used to escape the
responsibility of a decision
examine the evidence and search for the
truth giving the defendant the benefit
of every Reasonable Doubt
evidence is defined first as the sworn
testimony of witnesses both on direct
and cross-examination regardless of the
party who called the witness second any
exhibits which have been received
whether or not they accompany you to the
Jury Room third in effects which which
the lawyers have agreed or stipulated or
which I have directed you to find
anything that you may have seen or heard
outside the courtroom is not evidence
you are to decide the case solely on the
evidence offered received at this trial
you should disregard entirely any
question to which I did not permit an
answer do not guess what the witness's
answer might have been and if the
question itself suggested that certain
information might be true ignore the
suggestion and do not consider it as
evidence
attorneys for each side of the right and
duty to object to what they feel are
improper questions asked of witnesses
and to the receipt of other evidence
which they believe is not properly
admissible
you should not draw any inference
or conclusions from the fact that an
objection is made by allowing testimony
or other evidence to be received over
objection I did not indicate mean to
indicate any opinion as to that evidence
you jurors are the sole judges of the
believability of the witnesses and of
the weight of the evidence
at the beginning of the trial I
described the charges against the
defendant counts six and seven which
respectively charged possession of a
firearm by a minor and curfew violation
have been disposive and are no longer
part of this case the other counts
remain do not guess about or concern
yourselves with the reasons for these
dispositions it must not affect your
consideration of the charges that remain
do not consider evidence that related
only to the counts which have been
disposed of
during the trial I have ordered certain
trust testimonies stricken and you must
disregard all such stricken testimony
exhibits become evidence only when
received by the court an exhibit which
was marked for identification but not
received is not evidence
whether or not
excuse me uh is not of us an exhibit
received is evidence whether or not it
accompanies you to the Jury Room
remarks of the lawyers are not evidence
and if the remarks suggest certain facts
not in evidence disregard the suggestion
consider carefully the closing arguments
of the attorneys but their arguments
opinions and conclusions are not
evidence draw your own conclusions from
the evidence and decide upon your
verdict
upon the evidence and instructions given
you by the court
I have taken judicial notice of certain
facts and you are directed to accept
them as true
the state has introduced evidence of
statements which it claims were made by
the defendant it is for you to determine
how much weight if any to give to any
statement and evaluating each statement
you must consider three things whether
the statement was actually made by the
defendant only so much of a statement as
was actually made by a person may be
considered in evidence
whether the state was accurately
restated here at the trial whether the
statement or any part of it ought to be
believed you should consider the facts
and circumstances the round surrounding
the making of each statement along with
all other evidence and determining how
much weight if any the statement is
the weight of the evidence does not
depend on the number of Witnesses on
each site you may find the testimony of
one witness and entitled a greater
weight than that of another witness and
you may give it such weight in
considering your verdicts
and awaiting the evidence you may take
into account matters of your common
knowledge and your observations and
experiences in the Affairs of life
ordinarily Witnesses May testify only
about fakes however Witnesses with
specialized knowledge in particular
Fields May Give opinions in those fields
in determining the weight that you give
to these opinions you should consider
the qualifications and The credibility
of the expert
the effects upon which the opinions are
based and the reasons given for the
opinion opinion evidence was received to
help you reach a conclusion however you
are not bound by any Witnesses opinion
it is your duty as jurors to scrutinize
and weigh the testimony of the witnesses
and to determine the effect of the
evidence as a whole you are the sole
judges of The credibility that is the
believability of the witnesses and of
the weight to be given to their
testimony
in determining the credibility of The
credibility of each witness and the
weight you give to the testimony of each
you should consider these factors
whether the witness is interested or
disinterested in the outcome of this
trial conduct appearance and demeanor on
the witness stand the clarity or lack of
clarity of the witness's Recollections
the opportunity which the witness had to
know enough deserve the matters and
things about which testimony was given
the reasonableness of the witness's
testimony the witnesses apparent
intelligence
bias or Prejudice if any has been shown
possible motives to falsify and all
other facts and circumstances during the
trial which tend either to support or to
discredit the testimony and then give
the testimony of each witness the weight
you believe is entitled to receive
the defendant has testified in this case
and you should not discredit his
testimony just because he is charged
with a crime he was the same factors to
determine the credibility and weight of
the defendant's testimony that you use
to evaluate the testimony of other
Witnesses
there is no magical way for you to
evaluate the testimony instead you
should use your common sense and your
experience in your everyday lives you
determine for yourselves the reliability
of statements made to you by others and
you and you should do the same thing
here
evidence has been received the two of
the Witnesses in this trial have
previously been convicted of crimes this
evidence was received solely because it
Bears upon their character for
truthfulness it must not be used for any
other purpose
we're going to hear the closing you know
what does anybody want a break even just
a short one or not you want to go right
into your discount anybody need a break
okay we're going to hear the closing
arguments of the attorneys now here we
go
they
um
the uh the we follow the classical
debate format in the court and that is
that the defense of the proponent of a
proposition is entitled to give uh the
first and the last argument
so um Mr Binger will address you first
on behalf of the state then Mr Richards
for the defense and then after uh his
remarks one of the attorneys for the
state will be addressing you on behalf
of the state and rebuttal limited to
rebuttal of things stayed stated by Mr
Richards during his presentation
the um
the
um
a break obviously I'm not going to make
you sit there for five hours unless you
watch it
um
um and uh so we'll break I miss her uh I
asked Mr Binger while you were out of
the room uh if he was comfortable with
breaking his arm the audio has become
unsynced we're just going to do a quick
refresh could be the court
room
uh if he was comfortable with breaking
his argument in parts and he he was so
at a time he thinks is appropriate
around noon noon will take a
we'll take our lunch break warm food
around noon and then pick up this
afternoon and then after all of the
arguments have been presented I'll give
you about three or four more minutes of
instruction and then we'll do our
striking with the tumbler over there and
uh it'll be yours so um let me ask you
which one do you want
the sisters pointer okay thanks to
sander Degroot for signing up on my
website joinpakman.com thanks Xander
but hey I'll take a vote right now
supposing the case arguments are
finished at
4 4 30 5 o'clock and we'll be working
well to get there uh how many would like
to begin their deliberations tonight and
stay until
a later hour or
how many would like to come back and
start fresh in the morning hmm uh and
the cutoff point would be
say we got finished by four and I give
you the case
uh and um I don't think they're going to
be done at least I would let you go if
you didn't want to stay late would
probably be about five five o'clock
uh and so I don't know how much you'd
get done but uh you'd have the option to
get started this is this uh today
or we just start fresh in the morning if
it's if we finish up anytime after
330 or 4 o'clock
so how many would want to continue on
today
one two three four five six
eight out of
when you would rather come back fresh
tomorrow all right how was the KFC very
good we're coming back uh but uh well
okay let's I and of course as always
I'll make the final final decision but I
certainly will try to follow your wishes
so okay with that Mr Binger it's yours
thank you judge
good morning ladies and gentlemen
I want to assure you that everything
that the judge just read to you you'll
get a copy of so you'll have a chance to
look it over yourself you don't have to
memorize everything he just told you
I think it's no surprise that this is a
case that there's a lot of noise and a
lot of static surrounding it
so what I'd like to do at the beginning
is crystallize it in a nutshell for you
and keep it as simple as possible
this is a case in which a 17 year old
teenager killed two unarmed men and
severely wounded a third person with an
AR-15 that did not belong them
this isn't a situation where he was
protecting his home or his family
he killed people after traveling here
from Antioch Illinois and staying out
after a city-wide curfew
I knew it
will curfew charge anymore there's no
gun charge I knew that that was coming
although he claimed there's no charge
but
um and and
they're
there there has been some discussion
about the lawfulness of the curve you're
not in this case but elsewhere so it's
there but there was had been a curfew
announced wow that does not mean that
um it was technically lawfully uh
legal curfew but there I've been wow
can you imagine that all the rest of us
here in Kenosha were aware of and I
think most people most reasonable people
obeyed
although the defendant claimed to be
protecting a business that he wasn't
familiar with the actual killings in
this case had nothing to do with that
and he also spent the entire evening
lying about the fact that he was an EMT
none of the things that I just told you
are in doubt in this case
so when we think about the defendant
I'd like you to consider as you think
about this case what were his true
motivations were
was this a situation where he sincerely
cared about car Source even though he'd
never heard of it never bought anything
there never worked there and not even
its owners were out there that night
protecting it
was he genuinely interested in helping
people
he ran around with an AR-15 all night
and lied about being an EMT does that
suggest to you that he genuinely is
there to help
he's not there
for the same purpose as the protesters
so why was he there
that night
when you think about these things I
think there are some things that we can
all agree on
in America it's hard these days people
are polarized and there's a lot of
political issues back and forth and the
judges made it clear this case is not
about politics
there is Common Ground here
we have all agreed and I asked you this
two weeks ago today
raise your hand if you agree life is
more important than property and all of
you raised your hand
we also agree that no one person's life
is more valuable than another
you don't get to kill someone simply
because they're a drug dealer you don't
weigh a pastor's life over a teacher's
life you don't weigh a police officer's
life over an engineer's life
all life is sacred
I think we can also agree that we
shouldn't have 17 year olds running
around our streets with AR-15s
because this is exactly what happens
and finally I want you to keep in mind
that we've all read stories and heard
about heroes that step in to stop an
active shooter or to give their life to
save others in fact many people in
Wisconsin went out and got carrying
concealed weapon permits just so that
they could be there in case there was an
active shooter and wanting to stop them
so when you consider this case look for
the truth
so many people look at this case and
they see what they want to see they have
a preconceived notion and they tailor
the facts to fit whatever they believe
and you all agreed to keep an open mind
you all told us you didn't have any of
those preconceived notions
now you've heard the evidence and it's
time to search for the truth
so consider for example whether or not
it's heroic or honorable to provoke and
shoot unarmed people consider whether it
makes someone a hero when they lie about
being an EMT wow I think all of us are
familiar with someone who does the sorts
of things that the defendant has done
they enjoy the thrill of going around
and telling people what to do without
the courage or the honor
to back it up and without the legal
authority to do so
and when you think about the defendant's
behavior in this case contrast it
with Anthony Huber
a man who was there because he knew
Jacob Blake who carried his skateboard
everywhere and who rushed towards danger
to save other people's lives
so when I talk to you here in my closing
argument I'm going to focus first on the
murders that the defendant committed
second I'm going to address some
background issues give you some context
and talk about some of the things that I
don't think are relevant to this case
and finally I'm going to tie it all into
the jury instructions that the judge
just gave you well done so far
as prosecutors in this case my colleague
Jim Krause and I have tried to present
you with all of the relevant evidence
that we think you should consider in
this case and I told one of you in jury
selection that at the end of this you
would be the expert you would have all
the information you would be the one
Who would know all about this case and
make that decision and that's what we've
tried to do
so let's go to August 25th 2020.
the defendant came from outside our
community
carrying a gun that wasn't his
because he expected and anticipated
violence that night
and he pretended to guard what turned
out to be an empty building owned by
people he'd never even met
while fraudulently claiming all night
long
to be an EMT elements of medical
there were a lot of people out that
night
some people stayed home protecting their
homes and their families others went to
their businesses boarded them up and
protected them and a lot of those people
had weapons
a lot of them had guns
there were other people who came along
to protect car Source or ultimate gas or
other businesses and many of them were
armed with AR-15s just like the
defendant in fact you're going to see a
video and you've already seen it of a
clash between people with AR-15s at
ultimate gas and other folks that are I
guess protesters and there's
people getting in people's faces there's
yelling they're shouting there's even
shoving
and yet
in this entire sequence of events from
the shooting of Jacob Blake on Sunday
August 23 2020 all the way after that
everything this community went through
the only person who shot and killed
anyone was the defendant
yes there was property damage no one's
here to defend that no one's here to
tell you it's okay to commit arson or
looting no one's here to tell you it's
okay to be rioters I'm not defending any
of that
you know because you've been told in the
testimony I'm Prosecuting Joseph
zaminski for arson
that's not okay
but what you don't get to do is kill
someone on the street for committing
arson
so let's keep that in mind
when we're talking about the people
involved in this case
so let's begin
with the provocation
and the murder
of Joseph rosenbaugh because it's all
captured on video
as the defendant and Mr Rosenbaum arrive
at the 63rd Street Car source Mr
Rosenbaum is ahead of the defending and
as you see in the FBI video when Mr
Rosenbaum starts to run the defendant
starts to run as well at the same time
as if he's pursuing him
Mr Rosenbaum
could not have possibly have known the
defendant is behind him there's no
indication in this record that he knew
the defendant was there it's not an
ambush it's not a situation where he
goes there and lays in wait for the
defendant
the defendant rise at that location and
you hear him yell friendly friendly
friendly
because he's aware of the fact that the
people that he's about to confront are
hostile to him
and I'm going to show you in a moment
the video in which the first thing he
does when he arrives at that location is
drops the fire extinguisher that he's
holding in his left hand so he can raise
the gun with his right and left hands
and point it
this is when you hear someone
I think the testimony is Rosenbaum it's
not clear to me but either way yell gun
gun
and then Mr Rosenbaum charges around to
try and stop the defendant from pointing
his gun or shooting anyone
so let's take a look at some of that
video
very childish people getting themselves
banned in the chat it's this is exhibit
73 the full drone video
and as we've pointed out to you before
and Jim will point out to you here in a
second on the screen
when the defendant originally arrives at
that scene the first thing you see him
do is drop the fire extinguisher and
point
his weapon at people and then the chase
occurs right after that
and you're going to see that entire
sequence of events here on the full
drone video
the defendant turns as he's being
pursued and points the gun at Mr
Rosenbaum and then as he enters the area
between the parked cars he slows and
turns and before Mr Rosenbaum can even
come close he Fires at him shooting and
knock him to the ground
now I'm going to show you the slowed
down and zoomed in video of the
defendant when he first gets there and
Mr Krause is going to help me by
directing your attention on the larger
screen here to exactly where you will
see the defendant
I'm gonna replay it a few times so you
can see quite clearly that the defendant
sets the fire extinguisher on the ground
with his left hand
and then brings his left hand over to
the gun and raises it and points back in
five
guys check the gun make sure it's empty
under Wisconsin law you're not allowed
to run around and point your gun at
people this is the provocation
this is what starts this incident
the defendant rushes in and immediately
points the gun
and as you'll see in a little bit Mr
Rosenbaum doesn't take kindly to people
pointing guns
I don't think anyone does That's Not
Unusual
no one wants to have the gun pointed at
them and no one wants to watch anyone
else do this to someone else
we have the gun it is in evidence as
exhibit number 28
I'm having the detectives check it to
make sure that it is safe
the defendant comes running in and drops
the fire extinguisher on the ground like
this
and then raises his left hand to the gun
and points
this is what we see in the video
in putting the fire extinguisher on the
ground and then raising the gun
your honor I'm going to check he's
facing the wrong direction
that's an argument okay
to actually have well I'll leave it
alone
so what you see in that video is his
left arm reaching for the gun holding it
up
you can see it again on the video here
his left arm reaching up towards the gun
that is what provokes this entire
incident
and one of the things to keep in mind is
that when the defendant provokes the
incident he loses the right to
self-defense you cannot claim
self-defense against a danger you create
that's critical right here
if you're the one who is threatening
others you lose the right to claim
self-defense
then we have the chase that occurs after
that
and we have taken that drone video and
we have slowed down portions of that
chase for you
so what we have right here on the screen
this is exhibit 84. and this is the
middle portion of that incident and you
can see Mr Rosenbaum chasing after the
defendant throwing that plastic bag and
then the defendant turns and points the
gun back at Mr Rosenbaum and this is the
moment in time when Mr Rosenbaum
essentially does sort of a little hop
with both of his hands in the air
and the defendant has testified
he saw at that moment that there was
nothing in the defendant's hand or the
Mr rosenbaum's hands he was unarmed
there's the defendant turning and
pointing the gun Mr Rosenbaum leaps his
hands out to the air and then watch here
at the end
this is where the shooting occurs
Mr Rosenbaum is not even within Arm's
Reach when the first shot occurs
I'll play that again
the defendant is pointing the gun at Mr
Rosenbaum Mr Rosenbaum raises his arms
off to the side
the defendant approaches these cars and
slows down
and then turns and shoots Mr Rosenbaum
finally I'm going to play you exhibit
86.
this shows you the final part of that
zoomed in and slowed down here is the
defendant running in between those
parked cars slowing down and you can see
just how close or rather how far away Mr
Rosenbaum was when the defendant shot
him
foreign
you can see from this video that Mr
Rosenbaum is not even within Arm's Reach
of the defendant when the first shot
goes off
the defendant fires four shots in quick
succession
and I'll come back to this in a moment
but you'll note during this entire
sequence it's the defendant who chooses
where to go
he's the one who decides to run where he
runs
and he slows down right as he gets to
these parked cars
that's what allows Rosenbaum to get
closer
we've seen this on the aerial footage
from the FBI and I want you to see that
perspective as well
this is exhibit 25. this is the
annotated aerial footage you see the
defended approach running in the same
directions Mr Rosenbaum
this is where the pointing occurs in the
direction of the zaminski's
you can see Joshua zaminski's right
there on the screen
I'm going to put the cursor over where
the zabinskis are they're right in there
the defendant is pointing his gun right
here
and he's pointing it in the direction of
the zaminski's because they're standing
next to that car
and then the chase occurs now what's
interesting to me is watch when the
crowd starts to run
the crowd's already starting to run here
even before the defendant has fired a
shot
that's likely because they heard the
first shot from Joshua zaminski
and the crowd starts to run away
the defendant has testified that that
shot from Mr zaminski
had nothing to do with his decision to
kill Joseph Rosenbaum and I'll come back
to that in a second
finally I'm going to show you this
incident from the perspective of Drew
Hernandez because he is behind all of
this and then he comes upon Mr
rosenbaum's body
is that audio playing
[Applause]
sure why you're not hearing any audio on
that
is Brian around he's not all right can
you text Brian please
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
at this point the defendant has shot and
killed Joseph Rosenbaum and Mr Rosenbaum
is laying face down that's where he
falls
Richie McGinnis actually rolls him over
after trying to stem the bleeding here
you can see in the foreground that
plastic bag that Mr Rosenbaum threw on
the ground I don't think there's any
dispute there was nothing harmful in
that bag it was a clear bag containing
some uh some clear items
then you can make that dispute in your
argument
argument and you'll be allowed to
respond
so you can see in this video the crowd
is attempting to save Mr rosenbaum's
life
oh yeah
you're okay
so
we have shown you
defendant murdering Joseph Rosenbaum
from three different angles the Drone
footage Drew Hernandez and also the uh
FBI video
the defendant admitted that during this
entire incident he knew that Joseph
Rosenbaum was unarmed
I'm going to come back to this in a
little while but there's this alleged
threat
that Mr Rosenbaum made earlier in the
evening to kill the defendant I will
debunk that that did not happen it is
the one fact in this case the defendant
wants you to believe that there's no
video of and in fact I have the video of
the entire incident I've played it for
you and I'll show it to you again
there's no threat
there's also no evidence that Mr
Rosenbaum
he never said I'm going to take your gun
he never said I want your gun there's no
indication of that
Dr Kelly has testified that the first
shot that the defendant fired at Joseph
Rosenbaum hit the victim in the right
pelvis fracturing it
Mr Rosenbaum was incapacitated at that
point
he is whatever threat he might have
posed he's it's over there is no further
threat he is falling to the ground
and the defendant doesn't stop
after that first shot he tracks
Mr rosenbaum's body all the way down
firing three more shots
a second shot which goes through Mr
rosenbaum's Hand
and then a third and fourth shot one
that grazes the right scalp and one that
goes right into Mr rosenbaum's back and
that is the kill shot
that is the one
that took Mr rosenbaum's life
there is no evidence that Mr Rosenbaum
was reaching for the defendant's gun
and after that first shot there's no way
Mr Rosenbaum could have taken that gun
even if he wanted to he is already
falling to the ground he is helpless he
is vulnerable
and as I said the kill shot is the one
to the back
this is that wound
Dr Kelly testified that the angle of
this shot was from the left shoulder
towards the center of the back and the
bullet continued on down towards the
right lower back area
tearing through bodily organs and
killing Mr Rosenbaum
here's a picture of the wound to the to
the hand
there's been a lot of testimony about
this wound this is one in which
the evidence suggests that
Mr rosenbaum's Hand was most likely
turned in this position
Palms outward with his thumb to the
ground
when the wound the bullet goes through
the area in between his middle finger
and his ring finger and penetrates the
lower knuckle of the middle finger and
the index finger before exiting
Dr Kelly testified their soot in that
area suggesting that the hand was close
to the end of the defendant's barrel of
the AR-15 at the time of that shot
the defense wants you to believe it's
there because Mr Rosenbaum is
deliberately reaching for the gun
well that doesn't make any sense
first of all this occurs after Mr
Rosenbaum has been shot in the hip
I've got a fractured pelvis at that
point he is falling he is not able to
walk he's probably not even able to
control much of his movements at this
point
when you're reaching for that gun this
is not the way you're gonna do it
this is not
going to be effective
I submit to you ladies and gentlemen to
the the extent Mr rosenbaum's Hand ever
got close
to the end of the defendant's gun it was
completely inadvertent not at all
intentional
for people worried about the graphic
footage I was on I was actually talking
to our uh YouTube rep about the
everything that's going on everything's
fine everybody relax with any of this
there's been some focus on that because
I think the defense was hoping
they could work this into their
self-defense claim and make an argument
that that first shot by Joshua zaminski
somehow made the defendant fear for his
life
unfortunately the defendant was wasn't
on board with that because in his
testimony he told you that that shot had
nothing to do with his thought process
it didn't affect him in any way
he said he didn't think the shot came
from Joseph Rosenbaum he knew Joseph
rosenrum was unarmed and he admitted to
me you can't kill Joseph Rosenbaum for
something Joshua zaminsky did
so let's just carve Joshua zaminsky out
of this case I'll deal with him on his
arson trial in January
but until then
it doesn't factor into any of the
decisions the defendant made and in fact
as you see on the FBI video the
zaminski's continue walking straight on
down the sidewalk they don't pursue the
defendant they don't threaten the
defendant in any way
now the defense wants you to think
Joseph Rosenbaum was there to attack the
defendant
we'll never know
what Joseph Rosenbaum was thinking
because the defendant killed him
so we're just guessing
but let's assume for a minute yeah
Joseph Rosenbaum is chasing after the
defendant because he wants to do some
physical harm to him he's an unarmed man
this is a bar fight this is a fist fight
this is a fight that maybe many of you
have been involved in two people hand to
hand were throwing punches we're pushing
we're shoving or whatever
but what you don't do is you don't bring
a gun to a fist fight
yeah
what the defendant wants you to believe
is that because he's the one who brought
the gun
he gets to kill
so I want you to contrast this two
different scenarios one scenario where
there's two guys who are throwing
punches at one another like a bar fight
I think we'd all agree you can't kill
someone
you can't punch the guy and knock him to
the ground and then get on him and
strangle the life out of him that's
murder
so what's the difference here
the only difference is the defendant
brought a gun Point made by one of our
viewers last week remember
that's why he's got to come up with this
cockamamie theory that Joseph Rosenbaum
was not only going to take the gun
but take it and then turn it on the
defendant and the defendant actually
told you that he thought Joseph
Rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
not only kill him but kill other people
which is really ironic considering the
defendant is the one who killed people
in this case and the only one but
putting that aside kakame they have to
convince you that Joseph Rosenbaum was
going to take that gun and use it on the
defendant because they know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun when
you're the one creating the damn danger
when you're the one provoking other
people
this is very solid so far the defendant
fired four shots at Joseph Rosenbaum and
caused Five Wounds total
the first shot fractured Joseph
rosenbaum's pelvis
this causes him to be helpless he is
falling face first to the ground and he
is vulnerable
the second shot went through his left
hand probably ricocheted off the ground
and hit his lower left thigh it's a
flesh wound
I'm sure it hurt but probably not all
that serious
the third and fourth shots are as Mr
Rosenbaum has fallen almost completely
to the ground he is he's parallel to the
ground he noticed the judges eating and
looking at papers the defendant fire is
around into his upper back
which is the kill shot
and another round which grazes his right
scalp
at this point as you saw in that video a
crowd rushes to that body to try and
save Joseph Rosenbaum they're trying to
put clothing on the wound to stop the
bleeding they're going to take him
across the street to a hospital
kmh freighter itself is literally right
across the street and this crowd
except for the defendant
are all focused on trying to save this
person's life a person by the way
they probably had never even met before
because that's what most people do
Richie McGinnis testified
I rode with Rosenbaum in the back of
that SUV I told him we'd have a beer
together
when this is all done
Mr Rosenbaum was unable to respond
the defendant
decided to pull the trigger on his AR-15
four times
that was his decision
and he is responsible for every bullet
that comes out of that gun
he doesn't get a pass
by pulling the trigger fast
he could have chosen to stop after the
first shot
after the second shot
after the third shot
and assessed whether or not there was
still a need to keep firing
but he went four times in 0.76 seconds
the defense has made a big point of this
how fast he fired as if that somehow
excuses him
exactly the opposite ladies and
gentlemen he controls how quickly he
pulls the trigger he is in control of
that decision-making process
no one else made him do that
and this is indicative of someone who
doesn't care about the consequences
doesn't care to stop and figure out am I
am I good am I do I need to stop or I'm
just going to keep on going and as I
said he tracks the body all the way to
the to the ground with those second
third and fourth shots
the only way
that you could possibly justify
the murder of Joseph Rosenbaum is if you
believe that Joseph Rosenbaum was
actually reaching
for the defendant's gun
and that a reasonable person in the
defendant's position with that AR-15
strapped tightly to his chest
would think that Joseph Rosenbaum was
even capable of taking that gun away
as he's falling to the ground with a
fractured right pelvis
and then not only all that you'd also
have to believe
that Joseph Rosenbaum was going to turn
that gun around and use it to kill
the defendant
you have to believe all of those things
to justify the murder of Joseph
Roosevelt that's why the defense is
trying so desperately hard to convince
you that Joseph Rosenbaum threatened to
kill the defendant which never happened
that's why they're trying so desperately
hard to convince you that Joseph
Rosenbaum was reaching for that gun
because if he's not reaching for that
gun and he's not going to use it to kill
the defendant it is not justified there
is no valid self-defense claim
one of the things the judge has
instructed you is that when the
defendant provokes the situation he has
to exhaust all reasonable means to avoid
killing someone
did he
he didn't have to shoot
he's the one who chose where to run he
chose to run in between those parked
cars
he slows down
as he gets there
the crowd's already running away you
know the defense wants to make a point
there's a whole bunch of people over
there who are doing stuff to cars and
the defendant had no Escape Route the
crowd's actually already running away at
this point they've heard the first
gunshot from Joshua zaminsky and they're
already starting to scatter
but if you look on the video there's a
huge open space in that lot where the
defendant could have circled back around
and he actually does Circle back around
after killing Rosenbaum
or he could have gotten away
he has to exhaust all reasonable means
of Escape
before killing Mr Rosenbaum
your honor um
I do have some more video I want to play
I'm having a little bit of technical
problems that I'd like to work on so if
I think this would be a good time to
pause if that's okay okay thank you
guys during the break read watch rest of
my any account you
[ __ ] in 45 too soon
foreign
is that a better idea
let's do that two hour lunch
two hour lunch suggested there uh okay
judge confused about I guess timing and
time zones and stuff like that so they
will go to the food folks
more food around noon
to we have Subway tomorrow pizza is here
let's take a break lunch is here the
food is here by the way how are the
calzones all right how was the KFC very
good huh all right enjoy your lunch okay
so they are heading to lunch at this
point in time and we don't know exactly
what they're going to be having I want
to say thank you to Dana Trujillo and
lesko
you almost got me there uh someone named
lesko
um who signed up on our website
joinpakman.com new members 27 and 28 we
are in the 11th straight day of
streaming the Kyle Rittenhouse trial we
are about uh maybe a quarter of the way
through the prosecution's closing
statement then there will be a defense
closing statement let's see they're
going to be discussing a few other
matters
and then the prosecution will get a
rebuttal this is a big big deal
when we get to the point of
of
reducing the number to 12.
we have to decide what to do with the
other
six
and uh the Alternatives would be to just
let them go about their regular business
um and tell them we might call them if
we need them
or we can keep them here
where they can sit and watch daytime TV
can you imagine there are limited
channels they can watch
um
what a nightmare
I'd be I'd be punching myself in the
face and unfortunately will not be
permitted to talk about the case
so uh any preferences
my preference is to keep them here
yes okay we'll do that then and we'll
have to find some way to entertain them
um it makes it doesn't involve
some of the channels that are available
on the television okay
he doesn't want the jurors watching CNN
basically uh all right so there it is um
and they're going to be taking a break
now and then we'll be returning
um I I can't tell you how much I
appreciate people who have been
supporting these streams they are very
long days we're also producing the daily
podcast in addition to doing the streams
and we've got a live stream coming up
later today that I think many of you are
going to enjoy on my Instagram with a
celebrity a celebrity coming to the
David Pacman show and so many really
great things sign up at joinpakman.com
please and you can use this for as long
as the trial is going on you can use the
coupon code uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos spelling is above my
head it is all one word no space of
course and if you make a pledge on
patreon it counts double Pat Rowan just
made a pledge at patreon.com
davidpackman show and it indeed puts us
at 30. folks the mustache dies today
unless we get to 50 and we will open
phone lines at 100 and it is all
Extraordinary so I'm going to take my
lunch break as well I do have hot food
coming warm food around noon
uh oh no wait before I do that let me
just go over some of the memetic
elements that that I that I was not able
to show you guys
um so let's see just a couple cool
things that people in the audience made
here is lobamna okay check this one out
Obama
[Music]
okay so we got that one
we have a new song called Obama it's
very good very very good this is from
Jethro Bradley
check this out
anthemic I would say God bless
God bless
Obama you say Obama I say Obama you say
your mama I say your mama you say banana
I say banana you say David Pac-Man I
said David
that is being used by some but it's
Obama I didn't miss it I should have
mentioned it I agree
you say Obama I said Obama when Obama
killed Osama I think you mean Osama when
I smoke a blunt it's always matter one
mother dude from Tibet the Dalai
foreign
[Music]
okay
so we got that and then also another new
submission from our viewers this is a
very special whoa this is lilu featuring
diamond and silk and Deepak that's me
it's called bag of mangoes this may
arguably be even better
mangoes back the mangoes
I love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars and 99 Cents that seems like a
pretty good deal bag of mangoes mango
art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my man goes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
don't want me to be
oh man
[Music]
wow an extremely powerful message about
mangoes all right guys um we are in a
lunch break then the prosecution's
closing argument will continue thanks to
Cheryl Belcher for making a patreon
pledge those count double puts us at 32.
I will thank everybody every last
patriotic American and World resident
who signs up on my website after the
lunch break and uh it's all happening
keep it here
all right everybody we are moments away
from the resumption of the Kyle
Rittenhouse trial we are now in the last
day probably or maybe the second to last
day in the sense that we're in the
middle of the prosecution's closing
argument they have up to two and a half
hours total including a rebuttal then
the defense gets to go up to two and a
half hours then the prosecution will
rebut so there's a question as to
whether they're going to be done today
or not
um and if they are there's a question as
to whether they will begin to deliberate
today or not so that's what's going on
and momentarily they're going to resume
they are getting back from lunch
forward around noon yep so
um I just had a pair and I have to tell
you one of the best pairs I've had I
used to really struggle with pairs to
know when are they ripe and I would
either cut into it too early you get
that with a Bartlett you get that
unsatisfying
you know when it's not ripe enough when
you cut into it disappointing or it's
too late and it's got all these brown
spots inside but now I'm definitely
doing much much better as far as that
goes and I found a system that works for
me to figure out when is uh when when is
the pair ready so Bartlett is probably
my favorite followed by bosk and then
lastly
as some people pronounce it
um am I still growing tomatoes no it's
it's essentially winter
so uh no
um what else is going on
I guess that's sort of it as far as uh
the case goes let's get to some let's
get to some voicemails and super chats
about the case as we get set back up
here to get going again
um let's see of course of course Whitney
is checking in
so another note noteworthy thing that
maybe judges don't recognize or you know
have not observed is that the military
has options to where you can have
children in the military
of course of course let's see what else
we've got here
um
I think this is Troy York and David
packman
um Simpson James of the red elephants
just is this related Kyle kulinski I
never know he Troy is constantly calling
about things other people on the left
have said
oh sorry I've got to ban a couple people
on YouTube I apologize Troy York
constantly calls in about things other
people have said and criticizes me over
them or things people I haven't heard of
have either said about me or others in
this case he said
something James of oregano what was that
let's listen again hold on
let's see this is so obscure
um since and James are the red elephants
just is this really
Vincent James of bread elephants is that
what he said anyway let's see what this
is about Kyle kulinski in a missions
video of his
um Detroit I don't care what Brett
elephants say about Kyle kolinsky I
don't watch any clips of any shows like
mine so I don't know what Kyle's doing
and I don't know what Vincent James is
you know it's like give me a break guys
um
let's see what else we got
nope we're moving off of that
uh let's see what else we've got
well Whitney called back in
I just I don't see um
Trump being a six
th year in this country
um let's hope not
um I think this is another Troy York
hello her name is packman uh this is a
reference maybe to one unit programs a
week ago where you're talking about Kyle
Rick Kyle Randolph and uh why he was
over there
all right I just I just can't take the
Troy it's either he's coughing
uncontrollably
he doesn't remember what he was gonna
say it's just really really bad all
right let's get let's try super chats
instead because we're failing pretty
hard over on voicemails Papi says I'm
tired here's five dollars well I
appreciate that
Sean says I hope that people understand
if Rittenhouse is found innocent
remember it's not innocent it's not
guilty this sets the case law we're
going to have more teens running around
playing Call of Duty yeah I do worry
about the impact I mean this guy's gonna
be made a hero I already recorded
today's podcast and we actually
addressed this heroism element on the
podcast
um
let's see will I cover the riots after
the verdict I mean listen if there are
riots I will cover them I am going to
admonish you though please if there is
an announcement that the verdict has
been reached usually there's 45 to 60
minutes before they read it please start
emailing me info davidpackman.com I
don't want to miss it so that I can
actually get set up and stream
um and then as far as phone lines today
if we get to 100 today we'll do phone
calls if we have time if not it'll carry
it'll be good for tomorrow and if we get
to 50 I will keep the mustache for
another day otherwise it goes today
there's a lot of people in my household
very much ready for the mustache to go
and as of right now that's exactly what
would happen
is it just mirrored as the defense
attorney sound like Bert the Muppet
unsure
David sir we appreciate you thanks Katya
the judge's candy crinkling is out of
order was it candy or was it nuts
fantastic troll job by the defense with
the pixelated video stuff played the
judge like a fiddle yeah yeah yeah the
defense was so successfully Aber able to
um
play off of the judge's technical
ignorance
are they coming back oh we're almost
back yeah that uh it they very much used
it in their favor if writtenhouse had
been armed with mangoes then we wouldn't
have this situation although he still
could see a charge for illegally priced
fruits very much so
Hades wants to talk about Garrett Foster
not what we're doing today
let's see what else a lot of people are
borderline about to get banned I think
we might have already banned 70 or 80
people just today alone
um
like let me give you [ __ ] for example
there's someone who is every five
seconds saying will you condemn the
riots that will happen David Pacman show
will you condemn the riots that will
happen David Pacman show anyone who
knows me knows I condemn all writing
um but it's like how many times are you
gonna chat the same thing
before it's just gonna be like that's it
that's it we're Banning you
it's just spamming when you're saying
the same thing every five seconds I do
want to say instead of focusing on all
these horrible people okay all right and
he's still doing it so we're just gonna
ban
um
instead of focusing on these horrible
people
I want to instead thank everybody who
has been signing up and supporting the
streams we do have our primary funding
sources our website memberships uh
davidpackman.com membership or
joinpakman.com whichever is your
preference we are banned from twitch for
another 23 days and we lost a thousand
paid subscribers there as you can see
above my head it says twitch subscribers
zero and so
um I would love it for you to support
through our website joinpakman.com
today's coupon code is uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos you can also make a
pledge via patreon some people say
patreon I once heard someone say it I
don't know and
um you can make a pledge via patreon and
those count double they would very
quickly get us to 50 and also also also
whoever is number 50 gets a free item
from the David packman Show online store
a few other other people want bands we
can keep handing them out the bands are
free Joel
says appreciate your coverage of the
trial David some Chatters are hoping
that police would have mowed Kyle down
which is kind of extreme I hope people
would think a bit more critically about
this tragic and avoidable event yeah I
think that it's a legitimate thing to
say
people in Kenosha on that night could
reasonably have thought of Kyle
Rittenhouse as an active shooter who
needed to be stopped that's reasonable
it's also completely plausible that in
this situation that Kyle Rittenhouse
created
at some point he feared for his life
making self-defense uh accurate under
the law
so it's a horrible situation that is
completely and totally avoidable
completely and totally avoidable in
every way period
um
a couple other voicemails let's see
hi David this is Nick from Vermont how
are you today
um great mustache anyway thank you use
mascara that will darken it if you don't
know what mascara is ask your girlfriend
I've never heard of mascara I'm sure has
some anyway this judge is a joke do you
know if the
uh prostitution has any recourse you
know defense can always appeal
does the prosecution have recourse to
claim so our uh our our attorney who has
been sending messages said last week the
prosecution cannot appeal
a not guilty verdict that's what I
remember Graham the attorney telling us
last week and I'm glad to be corrected
or for there to be clarification
glad to uh have that happen
let's see
I think we've got someone trying to
sneak let's go Brandon into the
voicemail
yeah guys go to join.date.com use the
code let's go Brandy let's go Brandy
oh my God
how do these people I mean these are
like the lowest brow
bottom of the bottom of the bottom of
the barrel people we are blocking that
number
um
blocking a couple other people and it's
so cringy yeah let's go Brandon is so
cringy it's that's the thing they think
it's slick in some way but it it's just
painfully cringy
Ian says thanks for your coverage no
matter the verdict it's sad when
right-wing Vigilantes bring guns
illegally to escalate and use the gun's
presence to justify its use I thought
he'd grab my gun which I am not even
allowed to have so I shot him yeah
that's what we call a situational
problem with the whole thing I want to
say a big thank you to Sean Dixon who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code uncharged pickles uncharged
piccolos and his new member number 33
also thanks to Ola Nordman Nordman for
signing up with the same code uncharged
piccolos that's number 34 and then
short brief and Jason Bank Co made
pledges via patreon they count double
and it puts us at 38. we are standing by
here for the resumption of the
prosecutions closing statement and it
has been good so far
they're now going to bring in the jury
elements of cringe yeah flossy Carter
by the way we really appreciate flossie
Carter being in the chat today
philosophy's got nearly 2 million
YouTube subscribers making me look like
a little kid with my paltry 1.4 flossie
does really great reviews and different
uh reviews of different technical
elements that are available to people
great to have philosophy watching we had
tyt Sports in the chat last week
um and a lot of different people
uh remember these all caps free Kyle
Kyle is a hero let's go Brandon you're
just instaband and it's so sad that
so quickly you will never participate on
my channel again sad I guess for you I
don't know sad to be an adult and to be
banned
for humiliating yourself thanks to
Rachel Kendall for the patreon pledge
those count double and that puts us at
40 today also John Peter with a patreon
pledge puts us at 42. these numbers are
climbing very very quickly
what's the over under on when next the
next Whitney call would be I don't know
I'll let you guys know uh I'll keep an
eye on on it to see if she calls in PBS
a little slow here we go PBS is back
all right
Obama I read on Facebook that
rosenbaum's bag had uncharged pickles in
it I read the same thing actually
[Music]
oh
boy I got a couple emails about
um
actually I'm not going to even actually
I'm not even going to mention what I got
emails about
I'm changing my mind all right so Mr
Binger is going to continue his closing
statement it was it was solid to start
with I'm not saying it'll convince the
jury I'm just saying it was a solid
closing statement
um and we're watching all of these
statements very very closely
I will be stepping away for a phone call
at some point during this well your full
stomachs won't uh distract you too much
from uh the presentation here so I had
been uh talking about the murder of
Joseph Rosenbaum and as you can tell I'm
trying to go in chronological order I'm
trying to go through these events in a
way that that makes the most sense so
count one of the information is with
regard to Joseph Rosenbaum the second
count of the information pertains to
Richie McGinnis who you heard testify
he testified that he was in the line of
fire behind Joseph Rosenbaum as the
defendant fires four rounds with his
AR-15 which is loaded with Full Metal
Jacket ammunition and I'll talk a little
bit more about that type of ammunition
in a little bit but you've heard
testimony that it's the type of
ammunition that is capable of going
through body armor it is capable of
going through a squad car
it is designed to go through the Target
and continue flying on for up to 550
yards
Richard McGinnis testified that when
those shots went off he thought he had
been hit he thought his life was in
danger
one of the rules that I think most
people who are familiar with Firearms
knows is always check your background
meaning know what's around your Target
and know what's behind your target
this is true when you're hunting it's
true when you're target shooting and
obviously it's true when you've got an
AR-15 in downtown Kenosha in the middle
of protests with houses and people
nearby
but there's no indication that defendant
cared one bit about his background cared
one bit about where those bullets were
going to go
and as I said he put Richie McGinnis in
danger
Richie McGinnis after this incident
you've seen on the videos
goes to try and help
Joseph Rosenbaum and has his own video
shows when he first gets there he finds
Mr rosenbaum's body face down on the
ground
and I'm going to play this exhibit
exhibit 15 for you
Rittenhouse does not want to see these
videos that's for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
show your pressure on this dude
get away
dude there's a hole
[Music]
yeah
he's alive
you want to talk about medics
you want to talk about people who care
you want to talk about people who are
there
trying to help
you just heard them and you just saw
them
people who didn't know Joseph Rosenbaum
they just knew somebody needed help
and while that's going on
the defendant flees
callously disregarding
the body of the man that he just shot
and killed
and as he's running off
he's lying to the crowd
about what just happened
this is exhibit number 12.
so they were just like six shots
thank you
the defendant says he pulled a gun
[Applause]
okay
that's statements he pulled a gun
was alive
it's not true
the defendant knew it wasn't true
he's lying to the crowd as he's running
away
Joseph Rosenbaum didn't have a gun the
defendant knew he didn't have a gun true
the defendant is lying to save his own
skin instead of going and trying to help
the person that he has just shot and
killed
in exhibit number three
Gage gross kreutz's
Facebook live video he tells a similar
lie
as they're running Mr gross quartz asked
the defendant did you just shoot someone
and the defendant says something about
the police and then says I did not shoot
anyone
and this is similar to the lie that he
told Jason lakowski at exactly that same
time as he passes Mr lakowski he says I
did not shoot anyone
and that was established through Mr
wilkowski's testimony and again I think
it's worth emphasizing at this point
that Jason lakowski had just met the
defendant maybe an hour this is about 11
50 at night Mr lakowski got there about
10 45.
you know
almost
this is Gage grosskowitz running towards
Danger
running to try and help
this is exhibit number three
hey what are you doing you shot somebody
who shot
who shot
who shot
listen to the second thing he says
who shot
who's shot
you shot somebody
who shot
it's hard to tell what his exact words
are I hear the word not
pretty clearly in there as in I did not
shooting one I did not do anything
Jason lakowski he lies to the crowd he
lies to Gage grosscowitz he lies to
so at this point
the crowd is dealing with what they
perceive to be an active shooter
someone who has just shot someone who is
still in possession of the gun who is
fleeing the scene
and how are we supposed to know where
he's going next
you know all night that night
the crowd has been hearing the sound of
gunshots
they've been hearing fireworks
firecrackers
but now
someone actually has been shot
the crowd sees the defendant running
with a gun he's lying to them
he still has the gun he's shot someone
this is provocation to them
this is someone who has committed a
criminal act and is putting people in
danger
it is entirely reasonable for that crowd
to believe at that moment that he is a
threat to kill again
the defendant could have made it
unequivocally clear
what he was doing
he could have stayed at Mr rosenbaum's
body helped protect him help preserve
his life call 9-1-1
as he's running he could have announced
to the crowd exactly what he was doing
told them
he could have fired warning shots to try
and help keep him away he could have
dropped the gun he could have raised his
hands and surrendered
he could have signaled to this crowd
that he did not pose a threat anymore
but everything he does is indicative of
someone who is still a threat
now
the defendant is going to tell you he
wasn't but from the crowd's perspective
how are they supposed to know any
different
he does nothing to demonstrate to the
crowd that he isn't a threat to kill
again
and it turns out he does
it turns out within a few seconds he
does kill again
I submit to you ladies and gentlemen
that in this situation the crowd has the
right
to try and stop an active shooter
they have a right to protect themselves
the defendant is not the only one in the
world who has the right to self-defense
but what does the crowd do to try and
stop the defendant
I submit to you and this is not a
criticism of them but they use almost
the least minimal least intrusive means
possible
they could have used deadly force
against him
they could have shot at him
but instead somebody comes up behind him
and knocks his hat off
Anthony Huber comes up with a skateboard
and the defendant blocks it with his arm
and then the defendant falls to the
ground on his own no one knocked him
down this is an interesting approach
this man that the defense wants to call
jump kick man he's got no weapons no gun
no knife no nothing comes in and tries
to kick the defendant in the face
Anthony Huber comes back and tries to
grab the gun actually does grab the
defendant's gun and tries to pull it
away because he's trying to disarm an
active shooter
and Gage gross crates comes running in
stops with his hands up in the air until
he sees and hears the defendant
adjusting his weapon as if preparing to
fire again
and then what is Gage grosscrates do
he reaches for the gun to try and disarm
the defendant
Gage grosquirtz had his own gun in his
own hand he could have aimed it and
fired at the defendant but he did not
and you heard Gage gross kreutz testify
about that about how that is a decision
that he was not prepared to make it that
point in time he is not the type of
person
who is just willing to take someone's
life in an instant unlike the defendant
who took two lives that night
very quickly and seemingly very easily
there is a video exhibit five which is
the BG on the scene video which traces
this entire incident which we call the
second event
this is going to show you Mr Huber Mr
gross kreutz and the other individuals
who are trying to stop an active shooter
using what I would characterize as the
least intrusive means possible
someone knocks his hat off
Anthony Huber comes in with a skateboard
in just a few seconds
the defendant kills one person attempts
to kill two more and blows off Gage
gross quartz's arm
it's that fast
this is someone who has no remorse
no regard for life
only cares about himself
and these folks that are coming at him
the jump kick man Anthony Huber aren't
armed
they're not a credible imminent threat
to his life they are trying to stop an
active shooter
and they have a right to do so imagine
if the crowd couldn't do that imagine if
they weren't allowed to try and stop one
someone in this type of situation
after killing Anthony Huber
after severely wound engaged grosscoides
the defendant walks away
like they hear like he's some sort of
hero in a western
without a care in the world he was
providing medical though I thought you
know it's interesting this occurs about
a block away from the police line
right down the road
if the defendant's so concerned about
his safety the police are right there
and in fact they pull up to this scene
almost instantly
the defendant's got his medic bag on he
proclaims himself a medic he doesn't
know at this point if Anthony Huber's
Dead or Alive capable of being saved
and yet the defendant offers no
assistance makes no attempt to try and
help anyone else all he cares about is
himself
we have taken that video
and we have
broken it down into individual frames
and I want to take you through frame by
frame
the incident with Gauge gross courts
because a lot has been made about Mr
gross quartz's motions and what he does
and where he goes and things like that
so I think it's helpful for us to take a
look at this so this is exhibit 80
beginning with frame 356. at this point
you can see that Anthony Huber is
staggering off after being shot in the
chest the wound has entered his lower
left rib cage and has wound up almost
exiting near his right shoulder it is
ripped through his ribs
heart his aorta
and
he may not technically be dead but he's
he's going to be dead within a few
seconds
he is stumbling away the defendant has
the weapon pointed towards Gage gross
kreutz here who is cowering hovering
hiding covering his head trying to stay
out of the way and I'm going to go frame
by frame here slowly as we see the
movement
now we see the gun is moving down
towards Gage grosskroits it is pointed
directly at him from a distance of just
a couple of feet
Gage growthcreitz has his right leg
planted as if he's pushing backwards
trying to get away
the gun is still pointed at him
the defendant here is going to
adjust the gun
turn it over as if he's
making some sort of adjustment on it
Gage grosskroits testified that this was
a movement that he interpreted as the
defendant preparing that gun as if it
was going to fire again as if clearing a
jammed round so that he could shoot it
at Mr gross coits
at this point Mr gross kreutz is I think
probably thinking to himself if I can
get away I will
until he realizes that the defendant is
getting ready to fire again
why do people think they have a right to
chat on my YouTube stream like you don't
have you don't have a right to that
really troubled people
in none of these frames is Mr gross
kreutz's right hand with his Glock
pistol
pointed at the defendant
you can see Mr gross kreitz is actually
backing up with his right leg
let me go back a couple of frames here
this is frame 444
you can see his right foot is
on the ground but it's starting to move
back now as I move forward
in the frames 447 his right leg is moved
back
this is someone who's about to retreat
his hands are in the air he's backing
away from the defendant until as he's
testified he sees the defendant
start to manipulate that gun in such a
way that it makes Mr grosskroits feel
like he's about to be shot and only then
does he take action
what action does Mr gross kreutz take
does he hold that gun with both hands
the Glock that he's got and pointed at
the defendant no never
does he even take the gun with one hand
and point it no never instead you can
see him start to Lunge in with his left
arm forward
the gun is not in this hand I'll be back
guys I got a phone call he's lunging
forward reaching for the defendant
probably reaching for the gun
probably trying to block the gun you can
see now he's going to take a step with
his right leg across the defendant's
body
not directly towards the defendant but
across the defendant's body
as he's reaching him almost swiping away
at that gun with his left arm
he has bladed his body in such a way as
to try and present as minimal of a
Target as possible which is probably
what saves his life
his right leg is about to hit the ground
here the gun the AR-15 is pointed
directly at him
from just two maybe three feet away
he's trying to Shield himself with his
left arm
and as we approach for frame 500 here
the gun goes off
at no point in this process is Mr
grosskroit's pointing his gun at the
defendant
frame 499
the gun is just fired
frame 500 you see the puff of smoke
501 the bullet has hit Mr gross kreutz's
right bicep severing it
I'm going to continue forward after this
because you can see
that his right arm this is an
interesting frame right here 504 you can
see that gun
I'll go back even more you can see that
Mr gross kreutz's arm with the right
hand with the with the gun his right
hand is pointed off to the side what
pulls that gun down closer to the
defendant is the fact that Mr
grosskweitz just had his right bicep
severed it's not a voluntary action
it's an involuntary the muscle is
severed now watch frame 502 watch his
right hand
503
504
505 506 507.
508
at this point yeah
absolutely that right arm is probably
dangling down towards the defendant it's
not going to be able to pull that
trigger without a working bicep muscle
and it's not a voluntary thing it's done
because the defendant just blew his arm
off
but yeah this is the time after the
shooting when yes the gun happens to be
pointed at the defendant and I gotta
stop here for a moment and highlight the
hypocrisy of the defense
because according to the defense if
someone has a gun they're a threat if
someone points a gun they're a threat
there's only one exception to that the
defendant
by their logic he gets to run around
with a gun all night but oh we're not
supposed to take him as a threat he gets
to point the gun at everyone
but oh we're not supposed to take him as
a threat no it doesn't work that way the
same set of rules apply to the defendant
is everybody else
there's no exception in the law for Kyle
Rittenhouse
there's no exception that says if anyone
else has a gun you're a danger except
for Kyle Rittenhouse
there's no exception in the law that
says if he points your gun at people oh
that makes you a threat and I can kill
you
except for Kyle Rittenhouse I can do it
all night long
the same rules apply to him as everyone
else and everyone else has a right to
defend themselves also not just the
defendant
foreign
we have shown you photos and videos of
Gage gross quartz's injuries
exhibit 60 is a video taken right after
Mr gross kreutz
was wounded by the defendant
oh thank you
it's hard to look at
but this is what we're dealing with
when you fire an AR-15 at someone from
close range
this is what it looks like
I guarantee you ladies and gentlemen the
defendant had no clue what his gun was
capable of he didn't even bother to pay
any attention to it didn't concern
himself with what he would be doing to
other people
but this is what happened
let's not flinch away from this
it's important that we understand what
that gun was capable of that night
it killed two people and it did this to
Mr gross quartz's arm
when those shootings occurred that I
just played for you
what would a reasonable person
in the defendant's position at that time
think
the good news is ladies and gentlemen
you're going to tell us
as part of your decision in this case
you will represent the reasonable person
of ordinary and prudent person and you
will put yourself in the defendant's
shoes that night
I submit to you that at the time of
those shootings a reasonable person in
the defendant's shoes would have known
that he had provoked Joseph Rosenbaum by
pointing his gun at someone else that
the defendant had put someone else at
risk of dying by doing that
the defendant should have known that the
crowd was aware of the fact that he had
just shot someone and that they felt
their lies were in danger
that is reasonable
it is also reasonable
to understand that at that point Gage
gross courts had just witnessed all of
this he had heard the defendant had shot
someone
he'd heard the defendant lie about it he
saw the defendant shoot at jump kickman
at close range miraculously missing had
seen the defendant kill Anthony Huber
Gage girls kreutz reasonably believed
his life was in danger at that moment
and he was proven correct
because the defendant shot him too
so when you consider what's reasonable
in this case consider whether or not
it's reasonable for a criminal to be
able to shoot himself out of a crime
scene
when a bank robber Robs a Bank and runs
away and the crowd comes after him can
he just shoot anybody and claim
self-defense
if someone comes up to that person and
tries to stop them tries to disarm them
like Anthony Huber did
they forfeit their life
did Anthony Huber forfeit his life by
trying to be a hero and stop an active
shooter and protect others
is that justified
Can the defendant just kill him
in this case the crowd was right
the crowd knew the defendant had just
shot someone when they're coming after
him they they know he's just shot and
killed Joseph Rosenbaum
but you know not every active shooter
situation is the crowd have perfect
knowledge
when they're told that person running up
the street just shot someone we don't
have time in the moment to go back and
take a look at the body and replay the
video and make a decision before going
after the person with the gun
you know we've had several police
officers testify that an active shooter
situation their first
Instinct their first training is to go
in and stop the threat
they don't sit there and wonder well
maybe it was self-defense I don't know
I'm gonna you know let wait and see
and every day we read about heroes that
stop active shooters
that's what was going on here
and that crowd was right
and that crowd was full of Heroes
that crowd
did something that honestly I'm not sure
I would have had the courage to do if I
see a guy running up the street with an
AR-15 and I hear he just shot somebody
my first instinct is not to approach
Anthony Huber was different
jump kick man was different
Gage grosskroits was different
that doesn't make them
a threat to the defendant's life
it doesn't make their lives worthless
they don't give up their right to defend
themselves
they have just as much right as the
defendant
I told you I wanted to begin
by talking about
the murders committed by the defendant
now I want to go back and put it all in
context for you and that context starts
with
broth I'm just trying to be famous
The defendant's Tick Tock profile
four doors more horse
picture of him up in Ladysmith probably
in early May proudly holding his new
AR-15
up until August 25th 2020 this is the
only time he'd ever fired that gun
maybe put 100 rounds through it or so at
that property up there with Dominic
black
they purchased that gun on that same
trip
the defendant admitted he knew as a
matter of law he could not buy that gun
because he was only 17.
yet he wants to tell you that he thought
legally he could possess it
which didn't make a lot of sense to me
we don't have a lot of defendants come
in and say well I possess cocaine I knew
I couldn't buy it but I thought I could
possess it
no it's not the way it works
Dominic black conducted what we call a
straw purchase for the defendant
he purchased that gun for someone who
was not legally allowed to purchase it
for themselves I'm prosecuting Dominic
black for that as you know just like I'm
Prosecuting Joshua zaminsky
because what dominic black did was wrong
and we don't tolerate that
the agreement was Dominic black was
going to keep that gun until the
defendant turned 18. it was Dominic
Black's gun it was legally his
and the defendant knew that it was going
to be held on to until he turned 18 that
he was not going to have it until that
birthday
I want to focus a little bit on this
AR-15 because I think it's important
when you consider the recklessness of
the defendant's conduct how much he knew
cared
or didn't know
about this deadly weapon
he'd only fired at that one time maybe a
hundred rounds through it
he loaded the gun with Full Metal Jacket
ammunition which I'll talk about a
little bit more
he wanted it because he said it looked
cool
didn't seem to know or care much about
the type of ammunition or the type of
gun you had a couple of witnesses tell
us in this trial and I just I could not
believe it a gun is a gun as a gun
don't don't even start with that
I'll pull it it's a bullet no it is not
it is not
and anybody who says that is ignorant
and Reckless
because there are some important
distinctions here
Full Metal Jacket ammunition is capable
of piercing body armor
and squad cars
and you heard officer Krieger testify
that when they heard someone was running
around with a rifle he went and got his
plate armor out of the back because
their regular body armor wasn't going to
stop those rounds
Ryan Balch talked about how Full Metal
Jacket ammunition is designed and this
is a former Army infantryman is designed
to go through a Target like a deer or a
person and continue on
he says it can hit a Target 550 yards
away that's five and a half football
fields
and he explained that he had a handgun
that night which he put hollow point
ammunition on and that's what he was
planning on using for self-defense
hollow point ammunition acts differently
it's going to hit its Target but it's
not designed to continue on and go
through and hit other targets so you
will hit what you hit but you're not
going to put the rest of the community
at risk especially on a night when there
are hundreds of people out on the
streets in our heavy residential area
we can see on that map the car Source
there are houses there are churches
there are daycares there are schools
nearby and you're firing Full Metal
Jacket ammunition around
I submit to you ladies and gentlemen
that that AR-15 had no lawful or
legitimate purpose that night
now
the second amendment allows people to
carry guns that is true
there are people who can't carry guns
convicted felons for example
but generally speaking I'm not saying
people don't have the right to carry a
gun what I'm saying is that AR-15 did
not accomplish any of the goals that
these folks said it was going to
so for example Ryan Balch says the
handgun is what he was going to use for
self-defense
several witnesses agreed you can't point
this gun or shoot this gun at people to
protect property so if you're going to
protect the car Source building
how is this gun going to help with that
the defendant has admitted the gun was
useless when he was going to treat
people as a medic
on the way he had to take it off and
hand it to someone so you can't use it
as a medic
you can't use it to protect the building
so what's it there for
well
it looks pretty imposing and it has some
deterrence value but Jason lakowski
Dominic black and Ryan Balch all said
they never actually intended to use
their guns
so why is it there
the defendant was wearing a sling that
night
he purchased that sling at jalinsky's
that afternoon
the purpose of the sling was so the gun
couldn't be taken away
wouldn't fall off he wouldn't lose
possession of it it was designed to help
him retain possession of that gun
and he loaded it with 30 rounds the full
magazine
capable of killing 30 people or more
why do you need 30 rounds a Full Metal
Jacket armor to protect a building
this AR-15 is completely incompatible
with the role of a medic
I McGinnis testified he's been to
demonstrations in Seattle Portland
Washington DC New York Minneapolis he's
never seen anyone walking around
claiming to be a medic with an AR-15
and certainly when you see someone like
that it doesn't exactly send a warm
fuzzy message oh come to me I'm here to
help
and the defendant acknowledged he had to
take off his AR-15 to treat people
no serious credible medic wears an AR-15
slung around their body
defendant was a fraud
he was not an AMT he lied
he lied to the Press
he's being interviewed by Richie
McGinnis who he hears is a member of the
media and he says I'm a certified EMT
you lion
you're absolutely lying
Jason lakowski and Dominic black said
the defendant had to borrow his medical
supplies from us
this is an emergency situation
everybody's anticipating violence
everybody's prepared
for people to be hurt harmed injured
and yet the defendant's going to go
there and walk around claiming to be a
medic
he's like a quack doctor practicing
without a license that puts lives at
risk
and one of the things I had Gage
grosscoyz testified about is that tattoo
on his right arm which said first Do no
harm
which is one of the precepts one of the
fundamental tenets of the practice of
medicine first Do no harm
so how do we evaluate the defendant's
performance as a medic that night well
on one hand uh he wrapped up an ankle
and I think to maybe help somebody who
got a cut on their hand
yay
on the other hand he killed two people
blew off Gage girl skirts his arm
and put two more lives in Jeopardy so
you know when we balance your role as a
medic that night I don't give you any
credit
he showed no remorse for his victims
never tried to help anybody that he
hurts and even on the witness stand when
he testified on Wednesday
he broke down crying about himself
not about anybody that he hurt that
night
No Remorse no concern for anyone else
for him to call himself a medic as an
insult
to anyone like Gage gross quartz who
spent hundreds of hours training and
working hard to become an EMT
it's an insult
the defendant made a series of Reckless
decisions that night
going armed with an AR-15 at 17 years
old when he knew he shouldn't have done
so because that gun is normally locked
in a safe that he doesn't have access to
and it's not even legally his
out after a city-wide curfew
he's intentionally and knowingly
entering into a dangerous situation and
he expects it because he brings along
his AR-15 and some body armor
so don't tell me you didn't know
he brings along no non-lethal means of
Defense which means his only option is
to kill
I don't know about a lot of you but I
remember that night
I didn't come down here I don't think
most reasonable people did in part
because we all knew it was going to be
violent and dangerous
most reasonable people to the extent
they came out they were gone by then
because you don't willingly put yourself
in this situation
unless you want it
unless you're looking for it
unless you want trouble
now to put this in perspective at this
time here in our community there were
people who were scared
there were people who were worried about
themselves their homes their families
their business
that's understandable
there are also people out there who were
exercising their First Amendment right
to assemble
and to have free speech because whatever
they believed in and they have that
right too
but that's not what we're talking about
the curfew
the riots the arson the Looting that
we'd seen on those prior nights
roadblocks set up around downtown closed
exits on the interstates all of this was
sending the message to reasonable people
go away
don't come down here
who was left at 11 45 at night
most reasonable people had gone home
before the curfew
or never even came at all
but the defendant's down there he says
because he wants you to believe he's
protecting car source
even though he had no actual ties or
Jenny wine concern for this building
you have this Caravan of people from
West Bend Ryan Balch Jason lakowski
Joanne Fiedler coming down from some
other community having no idea what's
going on here Kenosha having no idea
what businesses are having never dealt
with car Source before just injecting
themselves into this situation
car source that night was empty
the owners testified they moved all the
cars off the lot they took the tools out
from inside and they didn't even feel
the need to protect that building
so who's there these guys with their
AR-15s or just want to be soldiers
acting tough
trying to manufacture some personal
connection to this event furthering
their own personal agenda
just a small part of the Deluge of chaos
tourists we saw here in Kenosha trying
to feed off of what we were going
through
despite everything we did to try and
tell them go away
stay out
did those owners Sam and Sal ask anyone
to protect their business you know I
called them to the stand because I
wanted you to hear from them
I had their statement but I wanted you
to hear from them
and I'm sure you formed your own
Impressions about them I'm not here to
tell you that I believe what they said
on the witness stand I really matters
much except I wanted you to have a
flavor of who these people were and what
was going on at that building
what was interesting to me is that text
message from the defendant to Sam asking
for the address of car Source even
though the defendant says he's already
been there that didn't make any sense to
me it's not hard to find if you've
driven past her every day you know
Kenosha is one of the easiest cities in
Wisconsin to navigate it's all east west
north south
how hard is it to find this place
but the agreement was the defendant was
supposed to stay at the 59th Street
location there's another group at 63rd
it was their responsibility and the
defendant testified that when the
shootings occurred at 11 45 or 11 50 at
night he didn't even know if that other
group was still there or if they'd left
but crucially you heard the testimony of
Kristan Harris
who's out there reporting for his
run-down live and he's making some video
and he tells the defendant stay on your
property
don't go out in the streets and engage
with these protesters because you're
just making it worse and you're
escalating the situation
he tells the defendant specifically that
just 20 minutes before the shootings
Kristan Harris probably said that
because he knows this is a crowd that is
feeling threatened by the defendant and
his group
Richie McGinnis testified when he left
the Stella hotel and immediately ran
over to 59th Street he saw guys up on
the roof and he felt threatened these
guns he said were the thing that changed
the dynamic for him
Drew Hernandez we showed video of Drew
Hernandez having laser sights pointed at
him
and he said he felt threatened he
thought someone was pointing a gun from
the roof and putting his life in
jeopardy these are two people who are
veterans they've been to protests in
Seattle Portland Washington DC New York
they've been through this before and yet
here in little Kenosha the defendants
group made them fear for their lives
that's the kind of impact these AR-15s
had
the crowd is yelling at the defendants
group stop pointing your guns at us stop
pointing these laser pointers at us and
the defendant sees this
he's well aware of the fact that the
crowd out on the street is hostile they
don't react well to him
and he knows that by 11 35 at night this
crowd is all the way down there south of
60th that's where they're at
so if I go down there I need to be
prepared and I need to expect that these
folks are not on my side
Joseph Rosenbaum
he's dead
so we don't know what he was thinking
we don't know what was going on in his
mind
that makes him an easy target for the
defense today because they can stand up
here and pile on him and Destroy his
reputation and he can't speak for
himself
that happens a lot in homicide trials
blame the victim
who can't speak for themselves
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about Joseph Rosenbaum and you've heard
some testimony about him he had been in
the hospital
left it that day had a clear plastic bag
with his possessions toiletries a water
bottle
we've all seen this you get it in the
hospital it's pretty common he's walking
around like it's pretty much his only
possession in the world
he visits Carrie Anne swart his
girlfriend and then happens to wander
downtown into the middle of civil unrest
no indication he planned to be there no
indication he's part of any sort of
movement
he just happens to stumble into it so
what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
Joseph Rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some Bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
if you were alive today like Joshua
zaminski I'd probably try and prosecute
him for arson but I can't because the
defendant killed him
but that's the way we deal with people
that do these things when you commit
arson we prosecute you we don't execute
you in the street
and I'm not here to say that the things
that Joseph Rosenbaum did were good
or that I condone that kind of behavior
not at all
but he didn't deserve to die for it
you can't kill someone for these things
he's five foot four
150 pounds
Jason lakowski characterized him as a
babbling idiot
Bukowski says I turned my back and
walked away this guy wasn't even a
threat
I think we all know somebody like Joseph
Rosenbaum the Napoleon complex the
little guy who just wants to chatter but
when it comes down to it it's all bark
it's no bite it's like a little dog bark
bark bark bark bark but really ain't
gonna do anything
there is no dispute in this record that
at no point that night did Joseph
Rosenbaum hurt anyone
never had a gun never had a knife never
had a bat never had a club
and in the Drew Hernandez video
that fight at ultimate gas that we
showed you he's being shoved around by
the crowd like a ragdoll
and yeah he's mouthing off he's he's
talking a lot
but he doesn't actually threaten anybody
doesn't actually hurt anybody
they're pushing him around like he's a
tiny little person which frankly he was
and in the background of this video you
will hear somebody say shoot your you
know Point your gun at me or something
like that
that's Joseph Rosenbaum he's upset
because somebody pointed a gun and that
triggers him
which is understandable I think most of
us would be triggered by that sort of
thing and that's what's upsetting to him
but he gets right in the face of people
of AR-15s never reaches for their guns
never rears back to punch anyone never
even lays hands on anybody
[Applause]
you're gonna watch this confrontation
here at ultimate gas and I want you to
keep in mind that there's a group of
people on one side with AR-15s and a
group of people on the other side and
none of the people with the AR-15s feel
their life is in danger
none of them shoot their guns
they can handle themselves
the defendant can't
[Applause]
[Applause]
wait
that sound you heard was somebody
throwing some sort of plastic thing at
one of the stanchions underneath the uh
the gas station and it makes a sound
that almost sounds like a gunshot so add
that into the mix you've got people with
guns loud voices clear hostility and the
sound of something that frankly to me
sounds like a gunshot and yet everybody
keeps their cool
nobody hurts anybody nobody fires a gun
and watch has how they push Joseph
Rosenberg like a ragdoll
[Applause]
watch this guy in yellow he's gonna
shove Joseph Rose's mom about eight feet
away
wow
I guess it was a different guy that did
that but they're they're shoving him
around like a ragdoll nobody feels
threatened by Joseph Rosenbaum he's not
reaching for anybody's gun he's a mouthy
little guy he's a little dog that barks
[Applause]
and you know what he's going to do now
he's going to tell him hey I need to go
grab my bag I don't know my bag so they
let him on through
there he is about to reach down and grab
his bag off the ground
that's Joseph Rosenbaum
you've heard testimony that he tells
people shoot me
asking them to shoot him
I'm curious how that's a threat to
anyone else
he's triggered as we saw in that video
by people pointing guns at other people
which is reasonable
most people would feel that same way
and then we get to the Crux of the
defense
this threat that he supposedly made to
the defendant
the
defense would love
to be able to play you a video of this
threat they would love for you to see it
and hear it yourself
this is a night in which there are
dozens of people out there reporters and
regular folks who are recording with
their cell phones and with other cameras
all night long
we have shown you video of almost every
minute of the defendants night
from multiple different angles and yet
you have not been shown a single video
with this threat
nowhere
it's not out there
Ryan Balch testified and we have his
transcript
we have his testimony and what he says
is
there was an incident in which
Dustin Colette
had put out a dumpster fire and said
something to the effect of [ __ ] around
and find out
and Balch steps in and he has an
exchange with the protesters and he
turns around and Rosenbaum is right
there in front of my face yelling and
screaming and I tell him to back up and
he goes you know what if I catch any of
you guys blah blah blah so that's the
timing according to Ryan Balch right
after that dumpster fire
Kristan Harris from The Rundown live was
there
physically standing right next to Ryan
Balch
Not only was he there during the
dumpster fire but he stays with Ryan
Balch and or the defendant for the next
six or seven minutes recording
everything and I've played this video
for you
it is exhibit 18.
and I played for you a period of time
from one hour and 22 minutes to one hour
and 28 minutes
and I asked Chris Don Harris I call him
to the stand and I said I'm going to ask
you two questions number one do you
independently
remember
seeing Joseph Rosenbaum hearing this
threat
and he said no
and then I said okay well maybe you
missed it because you know there's a lot
going on so we re-watch your video for
me and tell me is it in there
and he said no
this video captures just I didn't I I
heard all of it I was on a conference
call I had to be on but I was listening
and there's no threat there's no
Rosenbaum it didn't happen
the defense desperately wants this
because they've got to give you a reason
why it's okay to kill Joseph Rosenbaum
and this threat is critical to their
case
but it's not there
in exhibit number three
and I'll play it for you here as I'm
talking
Joseph Rosenbaum isn't even visible now
I submit to you that even if I'm sorry
this is exhibit 18. even if there was a
threat made
it's still not enough
because Joseph rosenbaum's unarmed he
can't kill him
but
the defense
has pinned a lot of their case on a
threat that didn't happen and they can't
prove
welcome to vouch who is joining a lot of
prominent streamers
um stopping by today live video
and I'm gonna go to that Mark
Down live and I'm here with a bunch of
them
Christianity
man so here here's the dumpster fire
Joseph Rosenbaum is not in this video
here's Dustin Colette about to put the
fire out
can we all at least agree whatever the
guilt or innocence of anyone involved
these are just great people I would love
to hang out with
yeah that's true just stay on your
property
[Music]
I have to agree with her
there's Ryan Balch standing right next
to Gage gross courts
Joseph Rosenbaum isn't here
and the defendant in his group are being
told an important message as long as you
stay on your property
but don't go out there and cause trouble
history
I have to do a third if he shouldn't be
on the street
[Applause]
he was protecting their property
the other guys losing his patients we
should go outside yeah
if you guys can switch them out he's
talking to Ryan Balch right now
protect your property the respected that
just can't keep it there
[Applause]
this is where Ryan Balch goes and talks
to a protester
there's this background issue to the
entire trial that's not even really
talked about which is the whole concept
of just random dudes
patrolling like even the mere use of the
word patrolling could be the subject of
hours of exposition about the absurdity
of the entire situation
not at issue in the guilt or innocence
on on this particular situation I I I'm
conceding that
life
around
[Music]
here
[Music]
thanks guys
the rest of the video is the crowd being
warded off by gas launched by the police
they launched tear gas which affects the
defendant which affects Ryan Balch it
affects Kristan Harris and that group
all runs alongside the 59th Street Car
Source away from the street away from
any protesters
at no point in that video
do you hear any threat that Joseph
Rosenbaum makes it's not there
trust me the defense had it they'd play
it for you
now they want you to believe that that
threat is made and they also want you to
believe that it was something that the
defendant
took into account when he decided to
kill Joseph Rosenbaum
one of the questions that occurs to me
is how would the defendant even know
who that guy is
because earlier in the night Joseph
Rosenbaum is wearing a red shirt and a
blue bandana
but by the time he's killed he's got no
shirt on he's got no blue bandana
this is someone the defendant has never
even met before he's one of hundreds of
people in the crowd and yet we're
expected to believe that in a split
second the defendant remembers this guy
I don't believe so
so then that video that I just showed
you picks off leaves off at about 11 35
pm
the police have moved
the protesters south of 60th Street
they've tear gas the crowd and there's
no protesters left
59th Street is no longer in any danger
it wasn't much danger to begin with
wasn't anything left there to protect
but by this point
there's no more Danger
as law enforcement comes through you've
heard this video where they tell the
defendant is group we appreciate you and
hand them out bottles of water
as long as you stay on that private
property yeah
no one is saying you don't have the
right to stay on private property and
protect private property what people are
saying what the crowd is saying is stay
there don't go out looking for trouble
the defendant hears this message from
the police
and takes it the wrong way
he thinks oh well now I'm Junior
policeman I can go run around stopping
crime basically
but I asked him and I asked some other
Witnesses if the police are there on the
scene and the protesters are gone
go home why are you still here shouldn't
have been here in the first place but
why are you still sticking around
and interestingly enough you know one of
the questions I've always had in the
back of my mind is what's the end game
here when is this crew going to be done
and decide that it's time to leave well
right after the defendant kills Joseph
Rose's mom kills Anthony Huber and comes
back they all flee like rats off a
sinking ship
but it's boring
at 59th Street
there's no protesters
there's no action I like that since it's
boring at 59th Street science about 11
35 pm
to cross the police line and go looking
for trouble
he knows at this point he's entering a
hostile crowd he's seen this crowd he
knows what they're like
that's why he has to yell friendly to
them because he knows they're not going
to see him and think he's friendly
and he knows he's got to have Ryan Balch
with him some sort of Buddy to protect
him
and he's immediately confronted by that
man with the yellow pants who says you
just pointed your gun at me
and the defendant says yeah I did
he admits that
now what's interesting to me is they
want you to believe this never happened
they want you to believe this guy and
the yellow pants made it up or is lying
but he's just standing there by the side
of the road mine in his own business
when the defendant happens to walk up to
him do you think he just sat there and
thought Oh I'm gonna make up a lie about
this guy on the spur moment or did it
really happen and is it consistent with
everything else you've seen about the
defendant does he sound like the sort of
guy who would point a gun
at someone for standing on a car
is he Starkey is the kind of guy that
would threaten deadly force to protect
property because that's what happened
the man the yellow pants says it
happened the defendant agrees and then
he comes into the trial and says oh I I
was being sarcastic like he's a little
17 year old and he wants to get out of
it
shortly after that the defendant loses
track of his protector Ryan Balch
so now he's in a position where he knows
that he's surrounded by people
that consider him a threat
he knows that he's not supposed to go
anywhere without Ryan Balch
he knows he's supposed to go back to
59th Street and he does he tries he
walks up to the police line he says I
work there that's my business which
isn't true but whatever and they won't
let him through
now Ryan Balch makes it on through
shortly thereafter
but the defendant gives up he could go
one block in either direction and make
it back easily if he wants to
but he stops and decides you know what
I'm going to stay here and
maybe see what's going to happen
so then he talks to these people with
fire extinguishers and he's going to go
down to 63rd Street and he asks one of
them to come along
and they say no
now at this point
doesn't have Ryan Balch he knows he's
supposed to go back he knows he's
supposed to have a buddy and yet he
decides to go It Alone
he decides to run down to 63rd Street or
walk down to 63rd Street doesn't even
know if that other group is still there
doesn't even know if he's really needed
but he can't wait
to take this opportunity to go down and
confront people
because he thinks he's some sort of cop
some sort of law enforcement agent some
sort of Junior Cadet who's out there
with a with the responsibility to fight
crime nobody asked him to do that nobody
gave him the right nobody deputized him
Ryan Balch says the police told me the
crowds were going to push him down by
you you're going to deal with them
the Bearcats hand out water and tell him
he's appreciated
as he's crossing the police line they
warn him about people throwing rocks
what is the message the defendant takes
from all of this
the wrong message
oh well now I've got the power I've got
the gun I'm gonna go confront these bad
guys I'm gonna get my stick my nose in
things
so what does he do when he gets down to
63rd Street the first thing he does
we showed it to you at the very
beginning that drone video
grabs that gun and points it at someone
to protect property
points it at the zaminski's because why
because they're what about to
mess with some sort of fire they're not
threatening anyone's lives he doesn't
need to protect anyone he doesn't need
to protect himself
pointing a gun because he thinks he
needs to protect property
he says he wants to put out a fire but
the first thing he does is drop the fire
extinguisher on the ground
his AR-15 isn't going to put out a fire
so why is he really there
and we all agree you can't use or
threaten deadly force to protect someone
else's property
you are here to decide whether or not
his actions are legally Justified not to
buy pathetic excuses that might be given
to you
as a teacher when a student says to you
the dog ate my homework that's an excuse
it doesn't get you out of the homework
assignment
in a situation that is not reasonable
that is an excuse it is not a legal
justification
if you're 17 if you don't have training
or experience if you put yourself in a
situation where you're in over your head
if you're scared those are excuses those
are not legal justifications to kill
they do not erase your personal
responsibility for your own actions
wow
the court has read to you the
instructions in this case they lay out
the law that you should apply
that reading took a long time
and I understand there was a lot to
digest
and one of the things that you will have
the opportunity to do when you go back
and deliberate is read through those
instructions yourselves
because I get that listening to them
doesn't always make it clear
but I encourage you to focus on some
things when you consider the defendant's
behavior in this case
you are told that criminal criminally
Reckless conduct
is conduct that threatens other people's
lives and poses an unreasonable and
substantial risk
to other people
there is no dispute the defendant's
activities here threatened other
people's lives he took two lives
you know this is not like a normal
murder case a lot of murder cases were
in here trying to convince a jury that
the defendant killed somebody that's not
in dispute here that's the easy part
the question is does it get a pass
do we think that's okay
do we think what he did was right
that's the question you have to answer
and when you consider whether his
conduct was criminally Reckless consider
did it pose an unreasonable and
substantial threat
to the safety of others
count four
charges him with first degree
intentional homicide of Anthony Huber
there is no doubt
that the defendant intended to kill
Anthony Huber or committed conduct that
he knew was practically certain
to kill Anthony Huber that gun was
pointed at Anthony Huber's lower left
rib cage and the defendant deliberately
pulled the trigger that was no accident
and when you do that with an AR-15
against someone's body it is practically
certain to kill
we all know this case comes down to
self-defense
but there's a high bar for using deadly
force
in a self-defense situation this is
crucial this is critical it may
intentionally use Force which is
intended or likely to cause death or
great bodily harm only if
the defendant reasonably believed
that the force was necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself
so did Joseph Rosenbaum
pose an imminent threat of death or
great bodily harm to the defendant
no way
did Anthony Huber pose an imminent
threat of death or great bodily harm to
the defendant absolutely not
did jump kickman or gauge grosquirts no
none of these people posed an imminent
threat to the defendant's life or to
cause great bodily harm
the standard when you make this decision
is what a person of ordinary
intelligence and Prudence would have
believed in the defendant's position
under the circumstances that existed at
the time of the alleged offense
the reasonableness of the defendant's
beliefs must be determined from the
standpoint of the defendant
at the time of the defendant's acts and
not from the Viewpoint of the jury now
so put yourself in the defendant's
position
would you have done the same thing
would a reasonable person have done the
same thing would you have engaged in The
Reckless conduct that led to this course
of events would you have gone out after
curfew with an AR-15 looking for trouble
would you have aimed at other people
would you have tried to use the gun to
protect an empty car lot
no reasonable person would have done
these things
the court has also instructed you on
provocation
you cannot hide
behind self-defense if you provoked the
incident if you created the danger you
forfeit the right to self-defense
by bringing that gun aiming it at people
threatening people's lives
the defendant provoked everything
and if he does that he has to exhaust
all reasonable means to avoid a
confrontation all reasonable means
so if Joseph rosenbaum's running at him
Joseph Rosenbaum is no threat to his
life
and not only is the defendant expected
to run he's expected to yell push shove
that Ragdoll around run backs for help
call 9-1-1 call for help do all sorts of
other things besides just turn and fire
four shots
as Joseph Rosenbaum Falls helpless to
the ground
ladies and gentlemen
there is no doubt in this case
that the defendant committed these
crimes
he committed a first degree Reckless
homicide against Joseph Rosenbaum
he put Richie mcginnis's life in
jeopardy he put jump kick man's life in
jeopardy he intended to kill Anthony
Huber and he attempted to kill Gage
grosskroitz all of those elements
true
the question is whether or not you
believe that his actions were legally
Justified
and I submit to you that no reasonable
person would have done what the
defendant did
and that makes your decision easy
he is guilty of all counts
thank you wow the
prosecutioner let's take a break and um
about
2 25 hopefully
so further admonishments from the judge
whatever you do ensure you go to the
bathroom yeah somewhere other than the
cartoon
by the way how are the calzones the food
is here
let's take a break lunch is here
uncharged piccolos pizza is here in fact
we have Subway tomorrow
warm food around noon all right how was
the KFC very good all right enjoy your
lunch all right so they will be taking a
break
um and we'll be back in about
very very 10 15 minutes uh I uh so
what's my thought on the closing
statement as a non-lawyer from the
prosecution I think that given the facts
of the case Mr Binger did almost as good
as a job as could be done
I think that there was a moment where
and we'll have to go back where you said
something along the lines of if you
bring the gun you can no longer claim
self-defense
that's not true legally is my
understanding
you can be the one who brings the gun
and it still could be self-defense the
mere presence of the gun is not
um
indicate
you know I I you could have gotten away
with murder because I wasn't uh I wasn't
timing it uh after Hemmings you were a
holiday talk
what no way
no way
no way
s and they can't
get
it
again
so well that's gonna be under oath and
wow
sorry we'll uh
we'll uh have a hearing on it
uh I'll explain that in a second
so the the prosecution has been allotted
two and a half hours total including
their rebuttal
if Mr Binger went an hour 45 as Jim
Krauss just claimed
he would have 45 minutes for the
rebuttal after the defense
if he went two hours and eight minutes
he would have only 22 minutes for the
rebuttal which sounds tight okay so this
is the so they one one side's claiming
he spoke an hour 45 the other side's
claiming that he spoke uh two hours and
eight minutes
um
let's see here vouch Destiny [ __ ] III
is asking when can we expect the verdict
we we have no idea there's it's not even
clear that they will deliberate today
um the defense now will have up to two
and a half hours for their closing
statement that would put us at let me
see 325
and then two and a half puts us at 555
which would be 455 there I don't see how
you even necessarily do the rebuttal
today depending on how long the defense
goes then there's a question as to
whether they would even be you know then
you've got the rebuttal I don't know my
instinct is they won't re really even
start to deliberate until tomorrow
that's my sense okay
um I want to say thanks to some amazing
people these are some of the most
patriotic Americans I can imagine Dan
Stevens Jeremy Jones and Jasmine Kennedy
we love all three of you three people
who grabbed memberships on my website
joinpakman.com you too can sign up at
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
uncharged pickles uncharged piccolos
which
saves you uh 69 I also want to say
thanks to our new patreon supporters j s
Mark dimaselli and Jacob Penland have
pledged those count double today
that puts us at 51. now I have an extra
special announcement this is a
heretofore unannounced element of the
show at 6 p.m eastern time today right
after the conclusion of this
I will be doing an Instagram live with
actor Casey Simpson who I'm told our
younger viewers are very familiar with
he's a follower of the show he's a
progressive we're gonna do it might even
be partially in Spanish He Speaks great
Spanish we had a completely abortive
attempt at a joint live stream on tick
tocks not long ago there was some kind
of technical problem we are going to do
it on Instagram today
okay very good people love it
um that's gonna be today at 6 p.m
Eastern Time everybody relax please oh
my God please proceed Governor that'll
be at 6 p.m eastern time today so I look
forward to seeing many of you there
it'll be on the david.pakman Instagram
as well as on Casey Simpson's Instagram
he's got he has like a borderline
illegal number of followers let me see
where he's at right now close to 2
million I have 97 000. so that's going
to be that's a preferential stream for
me obviously so that'll be at 6 p.m
eastern time today at the bottom of this
hour
um I'm gonna have to get on another
meeting it's crazy all these people want
to have meetings business meetings all
these different things I'm gonna get on
that um at the bottom of the hour but
this the stream will continue
super chats are pouring in like someone
opened a fire hose Trump's defense used
half their time during his second
impeachment yet the defense may not use
all of their time and they've said they
don't really plan to
I believe there was a missed opportunity
to mention that in the video Kyle is
running towards the crowd gun drawn how
did he then feel threatened
worst murder trial judge since Lance Ito
it's incredibly painful to recall the
details did the judge just joke you
could have gotten away with murder
it's a joke but really
Kevin says it's been a crazy trial and
the N2 people are dead another wounded
and one hangs in the balance this isn't
a football game these are people
Humanity gets lost sometimes
quote you could have gotten away with
murder I know
I know it's crazy David pakman sir what
will they be eating on the day of the
verdict I don't even
sir KFC Subway or maybe the Asian food
from the ports
um I actually bumped into uh I didn't
bump into I saw a friend over the
weekend
um and she's from a part of New York
where they have like a hint of this same
accent and she was talking about a
co-worker being fired and I just was
like I've been dealing with that this
this entire week I've been dealing with
that accent oh I'm forward around noon
by the way how are the calzones
do you think the fact that most people
recall the last bit of information to
reach decisions hurts the prosecution no
because the prosecution will get a
rebuttal the prosecution gets the last
word
the prosecution will have um somewhere
between 22 and 45 minutes of rebuttal
so that is something we are standing by
for
momentarily a few voicemails did come in
I was asked if Whitney calls in
let us know she just left this is hot
off the presses listen to this
[Music]
and stuff like that but also like
sometimes buying a gun is just
doesn't work just because
people can lie and get your guns taken
away
um so like recently I saw some stuff in
the news about uh Maria butina because
people all right now we're getting off
track also the Eggman called in which I
like let's listen to the Eggman
hey Dave I'm not a doctor but listen man
when looking at Kyle rittenhouse's mom
okay
um you could say that she's a mentally
disabled racist and you can determine
that from just listening to her on just
one or two interviews okay that's the
Eggman is shot out of a cannon um Let me
clarify what he's referring to
today I did a quite a segment about the
Sean Hannity interview with Wendy
Rittenhouse and in it I mentioned a lot
of people have been writing to me saying
David Wendy Rittenhouse is being taken
advantage of she's clearly cognitively
disabled I found no evidence that she's
cognitively disabled I think some people
are editorializing her physical
appearance to say she's clearly mentally
disabled
I don't know that at all and I think the
Eggman is reacting to that so let's
continue to listen pretty much it's
obvious but you can make determination
about Trump's health or Biden's Health
just as a bystander back in the day Dave
we had an r word to call people like her
okay it's actually a medical term when
your growth is is uh stunted okay your
mental growth it's called the r word
you can't say it anymore okay but that's
what she is an r word racist and if you
look at her and you can't see that from
listening to her you're giving her just
way too much benefit of the doubt the
eggman's on fire
wow I'm shocked here Shalom brother oh
and that's why he came out that way he's
disgusting just like her and if you
think people are judging her because how
she looks fine look at her face look at
her physical features scientifically
biologically you can look at her and see
that she's missing a a link a gene or
something there's something wrong with
those people oh my God
wow Shalom to the Eggman
um that that is really something else uh
I don't know how the crowd's going to
react to that
the Eggman even left another voicemail
do you guys want to hear the second one
because he's really on fire I want to
say thanks to Christopher Copley who
just made a pledge via patreon patreon
pledges count double today and it puts
us at 53.
wow people want the other Eggman
voicemail all right here's the second
Eggman voicemail these are super
aggressive today
I loved the call from Miss Darcy today
Dave so yeah your older listeners are
not all crazy right Wingers okay or old
people aren't crazy right-wingers but
the ones that listen to you Miss Darcy
just proved are New York liberal Elite
maybe Jewish Come On Dave dog and water
I want you to get an elderly person to
call your show and tell you that they
it's like a Southern accent or you know
something like that like um he yeah she
I was complimented by a caller on the
this is off podcast stuff the eggman's
all over today's podcast
which you all should be I jokingly said
dog the other day fraud fraud fraud it's
a fraud yeah and the caller really liked
it of course elderly people in New York
City like Ms Darcy
are liberals
but in the rest of the country elderly
people are crazy [ __ ] right-wing
psychos okay and they're all rooting for
Kyle Rittenhouse and these two guys that
murdered Ahmad Arbury so um it's scary
out there Dave I do like Miss Darcy
though I've got to go give my dog some
water right now because he's probably
thirsty Shalom brother all right so
that's the Eggman that's his full
testimony today
um
and re I mean I'm I'm gonna have to
really think about it for a while that's
that's a lot that's a lot a lot a lot
from the Eggman will I open phone lines
today so here's the deal
if we get to a hundred members I will
open phone lines
however depending on how long this goes
I may have to go into my live stream
with actor Casey Simpson so if that
happens we'll carry over the success of
the hundred to tomorrow and we'll open
phone lines tomorrow one way or the
other okay so please do support the
stream we are hard banned from from
twitch it's a total hard band
um and it's a it's a 30-day ban we're
seven days in 23 days to go we lost our
thousand paid members on Twitch so
please please please I would love it if
you signed up on our website
joinpakman.com because it's uh it's been
a tough one it's been a tough one we
were off uh off to the running uh Off to
the Races I guess I would say
um and then we just got hard band and
then our appeal has not even been
adjudicated yet so the coupon code today
is uncharged pickles you see it above my
head you save 69 when you sign up on my
website with that code uncharged
piccolos let's look at a few other super
chats David what's in the glasses are
you a Seltzer man this is just regular
water still as they call it these days
um just still water nothing nothing too
special
let's see if I have anything else here
here's one other Written House related
voicemail
David sir uh watching this Kyle
Rittenhouse trial with you right now and
I gotta say yeah I agree with you the
prosecution's doing well and closing
arguments
um whether it changes the
guilty or not guilty we'll see I tend to
agree with you
on the statement you made that it's
looking like he's gonna get caught okay
all right good so the the caller agrees
with me is essentially what we're
talking about here
um and let me see if I have anything
else on the trial
hi David my name is Nico from California
Los Angeles California
um I just wanted to say thank you so
much for all your coverage on the
Rittenhouse trial pleasure this judge
seems to be holding the uh defense's
hands in this trial
um
I'm just seeing you say the the or the
prosecution doesn't really have any
recourse if it's a non-guilty
what do you think is going to happen
after seeing their last minute
statements also uh you are so gorgeous
um are you single and where where do you
stay okay so I'm gonna assume the caller
is male because of the name Nico
although I could be wrong I am not
single but I I exclusively date women
that is something that uh I do so if
indeed the caller is is male it would
not be in my uh you're not on the right
team I guess is what I would say with
complete and total peace and love but I
appreciate the kind words of course
um let me see if I have any other
I do have
um one from one more from Whitney I
guess
like you know Caucasian families
start you know doing balloon size
and
what you know your people are getting
more and more recess
like
they're having their kids
inherit a world okay in which they just
all right so that's that we're going to
be done with that all right so the trial
is going to be whoa very shaky camera
there as you can see the trial is going
to be back momentarily
um I am going to step away I've got a
call in seven minutes then I'm gonna be
back we're gonna have the defense
closing arguments and then the rebuttal
from the prosecution I think it will get
crazy today everybody stand by the
stream's not ending it's gonna they're
back in five minutes and then I'll be
back in about 20. all right we'll see
you then
uh I I think we agree for the most part
on the
second portion of the
argument it would have been from around
an hour and 13 minutes
uh Detective Howard and I both timed the
first part
and
we have it well
attorney Richards has it as 37 minutes I
have it as 32
so I don't think it's two hour even with
his uh
his time stamps it's not two hours and
eight minutes
yeah look I mean you know I
I wouldn't have strictly enforced it I'm
but I won't because someone will accuse
me of being biased against my own
religion but
um
um
I I usually have been quite permissive
about this I said very
drools and then somewhat indulgent so I
probably won't call anybody about it but
um so you can you can both talk for
eight hours okay yeah we got it
you please the court ladies and
gentlemen are the jury good afternoon
fantasy
and showing you
sniff that states exhibit 18 which Mr
Binger just spent three or four minutes
showing that Mr Rosenbaum wasn't around
my client couldn't know that he wraps
his head you know or chain bag Orange
ladies and gentlemen
we had this video almost as long as
they've had this video but Mr Binger
will use this video to lie to your faces
and tell you that Kyle Rittenhouse was
taking advantage of the situation
it's in the picture
um it's argument
ladies and gentlemen
this case
is not a game
it is my client's life we don't play
fast and loose with the facts pretending
that Mr Rosenbaum was citizen a number
one guy he was a bad man he was there he
was causing trouble he was a rioter and
my client had to deal with him that
night alone
when I say that the truth matters and
this is not a game what do I mean by
that
Binger is the one who put on the kandiri
brothers
the reason he put them on in spite of
what he might say today
because he wanted you now 18 soon to be
12 people to say gosh that kid just went
to that place and just protected it he
wasn't asked he was asked
Mr kandiri's asked Nick Nick got a group
of people to go down there to people
from West Bend came
provocation another thing
think back to back on November 2nd when
this case started
did you hear one word out of Mr binger's
mouth about provocation you didn't
because it was never said but on his
case explodes in his face now he comes
with provocation
that was opening
and morals importantly
in opening quoting from Mr bigger's
first paragraph of his opening statement
on November 2nd
2021. this occurred after the defendant
chased down Mr Rosenbaum and confronted
him while yielding an ar-14
ladies and gentlemen you've seen the
videos Mr Rosenbaum sees and I'll show
you the video in my closing argument
you'll see Mr Rosenbaum take off
when he sees my client coming along with
his zaminski's set up the ambush of my
client provocation I don't think so
the things that I've just pointed out to
you
why is that a problem
because one he is lying
two he's misrepresenting or
he wasn't prepared when he started this
trial and his closing argument has been
a change to try and fit what has come
out remember how when he was talking
There's real proof that the rosenbaums
excuse me Rosenbaum and zaminski knew
each other maybe they didn't know each
other that night but they were together
throughout the night you see them
together in pictures wreaking havoc in
this city
and now
we have the magic pixel camera that
brings forth his provocation
I'm going to go through the charges
and we'll talk about each one of them
then I'll go through the witnesses and
hopefully I'll bring it home in an
honest and forthright fashion
count one
Reckless homicide
my client shot Joseph Rosenbaum ladies
and gentlemen make no mistake there was
nothing Reckless about my client's
conduct that day
in regards to Mr Rosenbaum Mr Rosenbaum
was coming at him
my client ran from him retreated which
is not needed continues to run
plastic bag is thrown the metallic
plastic bag
Kyle doesn't know what it is at that
time
it causes him to turn and look over his
shoulder pointing the gun in that
direction
Mr Rosenbaum is he dissuaded by that
no he is not he continues running and
advancing on my client
that whole time
the state doesn't say anything about Mr
zaminski firing the shot
Mr zaminski having his gun out
think of the circumstances as they
existed at 11 50 on August 20th excuse
me August 25th of 2020. he runs through
that parking lot he continues running on
turns as he comes into that box canyon
with the cars the van and I believe it's
a Pepsi machine and he turns because he
has no place else to go
I'll show you the zanine video
later on
what's important about the tzaneen video
you see that mob of people destroying
the cars at car Source three which Mr
Binger doesn't want my client to go and
try to protect even though he was asked
by those individuals to protect that
property Nick Smith called him hey
they're bashing up the cars and starting
fires go down there he goes down there
he has as much right to go there as
anybody else in the city of Kenosha and
be unmolested by the likes of Joseph
Rosenbaum
Kelly and Joshua zaminsky
and Mr Binger says oh we'll get the
zaminski's later well ladies and
gentlemen
last time I checked this is still United
States of America and he has the burden
of proof if he wants you guys to believe
that my client pointed a gun at him
called his Dimensions put him on the
witness stand ask him questions and let
me or Mr sharafasy cross-examine them
that's how we do things in a court of
law but not in Mr binger's Court
he says I'm blaming the victim as a
defense lawyer I might get accused of
that more than some other people
ladies and gentlemen Mr Rosenbaum was
shot
because he was chasing my client and
going to kill him take his gun and carry
out the threats he made
and Mr Binger wants to make a big
Hubble woo about the shot in the back
remembers opening statement he shot him
in the back and that's why I'm sitting
here in front of the jury like this
did he shoot him here did he shoot him
there
because of the way the bullet went in
and where the bullet ended up in the hip
you know full well that the individual
and I asked the doctor is on a
horizontal plane what is that horizontal
plane consistent of somebody leaping
lunging at my client
and we know how close
Mr Rosenbaum was to my client the
furthest he could have been when it
started the first shot four feet with
the stipling
we know that his hand was on the gun
so bigger wants you to believe that that
was just happen stance and accident
come on people
physical evidence does not lie
your common sense and good judgment
he talks about Mr Rosenbaum just somehow
ending up down at the riots
remember that
Mr Rosenbaum according to testimony
walked from the bus Center
four miles out to Ms Schwartz house
and then he couldn't stay there for some
reason and four miles all the way back
that's not just ending up that's going
someplace with a purpose and throughout
the night you saw his purpose
and
there was more than one piece of
testimony about Mr Rosenbaum whether it
was a hospital
or whether or not it was a jail
remember that
and there was testimony regarding his
medication
Ms Swartz said we couldn't get
medication because the Walgreens were
all boarded up
she said
the hospital said they gave him his
medication so whatever facility gave him
his medication
Mr Binger the man with the burden of
proof
why didn't he bring in
a hospital or a jail to prove that Mr
Rosenbaum was properly medicated
he'd been off his medications according
to miss swart for seven to ten days
we know
that he was acting like somebody who
wasn't on their proper medication he was
not acting normal
expectation
next
Richie Richard McGinnis
Reckless
and here
Mr McGinnis I'd like to talk about
because the self-defense
does not go
to Mr McGinnis but if Kyle was
privileged in exercising self-defense
against Mr Rosenbaum it carries over to
the endangering count of Mr McGinnis
and Mr McGinnis
specifically
if the defendant am reading directly
from an instruction page nine
second full paragraph which you will be
given
if the defendant was acting lawfully in
self-defense
his conduct did not create an
unreasonable risk to another that is Mr
McGinnis
ladies and gentlemen when my clients
shot Joseph Rosenbaum he feared for his
life he feared because of the prior
threats the prior statements and the
violent acts that had been witnessed by
my client
Mr McGinnis as a witness
I think he helped us more than he heard
us he talked about this was on Cross for
Mr Binger how do you know what Mr
Rosenbaum was thinking because I don't
but I know he yelled [ __ ] you and then
lunged
at Kyle Rittenhouse
why is he yelling the fu
one of two things one to intimidate
or two he got into a situation over his
head
thinking as he said before chasing him
you won't do [ __ ] MFR to my client well
he was wrong
he States Kyle did not know Richard that
he was there meaning Richard McGinnis
he's a citizen journalist who was
running along with his hand
in his his phone and his hand up in the
air
in to get a story
my client is not responsible for
endangering him when he runs into danger
plus the instruction says
that if he was privileged as to
Rosenbaum he's privileged as to count to
Mr McGinnis count three
jump kick man
the uncomplaining
unidentified
Witness
in count three
there will be some video later on when
I'm going through some of that you'll
see and I ask you to pay attention this
said
he's not kicking him he doesn't hit him
when you watch the video and it'll be in
slow motion
watch where his foot goes watch what
happens to Kyle's head the force of him
kicking him in the face spins his body
180 degrees around and then it's I
Huber coming in from behind hitting him
in the neck with the skateboard
ladies and gentlemen
what you see throughout event number two
and this is the beginning of it
is
individuals working in a mob
they don't know
what happened at car Source three event
number one but somebody said hey he shot
somebody doesn't know that he was being
chased by a crazy person
but they're gonna get their licks in on
Kyle Rittenhouse or as they perceive him
somebody from the other side who has
been putting out their fires causing
problems for their for them stopping
them from wreaking havoc in Kenosha like
they did the night before
okay
and ladies and gentlemen the standard is
likely to cause death or great bodily
harm great bodily harm
defined as likely to cause serious
bodily injury a kick to the Head
is likely to cause a serious injury did
my clients suffer a debilitating injury
as a result of that no but that's not
the standard
Mr Huber
he's a rioter
pushing a dumpster lit on fire going to
the barricades to pick up pepper balls
throw them back pointing his middle
finger at the police he's assisting
Rosenbaum at the gas station
hits Rittenhouse two times with the
skateboard and attempts to disarm him
you'll see it all in the slow motion
video later on
and
Kyle Rittenhouse is running away
from Anthony Huber the state wants to
call
my client an active shooter
and the reason they want to do that is
because of the loaded connotations of
that work everyone has heard of the
theater killings the school shootings
and things like that ask yourself
the definition of an active shooter is
somebody with a plan
to inflict multiple casualties usually
out of anger or animus towards a group
this case
what caused Kyle Rittenhouse
shoot somebody
Joseph Rosenwald he runs
after shooting Joseph Rosenbaum for
almost two blocks before scene number
two
Mr Binger makes a big thing about Kyle
Rittenhouse not staying around
car Source three after the shooting
ladies and gentlemen
if Kyle Rittenhouse had stayed at car
Source 3
all that would have happened is it would
have made the police have an easier job
because scene one and scene two would
have been put in the same location my
client ran two blocks without shooting
at anyone pointing at anyone doing
anything to try and get away
tells the individuals he's going to the
police and he's running in that
direction when he stopped he's hit in
the head with a hand with a rock in it
Knocking his hat off Mr Binger says oh
he just knocked his hat off I don't
think that individual was trying to
steal Mr rittenhouse's Hat
he was trying to take his head off who
comes in next
Anthony Huber for the first time
hit some
opening statement Mr Binger was he takes
a swing at him now it's he blocked
because we took the videotape and
lightened it up
Huber strikes him in the head and arm
the first time
jump kick man comes in kicks him in the
face
spins his body 180 degrees and Anthony
Huber comes in for the second lick to
the shoulder neck area trying to take
his head off
and when he does that his other hand
goes grabbing for the gun his bare hand
onto the gun and pulling it away from
Kyle Rittenhouse
if your Binger wants Kyle to sit there
and Hope
and pray to God his strap works and
Anthony Huber can't get the gun
we don't know that we'll never know that
as he's running away from him a shot as
the gun is being separated from his body
and you'll see the butt way far away
when the shot is finally fired
foreign
said he was concerned about the blows
that jump kick man
and
Anthony Huber were inflicting on Kyle's
head
that's probably
the only thing I agree with with Mr
Rosewood
Gage girl squids
the state must prove Beyond a reasonable
doubt that what Kyle did under those
facts and circumstances was unreasonable
that he was not entitled to self-defense
consider all the events that had
occurred that evening
him being attacked kicked in the head
hit in the head with a skateboard
other individuals running up on him and
now Mr grossquits runs up on him
and the first action of Mr gross woods
and I'll go through the video later
is really he's running in the hand is
coming up and The Gunshot with humor
goes off and the natural reaction is the
Flinch he covers up
and then he pulls his hands up and as
he's standing with his hands up look
he's not gripping the gun anymore in a
pistol grip hands apart hands up and as
he comes in to finish the job
the hand is on the gun going for Mr
Rittenhouse and
he says it's an involuntary movement
the shot comes before it gets directly
to his head but that motion is coming
the shot and it continues on with that
momentum enough momentum to go through
the bullet and point directly at Kyle's
head does Kyle fire again no he doesn't
actions likely to cause death or great
bodily harm and he is coming in with a
loaded Glock
and we asked Mr Gage girls quits about
it
he wouldn't even admit that there was
one in the chamber
that's why we had to put on the officer
to talk about the unfired shell casing
lakowski talked about clearing the
weapon and a live round coming out
because girls quits won't say anything
that puts them in a bad light gross
quits the person who is 10 million
reasons to lie and we all know he did
lie because he never
gave a new interview after giving his
statement saying he dropped his gun
going down the street
ladies and gentlemen those are the
charges those are a synopsis of the
charges as I stated
the burden is on the state and they must
prove Beyond a reasonable doubt that my
client did not have the right to
self-defense Kyle as he sits here is
Presumed Innocent of all charges if
there is any reasonable hypothesis
to reconcile with Kyle's innocence that
is what you are to choose
remember when looking at the burden of
proof
they have it
think about some of the things
the shoddy investigation
to rush to judgment from the Kenosha
District Attorney's office
the
zaminski's not being called
as Witnesses
they have the burden of proof we don't
they
want it to be that Kyle was out there
doing something
improper Kyle was a 17 year old kid out
there trying to help this community
he was asked to provide help in
protecting property at the car sources
it started and he did it he did provide
Aid and he was asking if anybody needed
Aid whether somebody chooses to accept
that Aid that's on them but Mr Binger
wants to poo poo his sincere belief that
he's helping people and because he
borrowed bandages from Dominic black
and I think he might have borrowed
something from lakowski also but in the
picture
when the canary poses with all the
people are going to protect his property
there's Kyle's Big Orange
Gator box he's got his pack on filled
with things and he's willing to do that
ladies and gentlemen
Kyle was not an active shooter that is a
buzzword that the state wants to lash on
to because it excuses the actions of
that mob on the 25th of 2020.
whenever Kyle was there
he reacted to people attacking him
there's numerous times and you'll see
him on the video he does not shoot he
runs two blocks from 63rd to 61st scene
two without firing his weapon individual
hits him in the back of the head he does
not turn around to address that threat
humor
takes a swing at him with the skateboard
like that Kyle blocks and the
skateboards knocked out of his hand he
doesn't turn around and shoot him he
keeps running and falls from the two
hits
he's run that far and yet somehow he
just fell over on his own
as soon as he's on the ground they're
there
attacking him and you see the people
a lot of self-defense
seen it you've heard it
now I'm going to go through the
witnesses
oh
Dominic black first Witness
charged by Mr Binger for providing the
gun to my client
who counts looking at up to six years in
prison his case has been adjourned so
that he can help the state I don't think
he helped the state that much I think he
was a pretty truthful witness all in all
he told him about Kyle there to help
people that they had permission from the
kandiris that he saw Kyle
help the woman with the foot help the
person with the hand Mr Binger wants to
just say oh that doesn't matter if it
wasn't Kyle it would have been somebody
else the point is he was there
and he did it
there was no pointing by Kyle of any
laser sight there was no ability for
Kyle or him to point laser sights at
anyone because their guns didn't have
the type of Optics that did that
said Kyle was there to help
the only person helping
was Kyle
say what he wants about whether or not
he let Kyle take the gun or not take the
gun
he never told him not to
he went to the location with him
they bought straps at jalenskies
together
he's trying to cover his butt a little
bit
the guns were there and they took them
they took the guns as he said to deter
people attacking them
saw Kyle at the end sweating
was in shock
and said
that he shot someone he had to do it
that is Dominic black
Corey Washington
saw the rioters breaking up concrete at
the church parking lot
described Rosenbaum as erratic
state of the crowd was suspicious hey
I don't know what that means one of the
things that I thought was strange was
they were the night before they were
burning garbage trucks but they only
burnt the old ones I think that tells
you something about his point of view
that there's a certain amount of
property damage that is Justified and
okay
um Kenosha was using those garbage
trucks that the rioters lit on fire
and
nothing
regarding property destruction
was going to do anything to help Jacob
Lake
we also learned the Kyle Rittenhouse
smokes
cigarettes and that he has an affinity
for the dinosaur museum
Detective Howard ladies and gentlemen
detective Howard's testimony and
detective antaranian's testimony is the
stuff of what Reasonable Doubt is made
of
two detectives both lead officers on
this case they've sat through every
minute of this trial
and their opinions of the actions of Mr
Rosenbaum from testimony
videos couldn't be more diametrically
opposed
Detective Howard on cross-examination
knew that the guy was hiding in the car
and jumped out from behind the car and
began chasing Kyle Rittenhouse oh boy
that's not good for the state's case so
there's the old Chit Chat between Mr
Howard and Mr antoramian and the
prosecutors after and all sudden we've
come up with the new Theory
and you heard the new theory that he
raised the gun
and
that's what's on the video can I have
the firearm please
okay
when
after lunch
check it again
[Music]
thank you
think about when Kyle Rittenhouse
is firing the gun when he's seen holding
the gun
throughout the events of the 25th
shouldering the gun and I'm not going to
bring it all the way up to my shoulder
to the right right shoulder which would
be a stance like this
the reason I objected
in his closing argument is because
that's not the way he was standing if
he's standing like this
this is right-handed
pointing the gun this way up at the
ready his back would be to the Drone
footage
in the Drone footage you see the arm
it would be somebody having to hold the
gun left-handed this is a right-handed
firearm if this gun is brought up to his
face
and it is pulled back
the shell casing hot and the fire that
ejects it is going to be going right
into Kyle's face
photograph I'll talk about later
you don't see the straps on a shirt it
didn't happen the way he said it doesn't
happen the way in the foot in the
photograph
I'm gonna need this again
burden of proof once again
the telephones the searching of
telephones with search warrants the
painting of Records I have no problem
with that it's good police work
but when you're picking shoes and you
make favorites it's not
my client testified and I'll say it this
way the detective testified
that my clients phone was sent to the
FBI
it was unsearchable because of the
operating system the FBI and the federal
government had not cracked it yet
we found out about that we had nothing
to hide here here's the numbers search
the phone as long as we're given
simultaneous copy so we have what you
have we can have our experts look at it
they can have their experts look at it
so we know that there isn't anything
added or deleted we did that we gave
that to the state if we had something to
hide they never would have gotten in
that phone
they took the phone
they made a copy they searched it lo and
behold nothing of an incriminating
nature in it nothing militia white
supremacist any of that
Gage gross quits
different story
they had a valid search warrant for it
the only search warrant that these guys
have never not executed when it's
sitting right in front of them
not just that but Mr girl squids could
have consented to them going in the
phone if he has nothing to hide
why not
why not let them look in the phone and
let's take common sense and judgment one
step further
police officers get search warrants
they execute the search warrant
sometimes somebody feels as though their
rights have been violated and it gets
litigated in a court of law
if it was illegal the information in
that search warrant never comes out in
court
if it's legal after a judge has said
there were no rights violated it comes
in in evidence what was Mr grosquit's
afraid of why wouldn't the state execute
the search warrant let Mr gross quit
send his attorney object file a motion
and say you can't go in my phone
let the judge decide not the person
who's Prosecuting and protecting Mr
grossquit's come on people
Mr grosquitz has 10 million reasons for
not wanting somebody to go on his phone
the timing
with the detectives and some of their
actions I think are very important
they get down to Antioch at about 3 30
in the morning of the 26th less than
four hours after this happens
by six o'clock
it's 30 given the benefit of the doubt
Kyle Rittenhouse is under arrest for
first degree murder
there's not been any autopsy done
there haven't been any witness
statements taken
they've got two or three videos
the bullets I should say it this way all
of the bullets have not even been picked
up from car Source at this point
but they're willing to make a decision
and were they under pressure
I'm sure they were they're afraid that
there's going to be another night
of looting
destruction in Kenosha
because of this happening and the way
the word got out
he traveled across state lines he was
here he brought his AR with him
the AR was here he was a white
supremacist looking for trouble
nothing nothing
that's why ladies and gentlemen when we
picked you guys as jurors we asked you
if you could decide based upon the
evidence that happens in the courtroom
not
what you'd heard before not all of the
lies and untruths that have been put out
in the media I heard one guy say my
client discharged the guns 60 times
ladies and gentlemen what's happening in
court is what you decide the truth on
he was charged on the 27th
still they didn't have the information
the autopsy's final anything like that
ladies and gentlemen this has been a
rush to judgment
Richie McGinnis I talked about earlier
citizens
citizen journalists Mr Binger talked
about him seeing guns but remember the
cross of Mr McGinnis guns are not legal
in Portland Washington or DC or New York
they're not allowed on the streets you
can be arrested there are state laws
and ladies and gentlemen
the gun in this case is no longer an
issue
whether or not it was a dangerous weapon
as it applies to the charges is but my
client is no longer charged with minor
in possession of a firearm
but he needs his AR-15 and the assault
weapon and the fear that goes with that
to try and bring home an unjust guilty
verdict Ryan Balch
Ryan Balch had never met Kyle written
Rittenhouse before the evening hours of
the 25th has never spoken to him or
known him after
and yet the state wants you to believe
he made up something about a threat to
kill why what's in it for him
the threat if I get either of you alone
I will kill you that is a threat with a
statement and a promise
and lo and behold the chance presented
itself to Mr Mr Rosenbaum
and he attempted to execute it and I
don't for a minute
believe
that he would have done it
if it was Mr Balch who's much bigger
than my client muscular well-built
and much more assertive and forceful
Rosenbaum like any as he referred to him
I don't even know what he called them a
ragdoll whatever but
the little guy who gets beat up likes to
go after the next littlest guy he saw
Kyle alone and that's what he chose to
or he could have been mistaken and
thinking it was the other person at the
ultimate that he went after and had to
be held back they were dressed very
similarly baseball caps mask and the
only difference was the difference
between shorts and alarm pants I can't
answer that Mr Rosenbaum at this point I
guess can't either
but you see
Mr Rosenbaum right around the timing
question
at that location menacing with his chain
I skipped
that's Mr Balch I talked about him going
on
Ms Reyes Amber Rasmussen she was the D.A
DNA expert what I say to the
you is DNA is an incredibly useful tool
but DNA is only as useful as what you
put into it and if
DNA shows
anything it shows that it's not proof
positive in this case we know in hearing
from Dr Kelly that he most probably
touched the gun
was a contact wound is the way he
described it
and we know through the videos Huber
touched the gun with his bare hand and
yet no DNA was found on that gun so
don't let your eyes deceive you don't
let the physical evidence
be discounted because of what she said
the end of that Barrel was not swabbed
and we know is a picture of someone
appearing to touch a gun considered
physical evidence that's weird would
have had the soot on all of the fingers
Jason lakowski
thought was an interesting Witness
he was the marine who put the phrase
shout shove show shoot
and I asked him about that and I don't
for a minute just believe that that's
the Marines rule is there any retreat in
there and he said no he looked at me
like I was stupid
the reason he looked like that was
because they don't retreat yet Kyle
Rittenhouse did Retreat he tried getting
away from Mr Rosenbaum
he described Joseph guys just a quick
introduction I felt that the the
prosecution has not done a good job
basically the whole case so far I've
been watching this defense while on my
call this is not great in my mind I'm
not saying he's going to be guilty but
it this is not very compelling
he was there for a shorter period of
time than anyone else at car source
he also cleared Gage girls with his gun
after the shooting and made it safe took
the shell out of it
and I asked you to think back to the
direct examination of Mr lakowski by the
state
when they asked him what did Kyle say to
you his first statement was I just shot
somebody I need help that's what he
testified to and then Mr Binger shows
him the statement and gets him to say
well I told the FBI that ladies and
gentlemen I don't know what he told the
FBI the FBI doesn't let him see that
statement doesn't let him read the
statement and say you've read this to me
it's true in a correct copy they write
down what they think they heard I ask
you to think about what he said
didn't shoot somebody why does he need
help
that makes no sense
said it he testified to it
that's what happened
State confronted him
and pushes him back to his original
statement so he doesn't get in trouble
he put the tourniquet on Gage grow
squids
testified that he had his AR-15 with him
providing Medical Services
first aid just like Kyle Rittenhouse
Elementary and I find it so ironic that
he
was there
Gage groskowitz had said to them go home
we have our own Medics you Stooges and
who ultimately helps
him with his tourniquet
Sarah Hughes
her testimony
she reminded Mr Huber and his girlfriend
they needed to be home by curfew
nice sugary Gatorade for him there you
go obviously try water
wish it had been
surrounded by Carrie Anne Schwartz I
talked about ocean water
she talked about Joseph rosenbombing
Joseph Rosenbaum bombing bipolar
being prescribed Gabapentin
he had to leave her house that night
after walking four miles
I'll take him about an hour
and then walking another four miles
back to downtown where the riots were
going on where he could involve himself
fully
her story
contradicts Nathan de Bruin I just got
out when he said I just got out of jail
and I'm not afraid to go back
you've been off his meds for the week
prior
the videos
of Joseph Rosenbaum show the state that
he was in
no proof that he ever took his meds
Saul
Saul kinduri
he was the first of the kinderi brothers
to testify car Source he's in the
picture with all the people who
protected his property
he's there
and he said he just liked the military
garb
why did he get a picture then with just
one of them how do you Wrangle all these
people up everybody in that picture said
that they wanted him there they gave him
permission even Dominic black concurred
in that
State's Witness
but as I said earlier they want these
two guys to dirty Kyle up he's just
picking a spot to pick trouble and to be
there and cause problems he was asked to
provide security he did
they deny that they were going to pay
any money yet Nick Smith says they were
and gonna pay money to Nick Smith and
ladies and gentlemen
you get the feeling that they're a
little afraid of being sued as everybody
else in this case is
what
and when they were up there I don't
remember them saying Oh you can protect
car Source tour car doctor but don't go
to car three they had somebody arranged
to protect car 3 car Source three
and the word came in that they had left
Dominic Balch join Fielder all of them
say they had permission
why would they lie about that how does
that protect them they're not charged
with anything who's the people who are
lying here
sell
and Sam
next
police officer Weidner
he was the ET
he went and recovered some of the two
two three rounds from car source
I believe he found three of them the
other two were found three days later
he forwarded Grafton mask
he didn't find the bag and we do not
concede that there was nothing in that
bag not for a minute they have the
burden of proof they have the burden to
preserve a crime scene appropriately get
the evidence and show it to you bigger
is going to be able to take that apart
very easily they didn't find the fire
extinguisher we know that the fire
extinguisher was there it's in the
videos but that doesn't fit in the
state's Narrative of Kyle actually going
there to put out a fire which had been
started earlier in the Duramax
Officer Van we recovered the last two
shell casings strike that
ah
struggling with the technology
I love technology
Officer Van we
officer Moretti
he was a driver of the squad car that
Kyle tried to surrender himself to
he said it was a war zone it was a war
zone those three nights he described it
as the city on fire
the police felt as though they were
completely surrounded described the
constant gunfire that evening
Mr Binger wants to Slough it off as
fireworks this really wasn't that bad
that night ladies and gentlemen it was
hell in this area downtown there were
violent people causing trouble
and the state wants us to believe it was
okay
the police pushed him back now they
could leave car Source was safe and I
can't remember specifically what witness
it was but it stuck out in my mind
witness said the police pushed him back
let him back pushed him back let him
back and a lot of the burning happened
late at night that witness said
gauge girl squirts gross quits
it's actually kreutz very weird reasons
to change his statement his attorney is
sitting in the courtroom has been
sitting in the courtroom when he
testified if he's just your average
complaining Witness
why get a lawyer what do you got to hide
he didn't have a valid concealed carry
permit he wasn't charged he lies to the
police about being armed that night he
said he dropped his gun going down the
street
ladies and gentlemen that's what's
called obstructing
most people when you lie to the cops
especially in a murder investigation you
get in a little bit of trouble it's a
little dubious to use once having a
lawyer as evidence that they can't be
trusted I mean just legally speaking
what paid for and protected
you don't want us to search your phone
oh we're going to invoke the never heard
before Marcy's law exception to the
search warrant even though they had
assigned also did Rittenhouse have a
permit for the gun he had at the
Wisconsin thing it was also an armed
medic wants you to believe that he
didn't have one in the chamber and he
would never shoot somebody
but before he said that he said he
wallet phone gun
never leaves the home without him ladies
and gentlemen I don't carry a concealed
weapon
and I don't think I could shoot somebody
but when people carry guns that's what
they're for in the city this isn't the
Wild Wild West he had his gun Kyle
Rittenhouse had run by him he'll see the
picture was by him gone did he go to
give medical help he didn't know that Mr
Rosenbaum was being tended to no he
decided to run in and Advance on The
Fray he the member
Top member excuse me Affiliated yeah
he's sort of saying like the right
taking advantage of the right to get an
attorney is suspicious and I might have
that one word wrong but he
he who ultimately put the
tourniquet and fixed it on his arm
but Mr lakowski a member of somebody he
refers to as the militia and the Stooges
two different encounters between gauge
girl squids and my client the first one
he does not show
or give any indication of a weapon my
client does not point a weapon at him
does not shoot at him does not swipe the
weapon towards him he States he's going
to the police that is uncontradicted why
doesn't Mr grosskwitz let him be and go
give Aiden Comfort to his fellow rioter
but instead he joins the mob
chasing Kyle arms himself
and runs in
the fifth or sixth person into the melee
in scene two
scene two this is not a great closing
statement I think
his friend said
in his
Facebook post his only regret was not
emptying the clip Richards actually
seems almost disoriented what his intent
was we know what he wanted to do Kyle
shot first as he was coming in and
Mr Binger talks about oh he was going to
grab the gun ladies and gentlemen guys
this sounds like a trump rally you know
when Trump's like it's like what is
what's Trump talking about now grab a
gun with a hand
filled with a phone
right hand gun
goes back loads up and is advancing
that's when Kyle shoots him he didn't
shoot him when he put his hands up I
don't even know what if that was it sir
no intent to harm him all he does like
everybody else
back up and nobody else gets shot but Mr
girl squids decides he's gonna shoot my
client unfortunately my client shot him
first
what if he had retreated it's over
and when he's got his hand up like this
as I said earlier the hands are up it's
not gripping the gun it's loose but when
he goes in like this the pistol grip is
tight
Heather Williams this really is one of
the strangest closing arguments I've
ever seen notice if you regarding that
detective Krieger
he was in the passengers this is a woman
absolutely no dispute afraid
did not get his ID didn't ask him about
the gun just told him to go home
Kristen Harris run down live
stated
the video
we showed the video to start this
clearly depicting Mr Rosenbaum standing
there at car Source two
shortly after the dumpster standing
there with his chain the shirt tied up
over his head but Mr bigger says it's
impossible for him to have threatened my
client that's garbage just like his case
and
Mr Binger makes so much out of him one
time saying stay on your property
my client has as much right to go
anywhere
in downtown Kenosha as anyone else
as the rioters did and as he walks out
to see if anybody wants medical help
he's not doing anything wrong
he's not doing anything to provoke
anybody
detective anteramian the juxtaposition
of him and Howard as I said he is the
one who talks about what he sees in the
video totally different
as you see why did Mr Rosenbaum
go behind that car two cars over from
the zaminski's what was he doing over
there why was he doing over there and
why does he come out as soon as Kyle
yeah Binger went for a while but there
was a story there's there's no story
here and he's just chugging blue
Gatorade
this is bizarre
by the way this may work I mean you know
the jurors okay
James Armstrong
the only thing I can say about James
Armstrong is okay that's interesting but
what I'd like to say about his
photographs his knowledge of what he did
and some of the statements that the
state has made regarding it is
what he did for those 20 hours is Hocus
Pocus and he makes an exhibit that is
out of focus and that's what the state
is relying this the picture does not
make sense as I showed earlier it has
Kyle shouldering the gun in the left
shoulder
if he has it in the left shoulder
his back would be to the Drone
the Drone is moving around and that
changes the focal point he's
right-handed that's where it goes you'd
see the crosses across his chest but no
they need him to have somehow pointed a
gun at the zaminski's I don't for a
minute concede he did but we know that
Mr zaminski has been armed all evening
how this is crazy
a gun at Mr saminski provoke Joseph
Rosenbaum who according to the state
earlier in the case they didn't even
know each other
but I think they had to run away from
that because there's so many pictures of
them together
Mr Armstrong's photograph
testimony it took three days and 20
hours worth of work to come up with that
picture
went from color to black and white and
he admitted he never compared it to the
original photograph
still shot
didn't take into consideration the fact
that the Drone was moving
state is said
peer-reviewed is an independent
verification
of the events the exhibit
so
there was no testimony to this because
it didn't happen that Mr Armstrong's
co-worker did 20 hours on the same
photograph and came up with the same
result
it didn't happen when you see and I'll
show it to you later when you see in the
video
the mirror and the shininess of the
mirror that's what that is and by going
around spending 20 hours and bringing
things up it doesn't account for Kyle's
arm it doesn't account for the heat
signature of the gun none of it
Dr Kelly
wait Heat Signature was there infrared
video presented now what what is he
talking about in the Drone video The
Heat Signature does it can anybody tell
me what that's about
my favorite Witness
because physical evidence doesn't lie
the soot extremely close if not touching
the location of the soot I had him
Circle it on the exhibit
and redirect after I had him do the
demonstration the FBI video the straight
tried to get him to back up his opinion
okay back it off okay okay the FBI video
had he okay all right that's fine
it's as they say in the business An
Inconvenient Truth
they can't change it it is what it is
that's the demonstration that happened
in front of you the gun and the hand and
if the individual is coming straight at
it the barrel of the gun
it would go through the hand like this
but we know that it was coming
from right here
going
down and came out with a very clean exit
wound
no soot here at all so we know that the
gun can't be here
we know there's mod just a little bit of
soot and what's commonly referred to as
the ring finger right here and the bulk
of it goes this way because it was over
the gun touching the gun and
oh
Mr bigger says he was swiping at the gun
ladies and gentlemen he didn't need to
chase him didn't need to keep chasing
him didn't need to Lunge at him
did need to swipe at the gun I.E grabbed
the gun
shot to the back as I said
four shots
in three quarters this is really bad
he's backing up trying to stay away from
him shooting
and shoots until the threat is
immobilized ladies and gentlemen
other people in this community have shot
somebody seven times and it's been found
to be okay
and my client did it four times in three
quarters of a second to protect his life
from Mr Rosenbaum I'm sorry but that's
what happened sorry and this is the
prosecutor who said he shot him in the
back
shot him in the back on a horizontal
plane consistent with lunging shot goes
in here and ended up in his lower hip
across the back
if he's on the ground or down and shot
the bullet goes into the back and ends
up in the stomach or on the other side
dear God cleared back here ended up in
the lower hip
that's because he was on a horizontal
plane when Kyle shot him
he had stippling to the stomach from the
first
pants stopped it from lower but it was
still on the upper the furthest he was
away when the first shot was fired was
four feet and closing
four feet
I think it was Mr Krause and I who had
the fight about how far four feet is
it's not that far
it's not that far at all
brought a tape measure so I could
measure a gun barrel for you today uh-oh
and so I'll show you what four feet is
sir I object
from the edge of the jury box
to my foot right here four feet lunge
grabbing the gun
think how close that is
think how fast that distance is closed
what
was Joseph Rosenbaum doing
was he running after my client to give
him a key to the city of Kenosha
was he running after my client
to say hey thanks for providing security
common sense in your judgment look at Mr
rosenbaum's Behavior throughout the
night
as I showed you these are the pictures
exhibit 105 Dr Kelly
so right here here's entry the exit
right over here
cross clean came out right there
this right here nothing nothing
that part of the hand no sir we know
what was over the barrel remember Mr
Krause asking the doctor well what about
that big puff of smoke
that wouldn't have an effect
so it only goes
so far
that was Dr Kelly's testimony
he doesn't have a dog in the fight
he looks at the bodies
says what they are
makes the determination and looks at the
evidence
we had an expert didn't call him because
Dr Kelly told the truth
couldn't agree more
ladies and gentlemen
facts
and Truth matter
in most trials the case would have ended
with Dr Kelly
but we wanted to bring you our side of
the story
we had nothing to hide
we're going to put on a defense
what
I heard
it's a bigger say red herring
the red herrings in this case are by the
state talking about super bullets this
Metal Jacket I've been involved in
homicide cases one time it's a metal
jacket the next time the problem is the
person had hollow points hollow points
are designed to kill full metal jackets
are to go through people
ladies and gentlemen bullets are bullets
I hate to tell you at close range in
close contact they wreak havoc on a body
Havoc no dispute
wants to keep pointing at the militia
the militia the militia he knows Kyle's
not a member of the militia he has no
evidence that he is they went to the
websites they went to tick tock they
want all of that all they can do is put
up a little thing of a 17 year old kid
from his Tic Tac trying to be famous
tick tocks Kyle shot Joseph Rosenbaum to
stop a threat to his person and I'm glad
he shot him because if Joseph Rosenbaum
had got that gun I don't for a minute
believe he wouldn't have used it against
somebody else it was irrational and
crazy
crazy talked about active shooter
the power of those words
my client didn't shoot
at anyone until he was chased and
cornered
Nick Smith
got a phone call from Sam
asked on the second night of rioting to
go down there they used the power washer
and buckets to try and put out cars
he did that out of the goodness of his
heart
Sam asked him to come and protect the
next night and be paid
and he agreed to do it he asked some of
his friends to come with the help
Kyle Dominic black
talked about another father and a son
and then the people from West Bend
showed up
he said that when they first saw Sam on
the 25th
Sam gave him a hug and thanked him
for protecting his property
he was on the roof when it was chemical
bomb
he knew that Sam was grateful
for their presence but he also knew that
people on the ground needed weapons
he heard Kyle when Kyle came back
saying I had to shoot
body armor
I don't know why the Grayslake Cadet
program gives people body armor don't
know my client had it and if he wanted
to be an active shooter as Mr Binger
wants to portray him why would he give
up his body armor Nick Smith wanted body
armor he goes here Nick use mine I'm
going to be doing Medical
helping other people to see him do it
throughout he gave Nick his body armor
why would somebody give up their body
armor if they're going to go out looking
for trouble seeking confrontation
doesn't make sense
Joanne Fielder
she described Joseph Rosenbaum
wearing a red shirt with a green earring
oh this was this one had a personality
on her I'll get to later
stated Joseph Rosenbaum
yelled he was going to kill us mfers and
cut their hearts out
Jr's arm goes up
and with his second within seconds
they're tearing up from a gas bomb
she couldn't say for sure
that she saw him throw it but obviously
that's the circumstantial evidence and
her belief
she never saw Kyle acting appropriately
with anybody
point a weapon at anybody
size of the weapon might change but it
doesn't change what it can do
presence speaks volume it's a deterrent
and they've been pelted all night long
with rocks
what
she was aware that they had consent to
be where they are
Nathan de baroon
oh this guy yeah I'll say
he
was out there
taking photographs on the knights in
question more importantly the 25th he
filmed the destruction of this community
Uptown downtown
and the ATF and the FBI found out about
his videos
his still photography which I think was
incredible they wanted it and what did
he do didn't ask for money
he gave it to him
he sat down with the detective
and gave a full interview showed him the
photographs talked about Mr Rosenbaum
and all the problems he was causing that
night the things he was doing and that's
within less than a month after this
he'd never met Kyle Rittenhouse didn't
know Kyle Rittenhouse
but he had a feeling about what happened
that night
and he said if
there was trouble Mr Rosenbaum was there
I don't think any truer words have ever
been repeated did he have a lawyer
when he met with Detective Howard no he
didn't
when did he get a lawyer
remember after he met with Mr Krauss
and Mr Binger
Mr Binger the person who's made it his
personal
goal of putting my client's head on his
wall
ladies and gentlemen
that's what it did that's kind of crazy
it's like he's been cutting corn he's
the prosecutor Nathan de broon said
after meeting with Mr Binger I was very
uncomfortable he tried to put words in
my mouth
and he had to go and hire a lawyer to
protect them
first it would show him the videos and
then ask him the questions trying to put
words in his mouth he didn't want that
to happen he wanted to be able to tell
his story of what he knew what he did
he talked about zaminski the photographs
of all the conduct that zaminski had
done that night and I'll show you some
of them
photos have a time stamp on them and
he was getting a lawyer is good now I
guess in September of 2020.
about Joseph Rosenbaum yelling I just
got out of jail and I'm not afraid to go
back
those are his words
that he heard Mr Rosenbaum
it was not objected to by the state and
there has been no proof that he wasn't
in a jail they want you to believe he
was in a hospital there's no medical
records he was in a hospital there's no
medical records he was properly
medicated and I submit to you that in
this case the way he was behaving I
don't think he was properly medicated
hmm
pictures with the trailer fires the
chains starting numerous dumpster fires
I submit that he was with the zaminsky's
on many of the occasions and he was
emboldened by Mr zaminski because Mr
zaminski was always brandishing his
firearm
we saw Joseph Rosenbaum taking the
chains
he chose to come down and Riot I'm
struggling to remember is getting a
lawyer good or bad is it a sign of
Innocence or guilt why did he Chronicle
it because it's no
it's it's not very interesting if you
take a picture of a protester who's just
standing there but Mr Rosenbaum was
involved in all these different things
and I'll show you those pictures
pictures Lucas zanin Kenosha County
resident every now and again he goes
down to Texas in the winter
testified
born and raised he stated he had empathy
for the small businesses of Kenosha did
not want them looted did not want them
burned
is that somehow to be called into
question
those fires started and to come and burn
I don't think so
he authenticated
the video that was taken from his car is
accurate showing the south side of car
source 3.
and you watch that video and you see
people
destroying someone else's property
during the video
you look at the one wall there's nothing
there you see somebody spray painting on
it and they've written the word loot on
it you see another individual going in
the hood of the car
trying to do something it's not his car
he's not some roadside mechanic they're
destroying property ladies and gentlemen
Mr Binger and I will go round and round
about it until the cows come home
they were rioters
they weren't demonstrators were the
demonstrators down by the courthouse
earlier in the night yes there were
people doing legitimate demonstration
these people were riding and you see in
his tape they're hitting the cars with
pipes you hear the glass breaking you
see the people jumping on it and the
important part of it and I'll show it to
you is you hear the first bang which is
Mr zaminski's shot
two seconds later
you see
you hear the next shot and then you see
The Exodus of all the people taking off
from that
that's why Kyle couldn't
run and continue to run from Mr
Rosenbaum which he was under no legal
duty to do whatsoever how do you see
bigger space Jacob Marshall referred to
himself as a little girl squids best
friend
we brought Mr gross Chris's best friend
in as a witness because
he had posted something on Facebook
immediately after this
is he chugging
yeah he testified he couldn't find Gage
girl squirts because he was under an
anonymous name at the hospital
nobody knew who Gage groskwitz was who
Jacob Marshall because it's not his name
but he takes who's Grace Gage gross
quits never heard of him his name's
gross kreutz
talking about
how
okay the next slide please
and hospitals jail I mean it's crazy
to his only regret was not killing the
kid and hesitating to pull the gun
before emptying the entire mag out
coward here's a picture of them
bugging each other at the hospital
this is posted
ladies and gentlemen why
does somebody post something like that
because that's what his friend told him
wanted to get Gage girl squitz's word
out
he didn't
repost and say
I lied
he took it down
to try and hide it but unfortunately the
inter internet
has a memory
next witness was Kyle Rittenhouse
done with the kanderi brothers
we did recall them but I talked about
that
Kyle Rittenhouse
did not have to take the witness stand
to tell his story it was told through
video he wanted you as the jurors to
hear his personal experience of the
night of the 25th he knew Mr Binger
would cross-examine him for hours and he
was willing to get up on that witness
stand take the oath
and tell his story the best way he could
and he did could Mr Binger pick on him
and find little things about it
a little bit did he damage his
credibility I don't think so
getting to Mr yellow pants which
he's been talked about Mr Binger talks
about he says with sarcasm ladies and
gentlemen you've seen the video but
remember that when yellow pants said to
Kyle he goes you held your gun like this
that's a little ready that's not like
this
it's down he never pointed his gun at
him did he have a gun yes did he tell
him to get off a car yeah but when he
said it to Kyle Kyle said I did and
walked away not wanting confrontation
and remember Richie mcginnis's testimony
about that this is all over the visual
with the slingshot
there was the individual with two rocks
in his hand and the other individual
with the gun and when Mr McGinnis walked
up to him he immediately had to put his
hand down because they were the one
Advanced on him and he bought him off
with a white claw
my client when this happened was 17
years old
his actions are to be judged as a 17
year old not by Mr Biggers standards but
by that of a 17 year old wait hold on
and Mr McGinnis said he didn't
appreciate
the way people looked at him and maybe
he didn't and I think the best evidence
of that is
when Mr Rosenbaum begins chasing him you
hear on the tape he yells friendly
friendly friendly
three times
he thinks that if he just says the magic
words they'll stop
they don't
they could have Mr Rosenbaum could have
looked at it and said hey you're not
trying to harm anybody I'll leave you
alone is that what happened no he said
you ain't gonna do [ __ ] mother effer and
began to continue to chase him
made a fatal mistake
that day
chasing Kyle Rittenhouse into the corner
he ran as far as he could
and he shot
four times and three quarters of a
second
Mr Binger makes so much
of Kyle's residence
Antioch Illinois
I think most people here know where it
is
it's not a foreign country
Antioch Illinois right across the border
he worked in Kenosha
his dad lived in Kenosha his grandmother
lived in Kenosha he worked in Pleasant
Prairie his best friend Dominic black
lived in downtown Kenosha
they want you to believe that there's
some Sinister thing about that ladies
and gentlemen we live in a very Mobile
World I'm from the foreign country of
Racine Wisconsin 13 miles away a little
bit further I'm on the North side ladies
and gentlemen when Kenosha burned people
who like Kenosha they hurt
I remember 34 years ago walking into
this courtroom first time I ever
appeared as a lawyer
back in that conference room
and when I saw what happened in Kenosha
it bothered me
those three days
people can protest
people can't indiscriminately burn
property for no reason of innocent
people how does that further anyone's
cause
Kyle
feels for this community he worked as a
lifeguard when he came down here are we
to believe that he's working
clean up graffiti not getting paid
because he's here to look for trouble
is this all some master plan that's
ridiculous
he came down here trying to help to see
the damage and that's what he did
next
Dr John Black
his testimony about the slides
making times and I'll go over some of
those
um
specifically as I test not as I argued
earlier
the zero shot
from
I should say it this way friendly
friendly three times to the first shot
10 point
some seconds
there's a change in elevation in the
video as he's lunging forward the shot
rings out after that
the zero shot which is shot one
then two 26 hundredths the next one 24
23 for a total of 0.739
226 hundredths
comes around the car because all the
individuals had left
after hearing the shots goes to check
and to believe that he could stay there
is preposterous
all I said would have happened
scene two would have been moved to scene
one you heard the one individual yell
get the F out of here the zaminski's are
screaming he just shot him he just shot
him get him Cranium that's all happening
Mr zaminski's walking around with his
gun over his head pointing at Kyle and
I'll show you that in a little bit
in a little bit isn't this guy about an
hour and a half in already just exhibits
Dr Black showed the jury
no color was added no color was
subtracted
the videos didn't go from color
to black and white there was no
structural problems
he demonstrated his technique regarding
changing brightness and contrast right
in front of you and the one video went
from a dark mass of nothing moved the
two lines I don't know how to do it but
he did right in front of you hit it and
all of a sudden it's light and you can
see it there's no way in hell this goes
to the jury today right I mean then
there's still the rebuttal two minutes
and 55 seconds from the three times
friendly to the time he surrendered or
attempted to surrender at law
enforcement officer Brittany Bray
let me go through the
backup to the first one
total time two minutes 55 seconds
according to Dr Black
the next friendly friendly four shots
10.8 seconds
those are the shot times remember the
sound he put and synced up with the
video that was the audio graph the green
thing we shouldn't underestimate that
this might be a strategy tailored to
what the defense perceives to be the
intellect of the jury to just kind of
jump around all over the place and just
kind of I don't know it kind of seems
like self-defense I don't know
have the time to think process and do
all that you have to remember how fast
all this was happening in event number
one he's running the bag is thrown he
turns addresses keeps running and makes
a decision
a life and death decision that he has to
turn around and address the threat of Mr
Rosenbaum at that point
Kyle has stopped Mr Rosenbaum like those
other people in event number two could
have put up his hands and just backed up
made a bad decision shouldn't have done
it no he goes diving for him yells the
fu it's going for his gun
next
event two
I have it beginning when he's hitting
the head with the rock and ending with
the fourth shot taking 14 9 14.9 seconds
next
police officer Brittany Bray
measured the gun the pullback
the slide four inches brought the
ruler out because you never see in event
number two Kyle pull back to four inches
slow motion or otherwise
there were no unfired bullets found at
the scene for the AR there was the
unfired Bullet by the clip and the Glock
that had been cleared from Jason
lakowski
Drew Hernandez judge is getting annoyed
Mr Binger for some reason didn't like
Joe Hernandez you could hear it in his
questioning
ladies and gentlemen
Drew Hernandez had a point of view
there's no doubt about it but what was
that point of view
he's a citizen journalist and he's
covering the right citizen he didn't
think that the mass media was covering
the riots correctly they were just
calling everybody demonstrators and not
covering the devastation and the
destruction that was being done he had
some bias it's like Alex Jones testified
um but does that mean that his video is
lying does that mean when he says I saw
him lunge that he's lying he doesn't
have a dog in this fight actually he
does to get all of his video to the
state the Dropbox wasn't big enough
is going to trial he reaches out
gets a lawyer and provides it
simultaneously to both of us and we end
up playing it
he describes the zaminski's
Joseph Rosenbaum starting fires in the
dumpster
the yelling he sees Kyle the yelling of
the word the n-word
sees Kyle walking around yelling medical
medical right up until last time
when event number one starts
he was standing right at the corner at a
clear view
to the first incident
described him as charging from behind he
saw Joseph Rosenbaum throw the bag he
described hearing a shot from behind
Kyle which we all know is the zaminski
shot the man who's never been brought
before you people you people Joseph
Rosenbaum lunge
ladies and gentlemen you sat through
almost 10 days of testimony
you've heard the openings
most of the closings
and I have yet to hear
Dr Binger explain why Joseph Rosenbaum
had the right to Chase my client
to me
if I didn't know better I would think
he's a whiny defense lawyer
everybody's out to get me everybody's
lying I'm the one who's bringing forth
the truth ladies and gentlemen the
videos a lot of attacks on the
prosecutor the videos show the actions
of Joseph
Rosenbaum
Balch is lying fiedler's lying
lakowski's lying Richie is lying Dale De
Bruin he's really lying because he's
imputing my character
dailed Nathan de Bruin excuse me
Hernandez he's lying because he's a
right-wing journalist all six of them
are lying and then I forgot
Detective Howard he's lying too because
he could see through the videos he could
see that Rosenbaum came out from hiding
behind the car after my client passed
this is painful
rush to judgment
as I said earlier you backed
highly charged atmosphere here in
Kenosha make no mistake you live here
you know
they had to do something they had to
charge the white supremacist supremacist
Supremacy never reassessed their case
they've never looked at it they've never
said oh Dr Kelly let's talk about this
wound on the hand
why that means she was touching the
barrel or his hand was over the barrel
when it was fired well that means he was
pretty close no
we're not going to reassess we're going
to March forward we're going to throw it
into the hands
12 people from the city and let them do
our work ladies and gentlemen this is a
political case
we can take politics out of it as a
Democrat and Republican
but the District Attorney's office is
marching forward with this case because
they need somebody to be responsible
they need somebody to put and say we did
it he's the person who brought Terror to
Kenosha Kyle Rittenhouse is not that
individual the rioters
the demonstrators who turned into
rioters those are the individuals who
bring us forth
and I ask you to remember and I'll show
you the videos for the last time for me
the anger and the mob that was going on
that night
they were not going to be dissuaded from
doing things they were pushing
firing dumpsters destroying property
firing dumpsters
that was
so you're saying Mr Rittenhouse put out
a fire yes it was a small fire last time
I checked small fires turned into big
fire
kind of stupid
James Armstrong oh man
please proceed Governor I talked about
him he spent 20 hours
reworking a frame in a video and
averaging having my clients somehow
miraculously go from a right-handed
shooter to a left-handed shooter the
mirror on the truck is the arm
their whole case
relies on that one photograph that he
spent 20 hours that's how they're going
to improve provocation a word you never
heard
in the opening statement
it was my client and chased him down and
shot him in the back this just may work
this just may work
this is the day before car Source
burning car Source One pouring in the
ground
what's in the foreground
trailer
pictures later on
there's Kyle earlier in the day on the
25th setting up his Alibi setting up his
I'm a good person story because he
thinks he's going to go out and kill
three people that night ladies and
gentlemen that is garbage
how would he know he's going to be
photographed and what does that do it
just shows he's interested in this
community trying to do good
picture
Mr kandiri at car Source three
State doesn't want pilot go to car
Source three according to the state he
has to stay at car Source too 59th and
Sheridan yeah Nick Smith called and
asked him to go there because whoever
was going to protect that property had
left without an objection under the
record does not indicate that Nick Smith
made that phone call
uh it's argument uh folks you heard the
evidence and use your Collective
Recollections uh to determine what the
truth of it is and discount anything
that is not supported in the evidence
well testimony was he received a phone
call saying they were destroying cars at
car Source three and he went down there
first
Kyle asked for a fire extinguisher asked
the other individual to go down there
with him he said didn't give an answer
and Kyle took off going down there
try and help protect that property
this
is that night
tear gas
players
here
it's Mr Rosenbaum
pushing one of many dumpsters
dumpster flares
right there that's one
another one
[Applause]
bats bats guns Mr Roosevelt pushing it
in either the gas stations through it
and it is
right down here they're trying to push
I apologize they're trying to push the
dumpster down to the line of police or
to the gas station
it's put out
and the reaction
from Mr Rosenbaum
dumpster number two
did you hear the voice why you do that
I'm doing this there's Mr Rosenbaum
arguing
Mr zaminski The Smiling puppeteers
standing behind him
yeah they didn't know each other maybe
they didn't but they sure spent a lot of
time together that night
Mr zabinski with the yellow circle
holding his firearm yellow pants Kelly
zaminski with a flashlight in her hand
last time I checked there wasn't any
lighting problems the flashlight is a
weapon to bash heads if you have to
many people with AR-15s not one person
with an AR-15
that's the difference between this the
ultimate gas station
crack us and what happened down at car
Source three it was a fracas
was alone
he had been taken away from the herd and
Mr Rosenbaum and Mr zaminski were going
to get him
movement
[Applause]
Mr Rosenbaum in his bag he's not
dissuaded by the people he's going right
at him
foreign
said they were going to be very short
we're already at least an hour 38
minutes in maybe more like an hour 45
and it's Meandering it's bizarre it's
very strange
N word Mr zaminski holding his gun down
to his side
remembering this is a black lives matter
rally and he's there to support their
cause yeah right
now
[Music]
Mr Huber right there holding him back
actually physically holding him back but
right in the middle of it
look at the anger in his face
this
here I'll start it but I'm going to
point it out first
stop video earlier
this individual starting the Duramax on
fire right here jump kick now
you see him shoot in the lighter fluid
or inflammable liquid you see John thick
man being right involved
this is the calm Tuesday evening that Mr
Banger is alluding to
Mr Rosenbaum this time wearing a blue
mask tipping over the porta potty it was
just a little porta potty
the trailer
is important because it's the way he
arms himself with the chain
Frozen ball pushing it
it's just a regular demonstrator or
misunderstood a little bit upset
what does he need a chain for
what does he need a bag why didn't he
leave it with Miss swart
here
three things
blue circle
is bagged backed up by the fire
look at that bag
does that look like there's nothing in
it
look at this
what do you think that's not a water
bottle ladies and gentlemen illegal bag
take it I'm sure from right here
the tow chain
man
right there the mask white jeans black
those balloons consume the impacting my
clients face
it's crazy how the bag is a weapon
um
the boots are weapons
it everything's with the flashlight is a
weapon despite no evidence that that
flashlight was ever used as a weapon
but
the AR-15 is not indicative of someone
who is expecting trouble if the boots or
the flashlight are right I mean okay
maybe none of them are but come on guys
run down live skateboard showed this
video I started my opening statement
with it I was going to show you where Mr
Rosenbaum is I've already done it don't
need to waste it that was a tactical bag
SWAT uses the same bag
I'll see you guys
how do I get to the end okay
oh
here's the picture that we showed at the
beginning right there the 125-26 Mr
Rosenbaum mask with his chain
during the rundown live video
Mr Rosenbaum with the chain
as I said earlier is look at how Kyle's
dressed look at the pack
on his left side left hip the crosses
going across the front and the back of
his chest
nowhere in the Magic picture is that
depicted elements of medical
1140 he's crossed over that line asking
people if they want medical runs into
yellow pants he walks away from
confrontation and yellow pants said you
pointed your gun at me and he goes like
this low ready
individuals who are there with him
slingshot rocks in the hand gun
Mr McGinnis well
Kyle
after having the brief
thing with yellow pants he goes away
from them goes over looks for
Mr Balch has it been mentioned why a
Rittenhouse was wearing purple gloves a
lot of the night I mean I just just out
of curiosity
want to skip back to car Source too
those are medical gloves okay
and weights he gets the phone call he
testified about the phone call either
from Nick or Dominic
and what does he do he gets a fire
extinguisher he hasn't had a fire
extinguisher all night but he gets a
fire extinguisher the circumstantial
evidence shows the call came through he
testified the call came through
you know please let me know in the chat
do you think there will be any guilty
verdicts here any at all yes or no let
me know in the chat
excuse me
yeah
more yeses than I would have thought
and during the first part of the trial
we saw this trailer go by and it cut off
the view from this location
and I'll stop it a few times and
did you hear that talking about a pepper
ball exploding in her ass that's Kelly
zaminski speaking
pepper ball
it's blurry
Drive
here and here
that's Kyle right there to the right
of the garbage can by that splurge
of light
there's the trash can fire Mr Rosenbaum
as soon as Kyle is coming
gets up
and starts walking away with Kelly
zaminski
this individual
jumping man was there earlier
up there
that's Kyle the fire extinguisher sure
one doesn't say anything to any of them
if they see him coming they head down
their ambush
he's not chasing them he's not running
after them
he's walking down to put out the fire
over again
what was the word he used that there was
a Splurge of light
you hear Kyle your friendly friendly
friendly that is the start of Mr
Rosenbaum chasing Kyle
very weird
strong it goes to the small
in the bag
Duramax just got home
that thermax got [ __ ] beast
shine on the Duramax
foreign
video it's shown on the FBI video
standing right here
you can hear the destruction of the
vehicles
approaches
open
[Music]
Gone Gone
and he's off and running
we've seen the videos here because this
is an in video
parts of it as I said watch for the
first shot
look
at all those people
standing there a wall of people
destroying cars
the state wants Kyle to run into that
wall of people listen for the first shot
and watch the lackadaisical attitude
and then here are the four shots in
quick succession and Watch What Happens
thank you
oh [ __ ]
they shooting
oh my God think about that ladies and
gentlemen
the first shot happens they barely begin
to move
between the first shot
and Kyle's first shot which is the
second shot you hear Kyle has turned
around why is he turned around because
that wall of people was there and he has
nowhere else to run
the cars the van all of the people
destroying property the soda machine he
turns around
and Mr Rosenbaum keeps coming
Mr Rosenbaum keeps coming
he lunges gunshots
as his wife yells F and get him F and
get him he just shot somebody okay I was
I was muted I'll explain it later dear
God
what an abortive stream
pointing the gun
once again
I'm an idiot
man I'm an idiot
what I was mentioning was we had to
temporarily ban Jimmy from Philly
because he was he was cheering for the
violence and when Kyle Rittenhouse was
shooting people that's just over the
line it's just glorifying violence and
he was also attacking people in the chat
so we banned him for now and he has left
like six voicemails and he's been
emailing emailing in and it's crazy
we'll listen to it in a bit
just this is gagepov
I'm going to get the police
he's going towards the police he's
continuing on he's past age girl squids
he hasn't shot Gage girl squirts he has
appointed the fire armor cage girl
squids the medic if you think someone's
shot why isn't he there he doesn't know
Richie McGinnis is tending to him none
of the people who chase him
a rat car Source three there is no
evidence zaminski doesn't chase him
zaminski doesn't want anything to do
with it his wife doesn't want anything
to do with it but the mob has now formed
and is chasing him
down Sheridan Road in a Northerly
Direction
he turns all the way around
looking towards car Source three
could go there
at this point he hasn't armed himself
Kyle is zero threat to anyone this
active shooter BS is something that Mr
Binger is trying to sell you people has
he shot anybody since car Source 3 no he
hasn't he's running to try and get to
the police
Banger must live in fairy tale land to
think that Kyle could stop put his gun
down and say hey everything's good leave
me alone I'm going to the police
unfortunately that's not how the real
world works this was real world
hey stop it
people yelling to stop them next picture
you saw it in opening statements
DeRozan
excuse me Mr girls how long is this even
going to be allowed uninterrupted I mean
we're almost at two hours straight right
now
look how far Kyle Rittenhouse is ahead
of him an old threat he's run two blocks
almost three because it's at the far end
of 63rd he hasn't shot his gun since
if he's an active shooter looking to
take as many people as possible he's
laying waste to everybody as he was
running remember he's got 30 bullets
shot eight times
four and scene one and four coming up
he's not indiscriminately shooting
pointing doing anything
's full speed
pointing the gun at anyone no running
down the street trying to get to those
lights
where the Bearcats are and law
enforcement
he's not running off to the side to
hiding the Shadows
Blow To The Head
first knocking his hat off
what has Kyle Rittenhouse done
nothing trying to get away from the mob
First Strike from the mom
he's not an active shooter
he's gone two blocks hasn't shot anybody
coming in behind with a skateboard at
the ready
Anthony Hubert
y Huber that will be strike number one
remember an opening statements when Mr
Binger said oh something happened to his
skateboarding he took a swing at him
Kyle blocked it with his arm and he
enhanced photos what does Mr Huber do he
runs grabs the skateboard and comes in
no
first of all
he's on the ground
vulnerable position you can be in
what do we have
Anthony Huber
here already picking up his skateboard
this guy with the towel wrapped around
his head coming in at Kyle
jump kick man
guys hit him in the head
we go forward just a little bit see
foreign
this individual over here is now
constructed come in that tile Kyle
points his firearm Adam
he backs up Kyle does not shoot
jump kickman
leading with this foot this foot is
still on the ground what direction is
Kyle pointing right now
watch what happens after John kickman
kicks him in the face
turned around he's looking in that
direction
Anthony Huber coming in with the
skateboard
watch what Anthony Huber does with the
skateboard
below to the Head
coming in
Kyle's trying to get up Anthony Huber's
hand goes onto the gun is a fast one
the gun is pulled away from Kyle Anthony
Huber fires
when Anthony Huber fires
Gage girl squids
quit
covers up
Nash natural
uncontrollable reaction
back
okay
ready
[Applause]
get his ass
now here's the slow motion he's been
hitting the head the cap is off
Anthony Huber winds up
full force of his body
and back here he swings the skateboard a
tile
Kyle senses it coming he turns around
and looks blocks it with his arm doesn't
turn around and shoot Anthony Huber as
he's being attacked with what is a
deadly weapon a skateboard can cause
death or great bodily harm ladies and
gentlemen
he doesn't do it he continues to run a
couple of steps
foreign
he immediately changes Direction goes
running for the skateboard
okay now this is slow motion
and she's on the ground
set up
trying to get up the individual to
Kyle's left is the one who runs in Kyle
points the firearm he backs off
he is not shot at
huh
backs up
he's now addressing the second nearest
threat
does not shoot
that individual right there in that
picture is stopping
jump kit man launches
contact fire
turned around in comes Anthony Huber
Blow To The Head and National
now I'm going to start it
you'll see Anthony Huber pull on his gun
and you'll see the butt of the gun
separate from Kyle's body going in that
direction but wait
see the gun being pulled away from them
shot
so humor goes down gross quits
flinches freezes
stops
hands up
no pull
Mr girls quits is standing like this and
all of a sudden you see him kick his
foot back and launch forward he loads
his back foot going forward at Kyle
with a loaded glock handgun Kyle sees it
coming
gets within a couple of feet
he fires
if he's got his hands up and it wants
nothing to do with Kyle
like everybody else
back away and you don't get shot Mr
grosskwitz decides he's going to take
him out and his only regret
stayed in the Facebook post
he didn't fire first and empty his clip
into the kid
in the arm he shot at once he's backing
up
that's the last shot
I went through the quickness of the
shots from The Rock in the head to that
fourth shot
he gets up
you still see
this individual
armed
board or two by four or a fence post
doesn't shoot at him this
this hands are up doesn't shoot a hip
now as he Wheels around watch what this
individual does
the end of it
Kyle turns around
he turns that individual steps away from
him no more shots
[Music]
doesn't shoot randomly shots from behind
him continues on his way trying to turn
himself into the police
[Applause]
trying to get to the end of it
foreign
people yelling to shoot them
he doesn't stop because it's not safe
goes with his hands up to law
enforcement
[Music]
years on
hands up you hear the story about the
pepper spray
ladies and gentlemen that's the case
there was
no threatening behavior that started
this
Mr Rosenbaum
was hell-bent on causing trouble that
night
he did what he did and he started this
there are tragical tragic parts of it
Kyle rittenhouse's Behavior was
protected under the law of the state of
Wisconsin the law of self-defense
you've heard the instructions and I'll
end with this
you decide on count one
if you decide that his conduct was
privileged under the use of self-defense
you don't go on to the Lesser included
if it was privileged under self-defense
that affects count two both of the
things that happened in scene one as I
read earlier page 9 of the jury
instructions if his conduct was
privileged as to Rosenbaum it's
privilege as to Mr McGinnis
on to the next ones
at scene two
ladies and gentlemen there is no
evidence whatsoever
that he was an active shooter other than
Mr Binger calling him that
and there's no evidence that any of
those other individuals
who attacked him in the mob
that night
were attacking an active shooter he
wasn't shooting
and if they want to be
the heroes and they wanna
beat somebody and do what they're going
to do to them
they better be right
and they weren't
Kyle Rittenhouse shot Mr Rosenbaum
because he was attacking Kyle
every person who was shot
was attacking Kyle one with a skateboard
one with his hands one with his feet
one with a gun
hands and feet can cause great bodily
harm
show the state's going to get up and say
well he didn't have great bodily harm so
it doesn't matter that's not the
standard the standard is could cause a
great bodily harm my client does not
have to take a beating
from the hands of this mob or the hands
of Mr Rosenbaum and
the Rosenbaum
might be little but he was a pretty
muscular guy some 30-some year old guy
can take a 17 year old kid nine times
till Tuesday ladies and gentlemen
it's a tough choice but the evidence
only leads to one conclusion that is
that Kyle Rittenhouse conduct on August
25th was privileged based upon the
actions of Mr Rosenbaum and others there
are no winners in this case but putting
Kyle Rittenhouse down for something he
was privileged to do
will serve no legitimate purpose I ask
you to do this do justice here under the
law of the state of Wisconsin thank you
very much
thank you Mr Richards uh let's take
about 10 minutes and please don't talk
about the case uh we'd watch your list
on any account
[Music]
wow
by the way how are the calzones
wow
I can't help but thank so many people
who have grabbed memberships look at
this folks signing up on my website
during the closing arguments Nora
Schmucker
Adriana Daniel
Carl Beverly
Kristen jagi Richard Rankin Julianne
villiere David Lindsay Megan Bolanos
Stephen Rowe Ben Ivory Rodrigo
Valenzuela usual misra and Patty de Bond
13 new members pushing us to 66.
an incredible moment
an incredible moment they're going to
come back with the rebuttal I have a
live I have a second live stream I have
to go on at the top of the hour so this
will continue I will also be streaming
on Instagram it's going to be insane
it's going to be insane I invite you to
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code uncharged pickles for a discount
uncharged piccolos now
we had something happen during today's
stream
um Jimmy from Philly had to be banned
from our chat on YouTube
because not only was he attacking people
attacking attacking attacking
when video was played of Kyle
Rittenhouse killing individuals he
started typing yes
that's over the line so Jimmy from
Philly has for now been banned
he started calling in while all this was
going on let's listen
I mean
on the trial on my stream why am I being
I can't shoot the chat I can't see my
chats why am I banned I just told you
and and don't tell me that you don't
know what that is what even advantage
all right then he called back again
take some silly
it's kind of pull
which which argument is fair the
prosecution's argument's over the
defense just started
why won't you do that poll at the end of
the defense then he called back again
David give me some silly
just very low tier trash commentary
every comment that famous makes
it's nothing
all right and then he called back again
silly what
so apparently you know nothing about God
David I heard you asked if Kyle had a
permit he didn't need a permit but that
guy pointing his gun at him he needed to
firm it
your commissary is trash all right then
he called back again David [ __ ] your
cappuccino then he called back again
Davis Jimmy from Philly what
why are you asking if Kyle had a permit
then he called back again David
from Philly White
what is this oh it's a medical key plan
you think that's that's funny me and my
chat think it's the lamest thing they've
ever heard and lastly calling again
David Jimmy from Philly what
do you want to you want to see a furious
trumpist take my call after the stream
yeah I don't know if
I don't know if we're going to uh
live calls today
but it's definitely something to look
into I'll probably unban Jimmy tomorrow
and we'll give him another attempt in
the sandbox to see if he can play nicely
um or not
okay everybody so we are standing by for
the rebuttal I also am going to be live
on Instagram I think at the top of the
hour assuming it all goes down let me
just see here let me know when you're
ready and I will start so I'm going to
be streaming in two places at once it's
just the way the timing worked out
um we've had 161 000 different people
watch pieces slices of today's stream
161
000 people and because a lot of the
people watching now were not watching
earlier just a few comedic elements that
I did want to go over with you guys here
is an Obama element that was created
foreign
[Music]
okay so that was one
here is a new Obama song from the great
Jethro Bradley
this is serious
[Music]
God bless
God bless
Obama
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so there is that and then lastly let's
okay we're still good here
[Music]
where's that coming from
okay and lastly this is lilu featuring
diamond and silk with Deepak it's called
bag of mangoes mangoes I bet the mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
right
[Music]
my mangoes back down
[Music]
bring my mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
if highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
goes there it is so an incredible Anthem
presented to us there it is really
something else so very much appreciate
those new submissions from people in the
audience extremely extremely uh powerful
from the standpoint of Music we are in a
what is supposed to be a very brief
break
there's going to be a prosecution
rebuttal here momentarily
and I think it's going to be wild I
think it's going to be extraordinary
um
okay oh big thank you to Robbie
largentin and Joseph Hurley who just
grabbed memberships on my website
numbers 66 and 67 no 67 and 68 I
apologize
um I invite you to sign up it has been
amazing streaming all 11 days of the
trial so far we're going to be here for
the verdict etc etc we are banned on
Twitch and lost a thousand paid
subscribers there that's why it says
twitch Sub Zero above my head so instead
I'm inviting you to sign up here on my
website at joinpakman.com uh an
absolutely perfect place to sign up and
today's coupon code and through the end
of the trial is uncharged pickles
uncharged piccolos exactly
so come on over you can also Pledge on
patreon and those count double uh
patreon.com
David packman is what it is Jimmy from
Philly is continuing to call in I'm kind
of over it I'll play one one more and
then that's gonna be it
David Jimmy from Philly wow
twitch being me
okay that we're done with Jimmy
uh clearly I think having some kind of a
uh mental health event over there so uh
that's it for Jimmy from Jimmy for today
Seymour Richard has just grabbed a
membership on my website and his new
member number 69.
a very powerful membership there
Jimmy is 12 sheets to the wind as they
say
Landon echeverio says after your
cappuccino
the jury has most oh Graham Graham is
our attorney commentator Graham is a
defense attorney and says the jury has
likely mostly made up its mind closings
aren't nearly as important as us
attorneys like to think no way to know
what they are thinking indeed indeed
this is a good question does the judge
still have the mistrial option yeah this
was addressed this morning where the
judge said he would formally give his
opinion on it which I can only imagine
means he is not going to Grant a
mistrial if he planned to I can't
imagine he would have all you know that
they would be doing all of this that's
my instinct that's my instinct
um
but that's where we are at this point in
time other super chats
um let's see or other voicemails rather
yeah Whitney did call in again
but um continuing talking about
um gun culture and stuff like that like
why somebody would feel like the need to
get a gun because they would see
somebody else like you know in the media
who has a gun who's just like them or
really similar to them who feels the
need to have a gun yeah man Whitney's on
fire today Whitney's on fire
uh hey how you guys doing make sure to
use the code let's go Brandon for 50 off
David Pacman's soy lattes thank you
everyone
yeah
oh that's the guy I banned oh okay okay
okay
yeah that's really cringy why like when
I see let's go Brandon in the comments
when I like tweet or post to Instagram I
kind of cringe a little bit like oh
someone thinks they're being clever and
it's so stupid
hearing the voice of someone doing let's
go Brandon
it's even cringier than I imagined and I
imagined it was pretty damn cringy it's
actually pretty pretty surprising
um
let's see what else we've got here
other voicemails
hi David this is Josh from Washington
State I just wanted to point out that
the
I look at the Kyle Rittenhouse case on
it from a objective perspective where
think about if it was a car accident
without car insurance just mold that one
over for a bit and what I think that one
over
I I don't understand the relevance quite
frankly I apologize I don't understand
the relevance
so I'm just curious where your thoughts
were on the polar vortex and how it's
making it cold this year
um wander thoughts on the uh winter
solstice and what you'll be doing for
the winter solstice this year also on
your thoughts on cereal
um I know you said you haven't eaten
cereal for breakfast in about 10 years
but
have you eaten cereal and are you are
you
um looking forward to the new year
um I want to be the first one to wish
you a happy birthday dude so happy
birthday oh my God that's almost none of
those things are relevant so I have no
thoughts about the polar vortex
I'm gonna be in Los Angeles
um on the solstice
um
I I have had cereal as a snack I haven't
had cereal for breakfast for a really
long time but I've had cereal as a snack
with milk
typically whole milk
I am
I guess looking not really looking
forward to the new year and my birthday
is months and months away so I just
don't
just don't even really know how to deal
with that
uh okay I want to say thank you to some
really great people Addison Gardner just
signed up at joinpakman.com
a Bernie art just signed up at
joinpakman.com and Belinda Kepner just
signed up at joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that a numbers 70.
71
and 72
oh and I don't want to forget oh let's
just make sure I get the name right here
one other person just signed up
man memberships are just dumping in
massively here
uh okay I'll get back to that because
I'm not exactly sure how this person
wants their name red what am I having
for dinner tonight I'm actually having a
lasagna tonight
um I know that it's no calzone by the
way how are the calzones yeah making a
beautiful lasagna uh uh what I have done
is
um taken a cheese lasagna recipe and I
have unilaterally decided we're adding
eggplant and we're adding spinach and
it's fantastic
this is the prosecution's rebuttal folks
oh thanks to Brandon deck who just
signed up at joinpakman.com Brandon is
number 73. uh whoa excuse me
um also momentarily in in seven minutes
I have a separate scheduled stream on my
Instagram so I'm gonna black out here
and I'll be on my it's a CR it's just a
crazy day and we can't keep putting this
off so I'm gonna do this other stream
with Casey Simpson on my Instagram it's
going to be great so you'll have two
things judge taking a phone call here as
we stand by for the start of the trial
uh judge very very strongly there
and making a number of different phone
calls warm food around noon but we have
Subway tomorrow Pizza is a
yes take a break lunches
what is here by the way how are the
calzones all right enjoy your lunch all
right how was the KFC very good whatever
you do make sure you go to the bathroom
yeah somewhere other than the courtroom
yeah man it's just it's really wild
what's going on with this uh with this
judge
uh
uh the jury's coming back in
judge now looking very perplexed by what
he sees on his phone
looking very confused actually
thank you judge
here we go
simply cannot be reasonable
for someone to be holding an AR-15
semi-automatic rifle I'll be right back
with powerful ammunition
and be chased by someone who is unarmed
who's smaller than him who's shorter
than him
and the first thing that you do to
defend yourself
is you plug four rounds into it
you shoot it from about four feet away
and not from four feet from Mr
Rittenhouse four feet from the end of
that gun
your first shot immobilizes him
it shatters his hip
then
he's caused to go forward and if you
watch the videos and we're gonna watch a
couple during this brief rebuttal
he crumples
he immediately crumples to the ground
no one is saying that Mr Rosenbaum
should have chased Mr Rittenhouse no one
is saying that Mr Rittenhouse did not
have a right to defend himself this case
is about the right to use deadly force
and I want to talk about that standard
because attorney Richard's
perhaps on accident misstated it
he said that the standard is that it
could cause death the great bodily harm
to Mr Rittenhouse or that it is likely
to cause death or great bodily harm to
Mr Rittenhouse that is absolutely not
what the standard is and that is not
what this trial is about
the standard is the defendant May
intentionally use Force which is
intended or likely to cause death or
great bodily harm such as fire and AR-15
only if the defendant reasonably
believed that the force used was Ness
was necessary to prevent imminent death
or great bodily harm to himself
not oh if you repeatedly smash someone's
face it might lead to injury not oh this
could have happened
imminent
death or great bodily harm
there's an old phrase that I could kill
you with my bare hands
and there is literally no evidence that
Mr Rosenbaum was capable of that
Mr Rittenhouse has size on him we heard
how he's a swimmer we heard how he's a
lifeguard he's apparently in some kind
of shape
punch him in the face kick him in the
testicles
knee him in the face hit him with your
gun
you don't just immediately get to shoot
someone and I don't care about
provocation or any of that put that
aside
it is not reasonable for any adult
for any person for any 17 year old male
to not try and defend yourself first
using other methods
now you factor in provocation the fact
he had no right to retreat or no no
ability to or he had to retreat and that
he had to exhaust all methods
clearly if there is provocation
he's guilty but even outside of
provocation
why do you get to immediately just start
shooting
as Mr Binger said he brought a gun
to a fistfight
and he was too cowardly to use his own
fist to fight his way out he has to
start shooting and let's just say
theoretically
that we think that the 12 of you think
that it is reasonable to have used
Force
deadly force in that situation
it's once takes out his hip
what does Mr writtenhouse have to do to
avoid that
well maybe take one step back
and Mr Rosenbaum is no threat
and Mr Rittenhouse is responsible for
every round of that gun it did not have
to happen as fast as Mr Rittenhouse made
it happen
he could have held back at one shot he
could hold back at two shots
the guy in the blue hoodie who came in
to attempt to kick him didn't get four
shots Mr Rosenbaum didn't get four shots
and Mr gross kreutz did not get four
shots
the defendant has the ability to gauge
what he is doing and to stop shooting
Mr Richards talks about the threat being
immobilized what threat does someone six
inches shorter than you that you've
already shot in the hip and is already
falling to the ground half
why do you have to keep tracking them
and shooting them in any of where the
kill shot in the back
hit him kick him knee them
anything else
and Mr Rosenbaum and Mr Rittenhouse are
alive
because the defense talks about games
that the prosecution is played let's
talk about games let's talk about how Mr
Rittenhouse on that night did not tell
Dominic black did not tell Joanne
Fiedler did not tell anyone
about this grabbing of the gun
didn't tell anyone about oh I was afraid
they were you used the gun against me
that is because
once Mr Rittenhouse
and his team understood that
an unarmed person chasing him in unarmed
people chasing him later on would not be
enough to meet this standard
to meet this privilege they had to
concoct a story
they had to concoct a story about how uh
suddenly I was in great fear of this gun
being used
and if that's the real reason why didn't
Jason lekowski know that
why didn't Dominic black know that why
didn't John Fiedler know that
you darn well know if there was any
evidence of the defendant saying that
the night of we would have heard about
it
so yes
Mr Rosenbaum is
four feet or so from the barrel of the
gun
he gets shot in the hip
he begins to crumple
now remember
we did this demonstration when the
doctor with Dr Kelly testified
this bullet
entered here in the middle finger and
came out here
this is how you grab something
I'm Mr Rosenbaum trying to take this gun
away
and this is how I'm going to do it with
my hand turned uh almost completely
around and with apparently my fingers
spread because these two don't get sick
which may mean they are on the gun or
outside of the path and the other ones
do get stuck
we're not talking about injuries to the
Palm here we're not talking about
injuries like this or any kind of
grabbing injuries we're talking about
either something accidental or
completely defensive to knock that gun
away as he is being shot
just before he is killed on the third or
fourth shot
well we're supposed to believe that
Mr Rosenbaum is Jason Bourne or John
Wick or some other movie star hero who's
capable of killing with his bare hands
and deserved the treatment
that he got from the defendant
Richards
closing
was quite personal
if not taking shots personally Mr Binger
it was gloating and boasting about his
clients kills
and he talked a lot about the zaminski's
he knows darn well that the zaminskis
are charged by my office and they have a
Fifth Amendment right this is a criminal
defense attorney
stop stop
let me ask you to step out for a moment
would you
what's your objection
all right her case has been disposed of
and she did not appeal
or was charged any arson which the
defense could get into and she would
have a Fifth Amendment right
wait a minute well as I recognize that I
think I have the case as I handled the
Jason
uh
Joshua
Joshua zaminski
that's pending right Mr zaminski's Case
is pending and it has been repeatedly
adjourned
to follow this case
um
at the state's request
um I handled the case of Mrs zaminski
and she came out on a reduced charge it
was a recommendation I think for a seven
day sentence
she was a she was being revoked and sent
to prison I know the pictures of that
case but if
if attorney Richards she wouldn't have a
right of
I think I
I sentence started seven months in
prison consecutively to her sentence
uh and I don't think why would she have
a testimonial privilege any longer
if there are charges outside of what she
was charged with
she was in charge with any arsons
charger
don't know
probably not
all of the charges out of the event were
wrapped up they can't piecemeal the
charges and to argue that she has a
Fifth Amendment right now is ridiculous
I did say Mr Smith get a Fifth Amendment
right and then the objection came I did
not say Mrs zaminsky
I can clarify that Mr zaminsky from the
report of what was said I thought it was
just Mr
um
I think he said that saminski's are
charged by my the office and they have a
Fifth Amendment right did you see the
zaminski's
both all right well then I I'll clarify
um I'll sustain the objection I
understand
um
all right
um
all right
um ask the jurors to come back in please
all right I've sustained the objection
because the statement which was made by
Mr Cross was not accurate at least as
regards Mrs zaminski
any question
go ahead Mr Krause
Ms zaminski was charged and convicted by
my office Mr zaminski still has pending
charges
attorney Richards knows that he has a
Fifth Amendment right to not testify
[Music]
yeah
um
let me ask you to step in the library
again please
foreign
one it's not an Evidence
he wants to say he has a fifth remember
right they also Grant him immunity
they're the only people who can and if
they're going to say that I should have
a cereal bottle to explain it to those
12 people they hold the keys
Mr zaminski testifying or not testifying
just heard two hours of how terrible
Joshua siminski was and the defense
wants us to offer him immunity that's
completely our decision Mr Krause please
he still has a Fifth Amendment right
what I'm saying is that but you know the
questioning the question the question
you're asking the zabinski case has been
here on number of occasions
and it has been either it's been a
mutual request to it during the case was
his lawyer Mr Barth okay it's been
repeatedly requested that it be
adjourned and I assumed Bart was told
I'm not sure which it would be adjourned
pending the outcome of this case
no that's not true no well it's not true
it is it is true that I assumed it uh
whether I was told that or not I don't
know it's not the same as Dominic
background there's it's a different
situation Minsky's case will go to trial
on January 31st well that's the question
but why was it being adjourned I think
there were some uh we had a witness who
was not available at the last trial date
so we needed more time to get them in
okay
um
Mr Richards also brings up a point that
you have control over the availability
of a witness in terms of Grant of
immunity but I don't want to get into
that because I think on the first point
he made which is that I don't think it's
an Evidence
what did you ask Mr debrone I uh asked
Mr de Bruin
that when we were talking about our
meeting that he was going to be witness
against Mr zaminsky and that Mr Binger
talked to him mostly about Mr zaminski
because there's a pending case against
Mr zininsky
say again
after Mr de Bruin
talked about our meeting
on cross-examination I asked Mr de Bruin
I believe this was a while ago
I indicated that he was going to be a
witness in the zaminski case
and that Mr Binger asked him mostly
about zaminski and why would Mr Binger
ask questions about Mr zaminski in an
effort to change his statement in The
Written House case
and he had no answer for that
the member right that the district
attorney is making or the defense
it's that there's an open pending case
against him there was because
on January 31st that came in through Mr
de bruyne and I actually mentioned it in
my closing
because it's in evidence that there's a
pending case I'm Prosecuting Mr zaminsky
and the trials coming up in January that
is in evidence John
what I'm objecting to and bringing that
into this
um I I don't know I I
you're making it sound as if well you're
making a sound incorrectly so that Mr
zaminski is unavailable
um
because of his testimonial privilege
but uh now Mr
um Richards is asking whether he should
be allowed a silver medal
to so the jury would understand
that that is somewhat under the control
of the district attorney
but
I'm not gonna at this point I'm not
going to get further into that I'm just
going to ask you to move on to something
else well my next line of argument is
that the defense name them in their
witness list and could have called the
zaminsky's
can't because he's got a fifth amendment
privilege for the very beginning and
privileges must be claimed as much as
possible outside the presence of the
jury that's the statute they could have
called kelly zaminski they admitted her
here from prison
uh
pardon me we had to ever available in
case something came up that doesn't mean
we have to call her we have no
obligation to put anybody on the witness
stand nor does the state and Mr
Richards commented many times about how
we could have called them which I think
was dishonest given the Fifth Amendment
issue but then also I can call I can
mention that when he set up and read his
witness lists the zaminskis were on it
and they have the ability to call them
as well
not in evidence
these are opening statements any comment
from those multiple times
I don't I
um
what was you what was the last statement
you made now that Drew the objection
that Mr zaminski as an open case under
Fifth Amendment right
yeah
that is an accurate statement
that I should be able to fill in the
holes because they're the ones who can
give them immunity I can't call them
well I know that
why'd you say you know
you know you know you know
no no no you address your remarks to me
both of you to me not not not not not to
each other please it's called being
prepared I don't know what's going to
happen at a trial okay
well I think I'm just going to tell the
jury that Mrs zaminski was
would have been available for call to be
called by either party
okay
fine fine oh man that got out of it
alive okay
um ask them to come in please
all right folks uh what the situation is
that Mrs zaminski
would have been available
to either party to call as a witness and
neither of them has neither of them has
done so
okay any question go ahead Mr Krause
thank you
Mr Richards also mentioned that
attorney Binger talked about all these
people are liars and he was being acting
like a whiny defense attorney
I don't know why that language had to be
used but
Mr bringer never said any such thing he
never called anyone a liar except for
perhaps Mr Rittenhouse
and Mr Richards talks about how well in
the state's opening you heard nothing
about provocation
to Richard's nose that is a specific
thing that instruction we get from the
judge at the end of the trial
had we mentioned at the beginning he
would have objected
he would have objected
now let's talk about this threat
this supposed threat
Mr Richards
talked about that gas station and showed
the video and it showed Mr Rosenbaum at
the end
attorney Binger had said he's not in
this video as it started and you don't
hear anything from him
and that is true
at the very end he is seen standing
quite a bit away from Mr Balch and Mr
Rittenhouse
this is where that supposed threat
happened
there's a distance between them
next time the camera pans back the
protesters are pushed back
and you never hear this threat you hear
nothing
and Mr and apparently that is what the
defense is accepting is where the threat
happened although Mr Rittenhouse
actually does not accept that because he
said it happened a block or two North
so they can't agree on when the threat
took place
they can't agree on where the threat
took place
and it's the only few seconds of that
part of the night that is not on tape
anywhere
it's another concoction to give Credence
or to give weight that oh he had to
defend himself against the unarmed man
there's been talk about how the
defendant came around that Duramax and
raised his gun
that didn't seem to be a a contestant
issue in the case until the defendant
lied about it on the stand
the defense themselves submitted an
exhibit number 41. in which it is it is
denoted where the uh person that put
that video together indicates
writtenhouse pointing gun at zaminski's
I think it has a question mark
this was their exhibit
there was testimony from Detective
antaranian
and we showed this drone video
now
but then the defendant won't admit to it
on the stand and then all of a sudden
the defense has to fight it and talk
about Hocus Pocus
and make up little clever rhymes
the defendant could have told you the
truth
but that hurts his case and that gives
us provocation
now
I did in I did have on rebuttal Mr
Armstrong put in two very blurry
pictures
Mr Binger didn't even mention these
pictures in his closing because they're
maybe the fifth sixth or seventh
strongest pieces of evidence that Mr
Rittenhouse raised his gun
but the defense is seizing on them and
they inaccurately said that it took him
20 hours of work to do
he worked on that drone video for 20
hours
he made us multiple uh shorter videos of
it
these images were the last part of that
work
and that image does show Mr Rittenhouse
holding a gun it is blurry does it show
every detail no
but we thought it important that there
at least be some still shot besides
these videos
the second one I showed again is very
blurry but it's of the shooting
and you see Mr Rittenhouse blurry you
see the puff of smoke and you see Mr
Rosenbaum blurry still very much upright
and that is why those pictures are given
it was the tail end of all the work that
Mr Armstrong did on this video
the defense seems very scared of these
of these pictures because it helps to
prove their client light on the stand
and it shows that he provoked the attack
now I would like to show you
I believe this is the full drone video
exhibit 73
foreign
so in this one it is difficult to see
the raising of the gun because it's the
full video
I would encourage you if you find it
necessary to take a closer look at the
bigger TV please stop it
now if you've seen this video Mr
Richards wants to make it seem like the
only recourse the defendant has in
retreating is walking into this mod this
mob of people who are breaking cars
but look at all that open space
that he has at this moment he could have
turned around and ran to that space and
got right back of Sheridan and everyone
be alive and everyone would be fine
instead he decides to start slowing down
and run into these cars in which he has
supposedly tripped which would be like
being trapped in a Target parking lot
as you see as we keep playing it he goes
around them no problem and he goes right
into this totally clear space that was
available to him the whole time
he did not exhaust his duty to retreat
he did not exhaust all of his options
now I'm going to go to the video I'm
going to point something out Mr Binger
is going to play it again and I'll show
you
this is in relation to Mr Richards
indicated that no one that attacked
or that went after Mr Rittenhouse the
second incident observed the shooting
that is not true this video shows the
person that is referred to as jump
kickman leaving the scene and we have
another view as well from another video
but I'll point that out
you know
you see this man in a wheelchair
struggling
to get out of the way this is
right here he sees it
'll be standing there the whole time and
he comes and he helps push the end of
the wheelchair out of the seat
so he absolutely was there
he did see what happened
this is exhibit 10 this is the Ford
Fisher video if you look after the
shooting
it shows
this individual
pushing the wheelchair away from car
Source three
there he is across the street
pushing the man in the wheelchair away
out of the scene
[Music]
foreign
this is a video you've seen before it
does look better on the large television
but this is where he comes into the
screen
this is one of the videos that Mr
Armstrong cropped for us in his 20 hours
of work uh this is slowed down down by
50 percent
comes in as good as good as possible
good limitations of the video I'll point
it out up here but I said it is better
seen on the large TV
close enough already have the adapter he
puts on the fire extinguisher and he
raises up
now to do the next student
oh we got it
all right
again that really wasn't an issue with
trial until the defendant lied about it
now exhibit 84 this is a another video
that Mr Armstrong did his 20 hours of
work
and this shows the
or the chase that you see in point
Mr Rosenbach does his jump
see the defendant's slowing down
seemingly preparing to shoot
and look where that first shot is
go back one more play One More Time
this is the zoomed in image that will
eventually was shown look how far
he's not reaching he's being shot in the
hip and falling and he goes immediately
to the ground and the defendant sees fit
just keep shooting at him although he
opposes absolutely no threat
again four feet from the barrel of the
God not for Mr Rittenhouse himself
here is another video Mr Armstrong made
in his 20 hours of work
I believe he made six of them all told
they're all on evidence here's a
close-up of the final shooting
a puff of smoke is already out he's
already upright he crumbles immediately
to the ground but the defendant keeps
shooting him
so did Mr Rosenbaum turn and get shot in
the back that way
no he was even less of a threat he was
falling face first on the ground with
his hips shattered
so yes he was shot in the back and he
was killed by a shot in the back and it
was the third or fourth shot
Attorney Richard has indicated that Nick
Smith called the defendant Nick Smith
did not testify to that he was never
asked we don't know who or what who
called the defendant to go to that scene
and despite the fact that there's this
madman out there who's such a threat and
is going to kill the defendant
he just saunters down there all by
himself no problem
he's not scared
this threat if it even existed was not
taken seriously
he's a babbling idiot as Mr lakowski
said
Mr Rittenhouse testified he didn't hear
the the anything before he shot he
didn't hear this [ __ ] you he didn't
factor in the gunshot
there is no evidence that Mr Huber did
anything on towards that evening uh they
talked about pushing a dumpster picking
up pepper balls that was not evidence
that was ever submitted in this trial I
don't know where it comes from
no evidence that he told Gage gross
quits I had to shoot in self-defense
and attorney Richards talks about how
well Mr Detective Howard testified in a
certain way
and how he didn't talk about the Drone
footage or anything he knows we got the
Drone footage
surprisingly after Detective Howard
testified
guns do not have handed there's not a
left-handed or right-handed gun
so yes the demonstration that Mr Banger
did is how it happened
the defendant was facing that way he
picked it up
and
the videos show it
reviewed it and saw it and testified to
it
and it wasn't an issue until the
defendant lied
videos don't lie but we know Kyle
Rittenhouse does
he lied all that night
a lot has been made about how Gage gross
Christ had an attorney
how hypocritical from a lawyer to hear
someone criticize someone else hiring
counsel
Mr Rittenhouse isn't here alone
he has lawyers
and
I apologize that the District Attorney's
Office followed our interpretation of
Marcy's law
which is a fairly recent especially at
that time
Constitutional Amendment
Gage grosgrades is not on trial
he followed the advisor Council not turn
over his phone just as anyone who hires
Council can do they can follow the
advice of their Council
we got his whole video from that night
the defense has seen it we have it what
else do we need
text messages from three weeks before
they just want to try to dig up dirt
because they think it's there because
the defense wants you to believe that
these people got what was coming to them
that they were bad people doing bad
things
and we should be proud and boastful of
Mr Rittenhouse for killing them
Gage gross Christ testified when he
heard that he heard I didn't shoot
anyone
and Gage grosskreitz acted on that he
Then followed it went he left Mr
Rittenhouse thinking that he was not
involved in the shooting and started
going to the shooting of Mr Rosenbaum
before being told by others
that saw it that he was the shooter and
then he returned
so Gage growth Sprites relied on this
statement of Mr Rittenhouse
we're talking let's talk about a rush to
judgment
Mr Rittenhouse turned himself in
are you supposed to be days weeks months
to charge murderers who we know murdered
people
it's a red herring as Mr Binger said
it's throwing up red herrings false
hypocritical arguments and attacks on
those that Mr
ridden house killed to try and distract
you from the fact that he was not an
imminent fear of deathly bodily harm and
he was not privileged to act how he did
we heard from Miss Carrie Anne swart
now that Nathan de Bruin talked about
jail now we can try to smear rooster
Rosenbaum more although there really is
no dispute or was no dispute that he
came from a hospital he's carrying a
hospital bag Ms sword testified that she
talked to the hospital about how he
would be released that he went to this
hospital she knew he was coming home
from the hospital she knew it was in the
bag and he showed that picture of it
backlit against the fire trying to make
it seem sinister
she talked about her medical papers in
there and we did that image again Mr
Armstrong did this image for us where
you can get a little peek in the bag and
I would argue you can see medical papers
though that big image that big image
they see looks like rolled up medical
records that you get when you're
discharged from a hospital
and Mrs Ward testified that he was given
medications that day
perhaps they didn't work perhaps there
was a bad reaction I don't know I'm not
a doctor but he was given that day he
could not get the ones for future Days
uh because things were closed
uh Balch did not testify that he thought
there's anything Sinister in the bag
um he made he said he
said something inaccurate at the time
but he said that he saw shampoo bottles
in a water bottle
Mr de Bruin
he did take some nice photographs and he
clearly wanted the world to know that he
took some nice photographs
he's really more relevant to Mr zaminski
and he apparently this is the photo of
the bay you can examine that further
Mr de Bruin must have some problem with
police and DA's offices
he goes to the detectives he doesn't
give a full story he says he testified
to this this is not me saying anything
he forgot things because he was so
nervous because the the door to the
police station still had an unrepaired
window that caused him such nervousness
that he could not give a full statement
he meets with us in a very
polite short meeting he has very little
relevance to this case that we knew
about
and yes we showed him some videos is
this Josh deminski oh no it's not okay
would you see him in these other
pictures yes you don't know it's Josh
siminsky okay
somehow that's us getting him to change
his statement
what's that
we show him pictures videos
say is that Josh schminsky I don't know
we show him other pictures do you
recognize that as the same person
yes that's not going to change his
statement we had him read a statement do
you have anything to add to it no
the next day he goes over to Mr
Richard's office all of a sudden he
knows all this extra information that
wasn't in his statement oh but he was so
nervous meeting with us because we
showed him a video or photograph that he
took of Joshua zaminski
and then what does he do
he goes and hires a lawyer
very closely connected with a gossip
blogger who attacks my office on a
regular basis and it was very
pro-written house
another just funny coincidence in this
case just like how Mr Hernandez who
doesn't live in this state could hire
any of the thousands of attorneys in
Wisconsin or tens of thousands of
attorneys in the state but no he hires
an attorney who Kyle rittenhouse's
defense team has already paid money to
that firm
what a coincidence
so Mr de Bruin doesn't tell us any
information then tries to attack us and
then gives tells the defense a lot more
information
Mr Rittenhouse denied pointing a gun at
the yellow pants man
said he was being sarcastic
well Mr Richards basically just admitted
he did point the gun
so which is it
we know that Mr Rittenhouse was going
around that night
trying to be a paramedic a policeman and
a fireman without receiving any real
training in any of them
tough job to do all three at once
and he went around with his gun trying
to scare people to intimidate them to
not do minor property damage
he's a chaos tourist
he was there to see what was going on
Act important be a big deal
and then the moment a little bit of that
chaos comes chaos comes back at him
cowardly shoots a man instead of
fighting back
you put yourself in this situation you
know it's going to be out of hand it
gets a little out of hand someone is
chasing me
and you have to shoot them
that is not privileged that is not
reasonable and that is not what any
reasonable person in the defendant's
shoes would have done
we kept hearing about this rock in this
hand there's no evidence of there being
a rock in that hand
now there's talk about how
the defendant maybe have re-racked his
gun
we don't see that in the video we don't
know what he did
but we do know that as Gage gross crates
is sitting there with his hands up the
defendant turns over his gun and is
looking at and is doing something with
it
fully reason the friend admitted to this
that he looked at the gun fully
reasonable that Mr grossquates could
have assumed that he was re-racking and
preparing to fire
and it does not mean that a unspent
shell casing has to be on the ground
officer Bray testified that she shot
AR-15s she knows AR-15s
there's an UNS if if it jams and there's
an unspelled shell casing the re-racking
will take out the unspent shell casing
it does not have to be a live ROM
I don't know what he was doing with his
gun but it's certainly reasonable for Mr
gross crates to interpret it that way
and then what does he do he doesn't step
back and take a firing position and
shoot he didn't shoot him
five to six seconds earlier
when he was when Mr Rittenhouse was
being an active shooter
after having killed his second person
and shot at his third
he would have heard of every right to
have to have stopped Mr rittenhouse's
activities at that point
but he didn't he came up closer he
surrendered and he said or you know he
believed his surrender was not being
accepted
who shoots someone like this
is he trying to shoot his own hand off
he never does anything about an actual
position to shoot that gun and as Mr
Richards admitted his closing when it's
pointed at his head his his arm is
already blown off
we're supposed to be so scared of Mr
grosscrates with his Glock when the
defendant is holding a loaded AR-15
then there's this Preposterous argument
that oh Kelly zaminski is holding a
flashlight it must be to bash heads
certainly no one carries flashlights at
night to walk home in the dark or walk
to your car in the dark
I take when I take my dog for a walk
I'm looking to Bastion heads
no
we hear about how oh this vicious kick
that
if you watch it live do not seem to make
much contact
it's fun I'm 180 degrees that is Kyle
tracking him with the Gun and shooting
at him he's moving as he's moving that
is not the force of the kick and the
video makes that clear
but again we're grasping at straws and
we're throwing out red herrings
and now a skateboard is a deadly weapon
someone should tell all the parents and
grandparents and Santa Claus
giving skateboards this Christmas
about how they're giving their children
a deadly weapon
I guess they should get him an AR-15
instead
it's just preposterous
and yes Mr Huber was acting heroic in
holding down that and taking that
skateboard and trying to hold him down
and trying to take that gun
and what happened
the gun stayed attached to Mr
Rittenhouse
because when the defense concocted this
they were trying to take my gun story
they left out that it is literally
strapped to him
he shot an honored Man four times
because he was so scared
that Mr Rosenbaum was going to take the
gun away from him when it was attached
to him
is an absolute red herring it is an
absolute ridiculous argument
imminent
threat
not oh in five minutes after we we get
beat up then I might be a threat
imminent threat
you've heard all the videos I'm not
going to go into it any more great
length but
when you listen to the crowd as Mr
Rittenhouse is running they start
running they start yelling Afters he's
running when they're streaming get him
also
as people are approaching him at the end
they're asking why did you shoot him why
did you shoot him
these are people that were provoked
because they witnessed
an attack or heard shots or heard he was
attacking
and they took action
as Mr Binger said I probably wouldn't do
it either
but that they did it is Brave
and they did not deserve to be killed
Kyle Rittenhouse is a strong tie as the
Kenosha but he needs Google Maps to find
a business he says he's driven by every
day
he supposedly knows Kenosha so well and
is such a familiar with Kenosha that he
doesn't realize you can walk one block
either way to get back to the car source
he didn't want to go back to the car
Source he wanted to go see what was
going on
he wanted to stay in the action
he wanted to continue to do things that
would make him feel big and make him
feel important
minor injuries we've heard the defendant
have
again
Mr Richards misstated
the standard
it is not could have caused Great bodily
harm or death
it is not likely to have caused Great
bodily harm or death
it is imminent threat
of death or great bodily harm
where is that when you get a couple
scrapes
everybody takes the beating sometimes
right sometimes you get in a scuffle and
maybe you do get hurt a little bit
that doesn't mean you get to start
plugging people with your Full Metal
Jacket AR-15 rounds and no bullets are
not bullets
and we heard testimony about that
Mr Richards mentioned this in opening
but apparently he's noticed that the
evidence doesn't bear it out he talks
about this
how Mr Rosenbaum put this
shirt over his head to hide his identity
because he's going to go Ambush Kyle
Rittenhouse well then obviously watch
the videos he's had that shirt in his
head for some time
whether it's covet this is all
pre-vaccine As We Know
whether it's tear gas whether it's fire
whatever it is he's using to protect his
face not as some evil plan to get Kyle
Rittenhouse
they're setting this fire and they begin
walking down Sheridan there's no
evidence that they knew he was coming
there's no evidence that they had a plan
to get him
I'd submit to you that the zaminski's
and Mr Rosenbaum were doing what they
were doing all night they were going to
go bash that Duramax or starter Stoke a
fire
Kyle sees this and then he runs onto the
scene that's clear in the FBI video he
runs on to the scene
he puts down the fire extinguisher he
raises up his gun
Mr Rosenbaum yells gun gun gun why else
would he yell that
it's very possible that while he was
yelling friendly friendly friendly he's
doing so while holding a load at AR-15
at the zaminski's
Mr Rosenbaum was going to chase him out
of there to end the danger
and Mr Richards boasts that you know
something lines you won't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] well Mr Rosenbaum was wrong
oh that's
that that's an attaboy right there way
to kill someone unarmed because you
won't
engage them
he raises the gun he provokes the attack
he has to retreat he has to exhaust all
remedies
before he can use before he regains the
right to even use self-defense not even
to use deadly force that's a whole other
separate question he does regain the new
spiritual defense if he exhausts all
options he does not he could have ran a
different way he could have fought he
had all sorts of different ways to
exhaust his options he did not do it as
I said in the beginning of my closing I
don't think you even need provocation
an unarmed man chasing you and you shoot
him four times as he's falling kill and
you kill him as he's falling in front of
you
because you don't want to physically
defend yourself
that's first we Reckless homicide right
there and Mr
Richards kind of plays games with the
name Reckless Reckless means not
intentional in this circumstance and you
can read the jury instructions you can
come to your own conclusions
and she fired an AR-15 in any
circumstance like this shows utter
disregard for human life
there's no other explanation for it if
you're shooting an AR-15 a close range
of people you have no disregard for
human life
that's not really in any dispute
I want to leave you with this
the meaning of Reasonable Doubt
I'm going to read portions of this
instruction obviously you'll have the
whole instruction
the term Reasonable Doubt means a doubt
based upon reason and Common Sense
it is a doubt for which a reason can be
given
A Reasonable Doubt is not a doubt which
is based on mere guesswork or
speculation
that's what the defense is asking you to
do to guess what Mr Rosenbaum is doing
to speculate Mr Rosenbaum was doing to
speculate and guess what Mr Huber and
this unidentified man were doing
we don't know because he killed two of
them
all we can look at is the evidence and
see him standing pretty much straight up
or exactly straight up when he was shot
in the hip and immobilized
a dealt which arises merely from
sympathy or from Fear to return a
verdictive guilt Is Not A Reasonable
Doubt
the defense's whole case has been trying
to stoke sympathy for Mr Rittenhouse and
showing how everyone else was just a
terrible person
every life counts every life matters
if people did bad things that night they
could have been prosecuted
it's not up for Mr Rittenhouse to be the
judge of the jury and eventually the
Executioner
A Reasonable Doubt is not a doubt such
as may be used to escape the
responsibility of a decision
folks I'm back the Casey Simpson live
stream was great what did I miss we all
know that we all knew that from the day
we walked in on November 1st
but this verdict should be about what
the facts are
and what Mr Rittenhouse did
that's what the 12 of you who go to
deliberate
will go and decide
you are the fact Finders
you decide what is beyond a reasonable
doubt you decide what he is guilty or
not guilty of from this menu of options
that you now have
an imminent threat
the only imminent threat that night
was Mr Rittenhouse
he was not acting in legal Justified
self-defense
he's guilty
thank you
Mr Krause
members of the jury the time has now
come when the Great burden of reaching a
just fair and conscientious decision in
this case will be placed wholly with you
jurors selected for this most important
duty it will not be swayed by sympathy
passion Prejudice or political beliefs
you will disregard any impression which
you may have regarding what you believe
to be my opinions on the guilt or
innocence of the defendant
he will disregard the claims or opinions
of any other person or news media or
social networking site you will pay no
heed to the opinions of anyone even the
president of the United States or the
president before him wow
the founders of our country gave you and
you alone the power and the duty to
decide this case based solely on the
evidence presented in this court you
will fearlessly keep Faith with those
who have entrusted to you the fair
rendition of justice and the protection
of our freedom you will be very careful
and deliberate in weighing the evidence
I charge you to keep your duties
steadfastly in mind and as Upright
Citizens to return just and true
verdicts
you will decide only whether the
defendant is guilty or not guilty of the
offenses which are charged any
consequences of your verdict our matters
for me alone to decide and must not
affect your deliberations
it will be for you to determine whether
the defendant is guilty or not guilty as
to each of the offenses charged or
submitted you must make a finding as to
each count of the information each count
charges a separate crime and you must
consider each one separately your
verdict for the crime charged in one
count must not affect your verdict on
any other
this is a criminal and not a civil case
and therefore before you can reach a
verdict which may lawfully be received
it must be reached unanimously in a
criminal case all 12 jurors must agree
in order to arrive at a verdict
when you retire to the Jury Room select
one of your members to preside over your
deliberations that presiding jurors vote
is not entitled to any greater weight
than that of any other juror
I am we're going to stop at this point
and uh I'm going to ask that you return
tomorrow I'm going to let you
to take a vote
when you want to start tomorrow
you could choose eight you can choose 8
30 you can choose nine
um how many would be in favor of
starting at 8 30.
how many you want to start at nah at uh
I missed eight didn't I
um how many still want to start a date
how many would like to start at nine
all right that's the clear consensus oh
it's not consensus but clear plurality
probably majority I think and uh by the
way how are the calzones as we have been
uh
the case is ready for a decision by a
jury of 12. we don't have that
uh and if so it's a
just as important as ever
I'd say more so except that it was
always important that you not discuss
the case with anyone
uh and you won't have to resist that
much longer now because you'll be able
to decide the case
um
please don't read watch your listen to
any account of the trial or anything to
do with the trial
and
um
tomorrow morning we'll assemble and uh
as I indicated earlier the Tumblr over
there will be used all of your numbers
will be placed in there that'll be
really interesting and uh
assuming they're still
and
um those persons will be
held in reserve
I will not join the 12 in deliberation
um we're going to retain you here at in
the building oh boy those of you who are
that'll be fun
selected
uh we'll stay here in the building and
um brutal brutal in the event that your
services are needed as we
and uh the 12 of you who are the jury
selected will
commence your deliberations at that
point so is there any chance these
people weren't looking up news coverage
of the of the trial every single day
question
so the jury will exit this is the end of
the Kyle Rittenhouse trial tomorrow they
will use a tumbler to extricate six of
the 18 jurors to leave a 12-person panel
to actually deliberate the other six are
alternates if there's a problem with one
of the twelve or it's conceivable that
attorneys will say we don't want this
person I believe there is another
opportunity to strike and strike and
strike tomorrow strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike yeah
um so I'll probably cover that and then
the the deliberations will begin
and then we will be on verdict watch we
don't know how long it will be could be
minutes could be hours could be you know
we don't know
um now judging from how much coughing
there's been throughout the trial in the
courtroom it wouldn't be a shock if
someone had coveted and whether that
will wreak havoc on the verdict we just
don't know I want to say thanks to
oh all right see you tomorrow be here
you be here for the obviously you're
going to want to be here and you better
be uh nine o'clock tomorrow morning
I sent them to you uh electronically
yeah about 2 45 I think okay if they
don't get it if you didn't get them I
had some trouble with your email
yesterday but I think I got it resolved
I hope I did if not let me know
all right thanks to Michael Duckworth
for subscribing on my website you are
number 74 and lastly today Coco Sutter
made a pledge on patreon those count
double and that puts us at 76 not a
Shabby day uh for sure
um that's going to conclude our coverage
for today oh and we will be back here
tomorrow with the final jury striking